n n n
[Music]
n
yo move move move the
crowd yeah it is the
day mic check mic check mic check Dr how
we
doing know yourself there nothing I
can't solve 360° I revolve an actual
fact it's not an act it's been proven
indeed I proceed to make the crowd keep
moving I'm in a good
mood what's going
on shout out to the god Rock
cam what's going on levels are good mhm
line has been held I see y'all I see
y'all Y mad shout outs today yeah King
rested King is
rested oh man let me get some early
shout outs man what's going on East
Texas Alex what's going on Gerald M the
OG Zack Riley Bots what's going on M
hole what's going on puny all right damn
I got super chat I got cut off I got to
see if I can get that hold on let's see
if I can get
that let's get that super chat all right
shout out to the
Outlaws Tupac in him L bronze what's
going on Star Killer what's going on $5
Super Chat congrats to saela Phil
Spencer Sarah B Brad Smith and all the
Microsoft Xbox and ab ABK teams who help
bring ABK to Xbox green check yeah yeah
a lot of work a lot of work Star Killer
again follow super chat now that ABK has
been approved what will Microsoft show
at the VGA in December looking forward
to Spider-Man 2 and also cocoon and FM
no doubt I'm assuming that's Forza
Motorsport no doubt Adidas 20 4 months
yeah yeah yeah you know what it is this
is the time Jal M the OG $5 super is it
possible that Candy Crush as well as
Call of Duty on top of Game Pass are all
used to fund Xbox first person over this
ooh you speaking my language OG yeah
people don't realize a lot of those
games that we we laugh at or don't care
about be them candy crushes to
Minecrafts and yo they be funding stuff
you'll be surprised what games actually
produc like so much yay if they can take
one of them make it just one for me you
know I'm with it Sith Lord what's going
on $2 Super Chat General King he held
the line what are your new order sit
tight the king will come all right so we
got we got the super chats take care
everything is good let's get some more
shout outs then 10 Dawn otaco what up
what up yeah yeah yeah I see y'all I see
y'all and we got it's Timmy no doubt oh
my man hand Solo in there I a forget you
brother I see you in there no doubt we
got got to get lined up I just got to
got to get myself to together I got to
get my life in order I got to stay out
the hospital there so much stuff going
on no doubt popn strange oh man that
Strange Love in there be
careful David cin what's going on going
on y'all rnf B Bingham what's going on
aquanale David Talbert what's up you
know what I'm saying father Gucci
Wolverine no doubt what going on F y'all
in here early I see young what up I see
you scoty what's going on geek the sneak
I like that I like that that's going to
be my man geek to sneak gam advice
what's going on 469 what's up so y'all
know what it is man we here we have long
awaited this moment King is rested Mo
you know what I'm saying but yeah it's
going to be a fun show fun show
hopefully we can get everybody up in
here addicts in the round see if unmute
his mic give his M check right quick
yeah to do M it yeah he's good he's got
a new shirt on one of them new fly
shirts what shirt is that
man what's what's that oh that's the
tackl on Titan
but that's
the he's killing it with the shirt game
lately no doubt your boy ready for the
smoke geek sneak done became a lord yeah
yeah I like that I like that big bad Mo
what's up yeah K going to be coming
through we going to get Tom Warren up in
there I don't know about jez cuz jez may
have something going on he just hit but
we'll see and then uh yeah we got some
uh some lines to be held and things to
talk about you know what I'm saying this
day it's funny a lot of people thought
this day would never happen so we are
here but anyway let me stop rambling the
king will be here soon to get us
demonetized I don't want his music to
come in here mess us up see y'all in a
minute here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being a accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original yall to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting and range you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless back when
was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but still by Coastal I got
let's switch that what did you do don't
stop that was dope keep that keep that
keep that going keep that going go ahead
look I guess you could say that I'm very
spoil them to be your dogs they very
loyal but I ain't going to hold you I
ain't heard the boy you ain't got to say
it I'm embarrassed for you always been a
nerd never been a loser making Vault
Tron with a gang of cougar and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a canable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's Saron up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM you got check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm antisocial
love my city but I'm still by Coastal I
got let's switch that up what you do
Don't Stop N that was dope keep that
keep that keep that going keep that
going n Go ahead look I guess you could
say that I'm very spoal feel to be your
dog thing very loyal but I ain't going
to hold you I ain't heard the boy you
you ain't got to say it I'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making vult Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y' to messed up and turn me to
an animal and heades be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a canable and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
the song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's arsing up in apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
and range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest started
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by Coastal I got let's
Swit what you do don't stop that was
dope keep that keep that keep that going
keep that going n Go ahead look I guess
you can say that I'm very spoil feel
them to be your dog they very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making V trying with
a gang of cougar and I'm going places
better tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard
to sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get the show started so
um look y'all to messed up and turn me
to an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm bet
and money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's sing up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
the range you just a Target when I'm in
the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
on AIM check my vocals all on Twitter
but I'm anal love my city but I'm still
I
[Music]
got keep that keep that going keep that
going no go ahead look I guess you can
say that I'm very spoal them to be your
dogs they very loyal but I ain't going
to hold you I ain't heard the boyal you
ain't got to said I'm embarrassed for
you always been a nerd never been a
loser making Vault Tron with a gang of
cougars and I'm going places better tell
a Uber cuz it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we about to get started I am well
it's not important who I am um what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speak and uh I guess I'm here to keep
you entertained until it's time to get
this show started so um
damn look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the Snapple and making it flammable this
is that this is that Yoga Fire Flame
they think it's up in the apartment they
call a department and I get the blame
still I'll be running collecting and
rign you just a Target when I'm in the
range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on a check my vocal all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still coal I got let's Swit that
what you do don't stop that was dope
keep that keep that keep that going keep
that going n Go ahead look I guess you
can say that I'm very spoiled feel to be
your dog thing very loyal but I ain't
going to hold you I ain't heard the boy
you you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser I'm making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until till it's
time to get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and head be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being account accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddy and Jason I rather be hanal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that yog fire this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they they It's s up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them R you just a Target when
I'm in the range I was the hardest to
start regardless back we was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still by coal I got's Swit what
you do stop thate keep keep that going
keep that going no go ahead look I guess
you could say that I'm very spoil feel
them to be your dogs they very loyal but
I ain't going to hold you I ain't heard
the boy you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making Vault Tron
with a gang of cougars and I'm going
places better tell a uber cuz it's
pretty hard to sleep on Freddy krga
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am U
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so
um look y'all messed up and turn me to
an animal and heads be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I rather be Hannibal
they be like why use a video game just
be original y'all to Dramatical I know
it's random but I am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's sing up in
the apartment they call it apartment and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting and range you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless back when you was
messaging people on AIM check my VOC on
Twitter but I'm antisocial love my city
but I'm still I got let's
Swit stop that was dope keep that keep
that keep that going keep that going n
Go ahead look I guess you could say that
I'm very to be your dog thing very loyal
but I ain't going to hold you I ain't he
the bo you ain't got to say it I'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making V Tron with a
ganger cgas and I'm going places better
tell a uber cuz it's pretty hard to
sleep on Freddy kruer
that's let's do that
again here you here you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am um
what's important is that that you are
pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speak and uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so
um look y messed up and turn me to an
animal and heads be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being oh yeah
yeah
yeah D this PR call Proclaim both loud
and clear a proclamation of invitation
turn not on
me I C
the near the river St Lawrence with a
through
and I'mma just chill and watch them many
snacks in the attic I wanted to chill
with the pack and be like a young whoop
but then they will mistake me for adct
if I can imagine it's cool to give you
some advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cuz if you don't give with that
option you going to be single player
like sere you going to get tossed in the
bushes by King David royalty and not a
pretender detrimental to a Elemental
what a avatar to a KN Bender I got to be
me though I know it's my destiny worko
who cares if you fly if you still a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really be steo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that dud King
never still be the king of the statu
since a juvenile I've been cursed the
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
that it's cool and it's beautiful we let
you know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's
day if you got work on a Sunday it's
suitable cuz you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the Lord's
[Music]
Day
yeah yeah yeah yeah M check M check
let's talk to S right quick I got you
got you cut off S it's weird I know I'm
good did you hear me am I good yeah
you're good you're good I had you cut
off in the thing for some reason adct
let's talk to the people right quick
might check what's going on guys we have
a a crazy show for you guys man you guys
got no ideal man we got no ideal yeah
one day we going to get him to say I did
right one day one day I at at this point
it's at this point it's just
fun okay get a mic check right quick man
how are you today even though I can't
hear myself this is the worst bro can we
address this so what happened this is
the wor oh you got to hear this you got
to hear this this this man this is the
way his setup is he puts it through the
Pod track so you know like the Pod track
is like a professional studio and he has
the setting on where he's monitor
monitoring himself right so this entire
time he's been hearing the the Reverb of
his voice behind he thinks that's normal
so now we like that's not how it
normally goes and you just plug it into
the source all you do is talk you hear
everybody that's it so the fact that he
can't hear his his glorious voice is
upsetting him you know what makes it
worse you know what makes it you know
what makes it worse he's been hearing
the nonsense he be
saying no and that's the best part about
it like this right here this is
unnatural to me I really I'm not going
to lie I don't know I might have
performance issues
today is Honestly though that is kind of
that's the professional way of doing it
so you know that everything's coming
through
correctly but at the same time I rather
just do that once in the beginning to
make sure it's tight and then the rest
of it go with God you know what I mean I
don't want to hear myself the whole time
no I see I like to hear myself I'm sorry
we know this wew but this is all I
learned you know what's funny I had I
was on a a podcast I I don't know how he
wants to be pronounced his name it was
the the the Japanese IND I talk about
yeah and uh like gishi or something I
forgot JY so the whole time you I did
the whole podcast he posted it up and I
was peing the whole video and I was like
and he did a test I was like why didn't
he tell me like don't you see so I would
know if I was peeking but now I can't
now other people got to tell me heo King
you're peeking or you man y Dallas in
the chat with boys he said he he has to
monitor his voice too he feels King he
said his we he agrees with King so y'all
professional studio you know what I'm
saying this man
MC anyway this yo it feels disgusting
introducing anyway here ye hear ye and
we are finally live welcome to the ey
Lords podcast LLC and also live on Lords
of gaming.net episode number 326 it's
another glorious Sunday we're back at
the round table on the Lord day and
today we've got the Microsoft ABK deal
approved by UK regulators and now
officially joining Xbox game studos we
we made it Lawrence the line has been
held we made it for the long you know
how many times I've had that topic
inside yeah oh funny it's been there for
a while it's been there for a while Sal
Salo
no doubt then we got Lords of the Fallen
issues and Roblox on Playstation to
discuss so we be Roblox yeah we got to
call it
Roblox got
be
Roblox out of control on Playstation
straight from Canada news so we are
going to get right into it so let's
introduce the four horsman of gaming
those original gaming nights of the
realm here at the round table my co-host
the coost my brother from another mother
the difficult game conqueror Lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
my man Lord addict back to back spit in
the
chair I had to do it man cuz it's the
ABK thing I had to do it it's the only
time you ever get me to do that live
realize how Tes I got to do I got to
spin this chair like for 30 minutes spin
the block bro spin the block he's not a
he's not a spinner like
that I'm not a spin give it give it give
it the block back to back one more time
I can't can't because of the this the
wire oh the wire the wire we W lose the
wire hold me hold it up like I'm
Cinderella ballerina at it chill chill
chill n n n Ain no baller look what we
done did look we done have a have a
little perette let's get perette my man
Twisted all crazy anyway you did that
too how you going to tell him turn
around I I was the Catalyst you should
people on my chat on uh when I make
videos they're like oh uh now since we
got the the spin we cuz I I started
doing like the clap thing now that's not
good enough they want to spin the clap
now they want a thigh slap and I'm like
I got to be getting some of Alex's fans
got you get you get a whole routine now
man into something special over there
you clapping and
doing SL nah buddy anyway what you been
playing what's going on man I've been
playing a lot of payday 3 really okay
like I I actually you know obviously
the yo Tom Alex say yo get out of my leg
you doing spinning you doing thigh claps
yeah bro you Fring on his face to be
fair Alex I don't give them the thigh
slaps like you do all
right thigh slap I ain't going to lie to
you Alex I was watching your stream
yesterday and you a genius this man if
if someone donates a $50 super he takes
his shirt off oh wow oh yeah I saw
nipples out one day I did see nipp out
listen he be out there full
pepperonis
playing shout up to Alex what don't you
playing so L play day three man like I I
can H say that that game came out like
the servers I think it was that game
pass effect I think you know you gave
all these individuals access to the game
they just they just lost their mind and
for the few first few days it just it
didn't work that well it's was like a
good almost a week but now like I'm
playing that like couple hours a a day
at this point like wow it's just cuz
they they have they've opened it on so
many levels that the second one wasn't
on cuz I ain't gonna lie to you okay
Chad now now n what don't look past me
when I say this I I was playing Payday 2
back in the day and I was quick
matching and I was like level three or
four and I got into
a glitched Lobby where they were maxing
their rank
out within 10 minutes I was I was max
level oh I never played it after that
because I had nothing to work for oh you
had everything you had everything you
had the hustle group okay but pay payday
three it's it's a good thing man it's in
Game Pass yeah you know go there play
that it's it's a fun experience I I do
recommend Game Pass it's it's fun I I
think that you know the I feel like they
did more
more more options for you to do Stu
stealth like like I didn't realize that
in order to get
people sound wild order get people on
their
knees you got got you got you got to
hold your firearm up to them and hit
them and they'll fall and then you you
tie them up and
then where is it going when the cops
show knees TI them up let's say you get
caught you you you getting some um some
hostages when the cops show up they're
like if you give us one hostage we won't
come in for a minute like I'm like so
I'm sitting there I got like a whole
room full of people okay you want five
one two three four five go out there and
you have to do that like as long as you
can because the moment the they they
come in crazy yeah they come in crazy
like the um so it's like a negotiating
tactic is what you said with them cuz
yeah I've seen like they got the snipers
on the roof the helicop I've seen it
when cuz I did the beta when it gets
crazy and they they full force on on
with the cops and stuff like that nah
this this game sounds like it's grooming
y'all to do
things this is a grooming game so I I I
do think that the best thing is they
really evolved the payday formula from
Payday 2 to three and you know obviously
I've been I played some Lords of the
Fallen last night we'll sa that what did
you play on top played on the Xbox oh oh
man yeah they I I had the option of
getting the other ones but I I wanted
the one I want to play on the plat line
you the line yeah
I God bless this the sad part when comes
to Lord with the Fallen such a good game
but we'll go into that no doubt and of
course we have the most tactical gaming
Lord the solo gamer lives for the single
player selfish experience and also the
sadis the Lord of clarity and Lord
patreon of the iron bank PC Master
Race's own show us your build Lord
Sovereign how we doing what's good
what's going on so today is the day of
celebration for for
some for some some this is not a day for
them let me say let me say this nobody
celebrate today damn it nobody celebra
today damn it let's let us never forget
oh we gotta forget what we doing let us
never forget what the Genesis of this me
I'm the Genesis of
this
we got people coming on the show talking
about n i was no you
weren't they wasn't official with it s
they wasn't official that us never
forget that my compatriots on this show
yes fact all frauded fact before they
held the line I did laugh you out the r
IIT I admit so no one celebrates until I
say so
D so I'm talking I can't even be mad he
was the only one to correctly predict
that y i I had to go back I yo was a
long time ago bro it was it was 20 it
was the Jimmy champagne episode oh it
was the Jimmy you know what's
funny one only like out of this world
like uh prediction and it comes true bro
the only other a world prediction I ever
made was that they were going to bring
back padra Dragon Saga as scalebound and
I still holding on for that n you killed
bro n this podcast be doing things bro
know s s you got to do me a favor you
got to say Microsoft spy Sega yeah yeah
put that into existence go ahead let's
do
that at the at the expense of my knees I
will say that though Microsoft will
enter into some sort of agreement yes an
agreement a partnership yes some
partnership or a purchase let's put both
out there you know let's not not close
let's not close off close here give your
prediction of Wiggle a little broad you
know broadness here yeah something is
going to happen and it's going to be
Xbox related let's let's say that let's
say
that me now call me
now you heard it here first Cleo s Cleo
Xbox buy and Sega confirmed but but I
have been playing get my amking murder
on with playing some Mirage curious how
you feeling playing more Mirage feeling
how you feeling Mirage so this is the
thing I don't like when you say tell
yeah you know it's bad when you say that
I know that bad you know I am like you
can tell that this evolved from a DLC
right you can tell that it was you you
could tell that it was something smaller
and they were like you know what just
blow it out into this bigger thing um so
back out yeah back out back
out um time he be extra because even
like in some it's it goes back to the
Simplicity of
ac2 it BR all that the Etso Trilogy and
even the first game it goes back to that
level of Simplicity and although I go
back to that and I what I love most
about that is the protagonist mostly
which is Etso I'm a big Etso fan right
the game play for its time was Leaps and
Bounds over kind of what you expected
especially when you jump from one to two
and then two to that that whole trilogy
of Etso they added extra things to make
the game feel more puzzle like in terms
of uh you know uh the traversal stuff in
terms of the combat they made this fluid
combat that was it was cool to see but
it was very easy all around it was just
about countering and they went back to
that and what I realize is that part is
nostalgic for me because of the
character not so much because of the
gameplay when I go back to the game play
I'm like this is cool this is simple but
it's still a little bit clumsy so what I
hearken back to for game play that I
really want him to go back to is Unity
that's yeah that's what adct said yeah
Unity you Unity when it came out was a
train w they they were doing too much
they were doing too much and it wasn't
ready and it wasn't ready now when they
fixed that
game and and now it's running 60 on
console and everything like that so go
back to it if you want to see the
fluidity of movement of parore the
fluidity of going from movement to
combat is the Evol true evolution of
that original formula in a way that a
lot of people just dismiss because they
they Overlook it because oh it was trash
when it came out everybody was playing
Rogue instead remember Rogue came out at
the same time right yeah yeah Rogue came
out on past gen if you see a par cor run
in unity today and you compare it to
what you could do in Mirage sick it's
it's kind of I'm not going to say
comical it's not comical the fluidity of
that character in unity which Arno right
Arno is the Assassin dude he can like
first of all there's animations for
climbing and descending full-on
animations for everything so isn't like
you just dropping down from a
leged they're created animations for
everything there's a dive animation you
can dive from a high point to a lower
point and grab onto it out kind of out
out of Spider-Man a little bit and hang
and and and you can dive to a lower
point and and then go from there and
continue your Parkour in a way that's
very like I would say Spider-Man or even
Daredevil like it is it's so fluid and
they built it for that and then they
kind of went away from it cuz even
Syndicate which was the the subsequent
game did some different things with
traversal that didn't feel as smooth as
Unity Unity was a special game it just
it it didn't come out at the proper time
well it didn't come out in the right in
in the right sort of yeah it was just
the technical issues hon it was
technical issues right the multiplayer
stuff is still is very cool as well that
also got looked over again because of
the technical issues of the game so I
hearken back to that when I play maras
I'm like I wanted this this is this is
the step up that I wanted and then some
right then take some of the that you
learned from the RPG ones and
Incorporated in that and they didn't do
that I'm enjoying it uh Baghdad is a
very is a beautiful city it's
beautifully realized in the game um but
it's it is very simple the skill tree is
very limited yeah old school just like
you want the old mixtape you got the old
mixtape exactly how it is the old mix
this is a restart so you're going to get
the and the next one is going to be more
stuff my hope is that right but I'm like
okay I get I get that but I'm like you
have this stuff y already did right but
I think what it is it's not you didn't
do it before right you're right and I've
had this discussion with Maddy I've had
discussion with Todd I think what it is
is they wanted to play it safe because
they know people do not like any of the
the New Direction where it went more
action Focus so they like look we going
to get them what they want and I think
they went too safe to your point the
thing is though is I do feel like their
mindset was if they wanted that formula
they would play the other games right
and I I do agree that they should have
it's like all right you know because I
feel like the the newer games got away
from the stealth elements they should
have put more stealth elements in this
game right yeah but I do think at some
point we already to the point where you
get caught you dead they didn't want to
make that worse yeah yeah so in this you
get caught you're not dead cuz once you
start you get that Parry down it's a now
you you have to really be cognizant of
the fact that everybody in the in the
vicinity is coming after you coming so
they they're going to be they're going
to be on your back they're going to be
on on your they're going to be all over
the place so the what I will say is that
I I am enjoying it bosom does kind of
seem like a wet rag um in this and again
I I never finished uh I never finished
Valhalla so I don't I know some crazy
stuff happens with him right but it
doesn't seem like this is going to point
towards that as much as it is a straight
like this is his origin story this is
that um but I I to me it's just I hope
what king says is true where they they
they say okay we're going to give you
the full full on restart and we're going
to give you the most basic stuff cuz
they yo that AI is dumb as dirt dude I
will go I will go into a hay stack in
the middle of like an area that they're
all occupying and I would just whistle
from the hay stack and they will all
make their way to me and that's going
what could that be oh my God and get
stabbed in the neck I'm like I just want
to know damn it what King's doing so
long yeah we got get K his K cameras off
I don't know what's going we got to get
I'm giving him I'm bustering I'm F of
bustering
I'm listening I'm listening it's it's
dope
listen that's that is it that's play
Mirage cuz that that's you know that's
um that's comfort food so that's your
that's your series I realize how much
that is your series I love that series
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka the EXs gamer ooh the
prophet of Xbox Swami King of the
statues who demands nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the whole theine movement o beloved
Lord G how are we doing sir I'm doing
fantastic I know a lot of dudes on uh
this past
Friday was traumatized and I'm here to
bring you more
traumatization
we we will be hunting you
down Jason X
Jason Friday the 13th you go play Jason
got Jason in face is in the building I
told you I was going to be a horror
movie for you f Dominus Maximus a really
spiss ass made it a reality Friday the
13th is your ban oh my God y'all knew
this day was coming okay and now we will
no longer hold the line we will ADV
that's the line oh we advancing we got
them on the ropes oh it is time people
no more game playing it's on
now I told y'all this ABK deal was going
to go through the queen has gave a
marching orders she wanted us through
Advance season so right now we will
continue to push the boot down there but
at the same time in the month of October
shober we will hunt them
down we will I ain't done nothing wrong
and I feel and I feel like I need to
hide yeah this is really intimidating
right now I don't know what to do
because it's like you know the fact that
this happened on Friday the 13th this
man is in this get up is it's wild right
now it's wild man I got him I got on the
dicky suit it's
all you know what's funny always refer
to D his community is the second line
with the arrows you know the people that
sit in the back and just snipe people
with arrows yo shout out to gravic go he
killed that Advance the alive bro oh my
Lord that is ill right there that's
hilarious that's the explosion I like
the explosion that's what I boom it
sound like it sound like they getting
bombed like it's a air strike you know
listen to the sound it's crazy what it
is they're they're Ground Dwellers so we
must blow them out of their
buers you got the want to run K you got
the want to run they they right now I
haven't seen them have yall seen them
haven't seen the spaces haven't seen no
face you a see the but I was told it was
definitively going to get blocked I was
told there was no chance this thing
would go through yeah they listen to me
though all these cats out here I see
dudes outside wear Xbox shirts talking
about yeah baby right about now
baby doing it up baby ain't no such SIDS
now
we got you now all the receipts and all
you fake Xbox dudes is I knew it was
going to go through no you
didn't but but dudes can't celebrate now
that that the smoke is clear everything
is clear we know who ain't dancing right
who ain't really celebrating that's the
dude that was giving out the information
I think over
there y the real dudes know who the real
people are and those fake dudes we will
continue to put the boot on your neck
but right now all Sony dudes y'all gotta
hold the line oh they got to hold the
line why they got to hold the line it is
on their throat pause right now Game
Pass is on fire right now and the deal
went through remember all this happened
to you guys without the deal going
through it's a WAP for y'all now oh man
Phil Dominus Maximus AIA Spencer said
this is just begun and Friday the 13th
it was Monumental so in that vein I had
to come through as the best whoever did
it je forhe doing the four and I'm going
to be hunting y'all for the rest of the
month oh okay so let me tell y'all we
have a video game giveaway and how I'm
going to give the game away is a little
bit different shout out to Champa poppy
who gave the game now this is how I know
you got the game for every topic I'm
going to give out those five digits to
go to the code so you have to watch the
whole show in order to get the game all
right so it ain't GNA be none of that I
drop it in
there got the scoop it up that's right
so I'm going to give out the first five
digits it's y 6 G
D3 okay that's
Y6 G
D3 and I'm going to give it out the next
ones at the next topic and so on so you
will have to watch the show in order to
get this game this is champagne poppy
who gave this up slute to Drake We
exactly Shake Drake out here with the I
we got the connection y'all champagne
super like his name is champagne poy
though but yeah Champagne Supernova but
I want y'all to know like when we we was
talking about how to give it away and
you know he spent his money on this so I
was like let me get the best way to give
it so not no you knowbody just go in
there and grab it up and and they got
the game just earned to watch the show
for it he super supports so also a lot
of you guys want to know why I didn't do
General King yeah they was like what
happened um right now there's Wars going
on right now and it doesn't feel
appropriate for me to uh do a general
during the time of war and people are
suffering so again I wanted to make it
something comical some Friday the 13th
joint and and we're going to go with
that all right even though the hold the
line thing has some connotations to that
I don't want it to be associated with
that so my heart and and my my love goes
out to everybody who has lost somebody
on either side I'm not picking a side
I'm just saying that war isn't good for
anyone so I didn't want to um promote
War brother love you that's what's up so
besides hunting um what I've been
playing people down besides what have
you been playing oh um you'll be
surprised I've been playing PlayStation
VR2 uh today I'm going to um put on the
call it a beast um put that on I was
playing a whole lot of demos and stuff
that they had in there uh the
PlayStation VR2 is is pretty good I care
I care with you with this B like you out
here trying to have a normal
conversation you want me to switch it up
no leave I me it's just hilarious trying
to try to focus on you when you talking
that you keep it read like two super
chats I had this now this the funniest
thing ever continue yeah let me let me
let me let me switch it up so just read
like two or three super chats real quick
and I'll switch it up I mean I can do my
int
he got more stuff to say he got more
stuff to say I got stuff that I was
playing though you know what let me get
to my stuff get your stuff get to your
stuff all right so um yeah the
PlayStation VI is kind of cheap the the
headset itself it doesn't feel as solid
as the Oculus so he's like I got to get
to this [__] talking first he said let
me say that it's cheap first let me get
that off the yeah the plastic does feel
really cheap the headset itself feels
really cheap the only thing that feels
good in it is the the tech that's inside
like the the resolution and stuff like
that that's it it's really good but
other than that the material and itself
is really cheap so I would love for them
to change how the cushions are in the
front because in the front it doesn't
feel um comforting after a period of
time you just have to take it off
because either the up front yeah yeah it
it doesn't feel I don't know they tried
their best with what they had so I'm not
going to bother them the controllers
feel really small for my big hands uh
but it's it's it's decent um they did
the best for what they what they was
offering so I got no problem with that
um I played uh some from the Stars yeah
no from space is inside Game Pass right
now it's a little top- down multiplayer
shooter and you you go you have this
like it's in hoorde mode so you unlock a
whole bunch of things you in space they
teleport you to a area where there's
aliens and you go around in a circle or
and in in different uh paths to shoot
and kill the aliens and just try to
survive vied around is a real fun game
uh playing fortnite play Mirage and I
was playing a little bit of Forza with
the with the steering wheel it's a um I
have to learn how to dial in the
controls on the steering wheel being
this is the first time I'm using a
steering wheel so it's a little bit
different than playing with a controller
but other than that uh Game Pass has
been fantastic Forza has been amazing
and you know PlayStation VR2 has been
something of a little bit of a surprise
today I'm going to play the premium game
to give everybody the details on what's
up with that no doubt and you already
know we got the gaming and gy himself
the Shinobi Lord kognito spread that
real to the Roman IOP not tell you what
you want to hear but what you need to
hear shout out to Mr M play Shout out to
finding Duke talking some comeback
stories with Xbox shout out to um last
word Travis and Ian just holding me down
I had to miss that episode and then it's
just been a rough week it's been a rough
week but I'm feeling a little better now
and uh we're persevering we're trying to
stay out of hospitals and and get things
done but um as far as me all during that
time Starfield it's been a lot of
Starfield man um still can't stop uh
finishing up all my little side uh
faction Quest I really dug the uh
Freestar Collective I did that did you
end it no I've been in it I'm on new
game plus I've been on new game like
this is New Game Plus oh yo yo you just
scared the hell bro you can't be talking
about did you
yo because cuz if you don't end
it I'm going to have to end
it yo chill I'm not feeling that this
this whole month I want be
stalk this whole kned over for you
that's that's the white that's the
whitest kings ever done oh you see a
couple of PlayStation dudes
yesterday this is in my this is in my
opinion the truly the best that ever did
it I I love
Jason Jason's a zombie Jason's a zombie
I'm a Micha human he's human he's just
my there Michael Myers is the farthest
thing from a
human he's technically human they've
never said he's anything but human yo
that my [__] is crazy I think I think I
think Michael Myers is is a human
possessed by a demon that that's my
personal that's what you're going with
yeah side of King scared me into what I
was playing um yeah just to finish that
a shout out to the like I said the
Freestar Collective I like that ship
they got there it's called the star
Eagle I'm in my ship collecting bag
right now I got a whole bunch of I got
like My my what you call my leadership
skill is dumb high I can have like six
seven people on the crew I've been my
like ship bag so I've been doing that
and then U what else what else what else
oh my stealth bag also I got a crazy
build with the pistol and got my pistol
rank high my stealth rank high so I'm
been doing that and then still been
playing a little bit of Destiny in the
meantime but uh that's been pretty much
it for me so we want to get uh the super
chats or we want to promote some things
want to talk about some things what we
doing let's get the super
chat you you muted something you m it I
was wondering if we're doing that cuz I
don't know that we got that the the the
link came through oh that's true that's
true so you won't wait on that so are we
holding I don't know promote we might as
well just do it yeah we can promote we
can promote oh yeah so let's go let's go
into that first let's go into that let's
go into that so a big big shout out to
our friends and partners at let me see
if you see it no other side other side
you good with the other side you gota go
this
way you see that b there go there you go
our friends Partners at Hayworth wor the
uh chair
manufacturers over there struggling sent
us these lovely what you just did I'm
sorry continue well see the problem is
I'm Too Tall so my head's not over do
what you just did do what you just did
it was hilarious what he cuz he's so
tall it's so funny continue I'm sorry to
interrupt you so no no no it's fine try
to get it the right way so our friends
and partners over at Hayworth that send
us these beautiful uh Xbox chairs uh
that are part of their Fern collection I
believe yes um yeah these are these are
very very very nice uh chairs with
excellent lumbar support very pretty
chairs we will be putting up stuff on
our socials specifically to show you
kind of more of the chairs or whatever
um but yeah shout out to them and shout
out to this partnership with them um
they were just very very generous to uh
get in here and get us all chairs and
these are some
lovely feeling chairs I want to do you
want it I don't even they they're up
there very they're very premium
that the fern the fern you know what I'm
saying um you can go to the website and
we can put that stuff in the chat and
show you what the chair is look at that
King so King you know is it fit for a
king is it is it is it is it is it
premium enough for you I you're person
it's quite Ry quite it's quite it's
quite it's quite Ry my deire my de a
everything de there this this is
fantastic I love this thing is so
premium I want to have like my pinky in
my mouth every
time this this the theand is it is it is
it very corporate car do we get a you
know little glass little wine with it is
very much you know what I like about it
I I I like the gold Xbox logo in the
back joint somebody spend the block and
show them a joint yeah add hold on hold
let me let add spend the block hold on
let me like he like turn it around o
that joint clean that joint clean right
there yeah yeah look at the spine on it
the spine on it is crazy crazy yeah the
spine is crazy so you got that office
feel but like with good ergonomics right
so you can sit in for long hours I mean
compare adct you're the person who
you're the gaming addict so a person who
plays very long gaming sessions and you
don't normally like to play on your by a
PC so for you explain the difference
between that and like the normal kind of
racing chairs You' been gaming chairs
You' been using so how I normally review
games is I will play
in with my computer for probably about
an hour and a half to two and it's just
getting gamep play you know that's all
it really is and like once I feel like I
got enough gameplay normally then I'll
like take my uh Xbox and hook it up in
like my room where I feel a little B
more comfortable or like I'll sit out in
the living room and play it but I can
honestly say I played I finally beat
Persona 5 this this week
and I the only reason that game was able
to be beat the way it was is because I
didn't have to leave this
chair like it what's funny is like this
thing is crazy like you can this is
going to be very like I'm a big person
you're a big dude and I don't feel like
this is just gonna break like oh no it's
definitely not no you're a big dude for
you to be able to do that is is crazy no
salute salute so we wanted to give our
good friends a whole like I said I've
been using it for a while absolutely
love it and again as a person who was
more concerned about back support and
being comfortable for a long as opposed
to the chair being fly you know what I'm
saying and you still after a couple
hours it starts to hurt but n not this
this Jordan is super comfortable I
actually feel when I get up like I'm
more well rested to a degree than I was
with the other chair the other chair cuz
I used to have a a secret lab chair the
Titan secret lab the XL one and and
that's like 800 uh and see it was
comfortable but I did feel like after
sitting it for a certain amount of time
like my back would be stiff yeah you
know uh it it just I don't think it was
designed to sit for long long amounts of
time especially four or five hours well
this this chair is really different
because it has so many different levels
and ways to customize it like even from
the the handrest the handrest you can
pull it up move it to the side it's it's
different ways that you can hold it and
then from the height of the hand to to
to the weight of the chair you can uh
change how far the chair goes in how far
it goes out how it fits your Lum bar I
have it on like I think it's like three
or four for my Lum bar and anytime I
feel my back getting stiff I just put my
head back in the chair and I go like
this and it stretches my back out
perfectly so I can get that perfect
stretch stretch your back
stretch pause PA on
you but but no this is and I love the
the signage all over the place Brandon
is is well known is well seen because
when wifey saw it she was like oh let me
see that and I said go have a seat she
said oh this feels really different and
the biggest thing that we're not saying
is like shout out to them how they they
deliver it to you I'm sure that I'm sure
that that's not cheap because they they
pretty much send it to you that's
probably why the chair is so much
because the shipping alone is
probably pretty penny yeah and like when
you get it like the whole thing is there
but this top part this top part put the
top to put on yeah that's it but yeah so
what we're going to do is like I said
like s said we will get our affiliate
links to you guys probably be you know
in a week or so next by next Sunday we
probably won't do a bit the the Twitter
post get cuz we want everybody you who
seen it you know and then from there
once you you guys are interested we get
the affiliate link get you a little
discount help the laws that kind of
thing and then we'll do some promo but
yeah it's no going back to other Chad
after this apologize I'm apologize to
King too cuz yesterday when I was doing
RNR because I record RNR I I am the the
background voice that what do you call
me on there King the disembodied voice
disembodied voice the voice of God my my
my my like my video isn't on it it's
just my voice yeah and I was I was uh
talking to King he's like man how you
going how you gonna make your new videos
with you the the chair
chair it didn't it didn't hit to me to
that exact moment I was like oh I have
been using that chair yeah he's been
he's been doing the spin with the chair
cuz he I watch his videos and I look and
I was like oh God he's like he he
snitched it he snitching early you know
what's funny there's not one comment out
of probably 6 comments talking about the
chair saw you bro it's all
good anyway we got to get it moving
because we got a lot of stuff in oh yo
also somebody just hit me in the DM yes
the Advan the line shirt is up in the
Teespring store right now right now the
hold the line shirt is only going to be
up there for two weeks we're going to
take that out and the only thing that's
going to be there is going to be the
advance the line shirt so Advance the
line is out there is pinned in the chat
as well at the top of the the chats
right now you can get the link go
straight to the shirt so Advance D you
only got a limited time left for holding
so the fra who wasn't holding You'
better get it now act like yall was not
going to be there long get to hold the
line before it's gone but Advance the
line is just went up the Vance the line
shirt is live right now no doubt and if
you what want to see is the advanced the
line on the hold of the line if if if
people if you guys have both of those
shirts post it on Twitter and I might
send you a game from the iron bank that'
be kind of crazy yeah for I I want to
see the first person to post a picture
of the hold the line and the advance the
line shirt to me on Twitter I will send
you a game from The Vault no doubt no
doubt that's what's up very nice salute
get what you going to send Spider-Man
I don't believe I have Spider-Man I'll
have to to you you a see what I did
right there yeah I see what he did yeah
because it's be PlayStation
dudes no doubt so you want to get the
super chats yeah let's go all right hold
on one second we start out with a let's
put the crest in the chat for Outlaw
2120 welcome to Lord bronze thank you
brother appreciate that Welcome to the
Real then we have Lord Star Killer Xbox
series x01 $5 Super Chat congratulations
to SAI nadela Phil Spencer Sarah Bond
Brad Smith and all of the Microsoft Xbox
and ABK teams who helped bring ABK to
Xbox then we got Lord Star Killer again
$5 super chat now that ABK has been
approved what will Microsoft show at the
VGA in December looking forward to
Spider-Man 2 also enjoying cocoon and FM
what is FM what isport for
for then we got Adidas 20 member for
months Lord bronze yes it's a whole lot
of yes
today then we got the homie Gerald Mack
$5 Super Chat is it possible that Candy
Crush as well as Call of Duty on top of
Game Pass are all used to fund Xbox
first person or first party I'm I'm
assuming over theh shoulder single
player Oh first person or over the
shoulder single player uh that's a yeah
that I mean Candy Crush is the gift that
keeps on giving man that's yep that
Minecraft that's just late that is
literally just passive money coming in
um let me see and we have Sith Lord $2
chat General King we held the line what
are your new orders
[Laughter]
Advance let us put the question in the
chat for the newest member of the realm
geek the sneak shout out to geek the
sneak Lord bronze you that's my man's
geek the
[Laughter]
sneak
yeah there we got n taku $5 for chat
they rumor circulating around so I'm
here to speak on it the rumors are true
I am the one who bought the one and only
Wii U sold in 2023 shout out to you
brother I'm sure Nintendo appreciate
you at full
price then we have a uh piss
squeak Super Chat maybe change that s to
a p but um $2 in chat what up Cog love
everything you do bro
ashop LSM salute LS fam there too salute
yes then we have Nintendo tacu $5 Super
Chat reviews for Mario Wonder ain't even
out yet but we all know that Sonic lost
again as
usual yo you being messy early daily
reminder that Sonic was never good and
never will be Jesus we going in shout
out to we got to get ever to combat
him then we have Doctor Strange Love $5
Super Chat no Bland all Thor today too
bad I wanted to teach them how we
prepare our meat at
ILP my special organic homemade marinade
on his meat wow crazy crazy W
yeah we have Zack Riley $5 Super Chat
Alexa play X go give it to
you
time to
ATL AKA Advance the line somebody just
coped that Advance the line I just see y
lle jump off off the winter okay then we
have brius $5 Super Chat I want an
unhinged King I want to overdose in the
salt so King is Hing all out this time
do it I want the salt salute salute see
another Advanced line t-shirt I see
y'all uh then we have Kell $2 Super Chat
so King is Lords of the Fallen Xbox
version King Ain't play it so it'll be
addict that'll be talking about it but
yeah yeah yeah real
discuss then we have sin Vendetta $10
Super Chat I'm with King it drives me
nuts if I cannot hear myself in the
party chat I don't know
but I never like that man again I guess
the professionals do it that
way then we have lady f box fire $5
Super Chat afternoon to everyone in the
realm what's up Lords and Ladies happy
ABK week # Game Pass looking mighty yes
it is a pass is looking mighty
Thanksgiving is going to be
bananas then we have Fant testicles with
the
five fiveo Super Chat good day Lords
what would be funnier Jim Ryan as the
new CEO of ABK or Bobby cck as the new
CEO of that is
both of them would like be Earth
scorching this is hilarious that would
be dope as
hell then we got Kryptonite Souls $5
Super Chat yo today is the Lord's day
stay blessed everyone and remember to
enjoy gaming no matter where you play
that is correct correct fact the games
are what matter Spider-Man and Mario
coming out on Friday exactly Mario don't
care nothing about what he L he looked
to the side he's like Peter who
me and uh me and King what we're going
to be doing is cuz like we want to do
more like stuff when it comes to us
playing games together that's not
necessarily the community thing I know
we owe you guys a community actually we
owe you a giveaway too but we'll get to
that uh but um you know me and Keem were
going to be doing some like Co-op
playing of Mario wonders cuz I I think
that's Co-op game you can play the whole
game up to like four people
C thinks you know I guess I guess we we
weird King we
playing I didn't say that I have fun
playing that game yeah I didn't say
anything go ahead continue yeah so you
know we will be I'll probably post a
couple of them it will be on the patreon
members I'll post a couple of them for
free on the patreon and then the rest
will uh you know I don't know what tier
we put it behind our dude that you know
helps us with uh the Youtube algorithm
he says putting stuff Stu up like that
isn't isn't good for the isn't good for
the Channel all right no doubt I see the
legendary Tom Warren in in in in the
round how we doing sir we check your
levels make sure they can hear you can
you hear me okay yes yes yes good to
have you good to have you sir thank you
for making it doing good just playing
some bills a couple super chats we going
to get right into
it no DG like thank you for making it
really appreciate you taking the time
yeah no wor no doubt no doubt s let's
get then we have childish B
remember for two months Lord bronze the
streets are silent in hoosville right
now salute to S thank you thank you hash
hold the line yes yes yes no doubt then
we have Craig hooligan who you know
quote unquote gifted one iron Lords
podcast membership we know how Craig
huligan gets down thank you we
appreciate you you know forcing the
people to
to acques and bring bringing them on
board I appreciate that Mr hul again
there we there we have the Hobie K Santi
$5 Super Chat salute to the Lords on
this fine Sunday we had a 5H hour
Preamble celebration yesterday on gcp
looking forward to the 10hour ILP no no
no no no and I have to respect Lord
Tom's time we will
not that man's on time limit we are not
doing that
continue we then we have GE bar Ingy
with the $5 super I in the building if
XBox give 10 Studios an 8year cycle and
the rest of fouryear then we are getting
an average of seven or eight first party
games each year think about that yeah I
mean the if everything goes right which
it never doesn't game that but if it
does the Cadence is going to be kind of
Bonkers uh so that's that's awesome then
we got Doctor Strange
Love be careful King with that mask
looks like he's into some domination
Miss I can help with that and more
kid you don't want to put the mask back
on let's get this let's get a sound
effect K effect no that wasn't that
wasn't worthy of we can do this hey
hey I can't hear it at all back to
you back to you s
hilarious let's put the crest in the
chat for Xbox Xbox South Coast welcome
to Lord bronze thank you appreciate you
m then we have Suicide Kings member for
35 months Lord bronze then we have
Goldberg's music comes on and King comes
out draped with security guard I have
one question King who's next we will
discuss we will discuss we will
discuss then we have just Spartan $10
Super Chat the new Halo season looks
sick the deal is over Cod is exclusive
and after almost two years away at War I
came back to my wife expecting our first
son life is good salute congratulations
yes blessing man C is is an exclusive
but but everything else everything else
is fantastic it's exclusive to Game
Pass then we have Hector the Macho Man
$20 Super Chat all hell the powerful
Lords General King operation pull the
plug on the bangers was
successful you spoke the prophecy and
now it's written into stone now I'm
going to execute the portal as you
requested sir Mao man
out
bless then we have metal marus $5 Super
Chat King don't mess with the steering
wheel settings on Forza the field gets
better as you upgrade your car with
better Tire suspension
Etc right cool keep then we got zip
Davis $5 Super Chat all right Lords I'm
listening with my ski mask on this is a
stickup Now give me my ultimate align to
Gold Edition backwards compat
yes I'm with you zip I'm with
you we got jfx 88 $5 Super Chat I need a
special edition Xbox series X that does
the
Jason when you started up this day must
be remembered okay salute salute then we
got senjutsu Sage hold on I got jumped
wow these guys are really in there today
hope I send you to Sage $5 Super Chat
King is a one piece Celestial Dragon
hunting down place St natives the world
government Annex an island Bard King
Garland it's very
descriptive very descriptive
continue then we have uh King blades put
the Crush in the chat for King blades
Lord bronze thank Welcome to the Real
Welcome to the Real then we got isvan
zadori with the five pound Super Chat
Ready Steady
charge no doubt I see it then we got
Cory Tidwell $5 chat these PlayStation
dudes been acting real sassy since
Friday angry tweeting while laying on
their
stomach what are we doing what are we
doing is the door
open yo whoa moving on moving on paast
paast continues moving on just a couple
more just a couple more there we have
the homie gaming 14 for 46 months Lord
bronze hey King Boo
Boo you're General Us Xbox fans needed
your leadership is contagious and will
win any battle you trust is pause us
into you trust us into Sal salute salute
Forte salute Forte you already know the
homie then we have Robert kellet $2
Super Chat my man Sonic killing it with
superstars I heard Superstars is good oh
it came out it came out already yeah it
wasn't trying
to you got to beat Mario to the punch
you can't be
out that sucks it came out ain't nobody
talking about
it yo oh my God no I thought oh that's
wait you know what I know the reviews
are up maybe it's not out maybe it's not
so maybe not maybe not miss because not
one person Show gameplay nothing
hopefully we'll get we'll get that
information this everb
sa there we have BT Maverick 707 $20
Super Chat oh slute is the ABK deal
closing as sweet as defeating the FTC
Jim Ryan bending the knee and the CMA
crawling back it's been a tremendous
journey and thank you guys for being
well for being well you guys and sharing
your friendship with all of us thank you
much love thank much love then we have
splendiferous member for 20 months Lord
bronze this podcast used to be even with
the attention going around but then Lord
cark started posting pics and tight
shorts everything is about to meet these
pics that I got in
t what's going on here what's going here
oh they they they sound like y want Lord
beefy that's what yall want that's what
they want let's let's give let's give
them Lord beefy real
quick Lord beefy is debuting right now y
go get this what y'all want right y get
in the beef
now salute salute it is up the de salute
the gra they want the beef now you get
the beef you know what I'm saying Dr
strel and um joystick be I know watch
y'all watch y'all cuz I know what y'all
doing yo no no I didn't see
that we're debuting it now we're de this
is a beef cast very beefy now shout out
to graphic gun y those t-shirts is going
inside the store those t-shirts might
not make the store but we going to move
on he think he's
SL get the rest super CH no we're not
moving on no no King King King imagine
we got to respect Lord Tom Warren's time
we imagine imagine one close eating the
beef and the in the back of the shirt
says that's
good
good yo sorry Tom I'm sorry this is the
first time we got a chance to see this
he been hiding
this and he knows that I would have had
it oh Lord Pete yo s yo please make sure
you get Lord beefy inside the T-shirt
Teespring we can push that back a week
right now we we're advancing the line
we're advancing the we're advancing we
pushing
beef you know what's funny I have never
seen that emote till
tonight shout out to graic God shout out
to the inspiration you know what I'm
saying looking like looking like he- man
pumping me that's that's great moving on
let's go we got we got to here we got
things we have to do we have to go on I
wasn't ready
was I love all these
animations to the that's absolutely
crazy then we have then we have the
homie hary chatty $5 Super Chat Xbox
split ABK into three Publishers they
into three Publishers they are or keep
them under Activision would make sense
to split them up they did mention reorgs
it could be see we see yeah we'll see
then we got once again geek the sneak my
Super Chat big wish is that Xbox puts
Lost Odyssey on PC o that would be nice
that' be nice that would be nice you got
geek the sneak and zip with the drip I
love that I love that so we all good we
all caught up hell no but we got more we
got a few more we can hold on it's like
four more four more all right let's
let's hold on because yeah because we
got that and then the Patriot I do have
to respect uh La Tom's time so that's
what we going to do so last week's poll
are not work results are not in and not
people not spoken cuz Co forgot is doing
procedures and stuff so we forgot but we
will take care of that next week but uh
we got to get to it y'all we got to get
to it y know what yall here for all what
always say you know we got to talk about
it you know one of the uh biggest you
know news in gaming you know it pretty
much broke the internet as far as just
in general of the the the stakes and an
inflection in gaming this long process
almost almost over 20 months of you know
the whole ABK thing and uh yeah shout
out to Xbox wire put out the post yeah
welcoming the legendary teams at
Activision Blizzard King to team Xbox so
this broke on Friday the
13th at that which was uh quite uh uh
actually inspired by Lord Tom Warren who
kind of gave us some foreshadowing into
that which was kind of interesting but
uh yeah we got to talk about a couple of
things really quick before we set this
thing up and uh yeah so the Activision
blizard deal was approved by UK
Regulators Microsoft is now free to
finalize its uh 68.7 billion acquisition
and we saw a kind of flurry barrage of
tweets Brad Smith of Microsoft the CMA
Lulu missery of Activision Activision
themselves um and uh finally Phil
Dominus Maximus aelia Spencer he had a
lot to say at reference I'm just going
to read a quick epert of uh what Phil
had to say and uh pretty much say today
is a good day to play we officially
welcome Activision Blizzard King the
team Xbox together will create stories
and experiences that bring players
together in a culture empowering
everyone to do their best work and
celebrate diverse perspectives to the
millions of fans who love Activision
Blizzard and King games we know that you
are the heart and soul of these
franchises and we're honored to have you
as part of our community whether you
play on Xbox PlayStation Nintendo PC or
mobile you're always welcome here even
if Xbox isn't where you play your
favorite franchise because when
everybody plays we win so that also went
out in conjunction to a note that I
wanted to read that uh Phil sent to
Activision uh blizzard King employ
employees you know he's thrilled to
welcome them to teamx boox he goes on to
talk about how um the teams represent
incredible opportunity for them to learn
from each other he though talks about
the skills and talent of all the teams
and then some Keynotes as of today we
couldn't be more excited that Activision
Blizzard employees and our colleagues
co-workers and teammates as mentioned in
Bobby's email earlier we have agreed to
remain he has agreed to remain in his
role through the end of 2023 reporting
directly to me to ensure a smooth and
seamless integration look forward why
you we how you laugh we're looking
forward to working together as a unified
team and we'll share more updates on our
new organizational structure in the
coming months through this integration
we remain committed to being transparent
and sharing information wherever
possible we have a dedicated team
ensuring that you feel welcome have
opportunities to ask questions and that
we're creating a culture of trust
inclusion and collaboration with you to
early today he sent a note to Microsoft
letting the rest of the company know
that they officially welcomed them and
then yeah they said over the coming
weeks he'll be visiting Activision
blizzard and King offices along with the
members of the Xbox leadership team
there we will have the opportunity to
address questions and hear from each
other we also look forward to welcome
you alongside team Xbox at our next
virtual all hands and welcome to team
Xbox it's a good day to play so yeah
this this was out there man a lot of
stuff so actually um King I don't know
if you am I allow am I supposed to let
you get your bars off first you know oh
well um first before anything I got to
give the code so all right this is the
second part of the code for the free
game giveaway that was being given away
from champag poppy uh Champagne
Supernova c c
hx9 that's c c
hx9 all right cool so King I've been
advised with you being the creator of
the hold the line now Advance the line
of movement who uh held the Xbox Matrix
of leadership lit our darkest hour
during the uh the previous FTC the CMA
blocks red fall launch you know well the
the Xbox Autobot faction confidence may
have been broken but Lord King you had
the touch you had the power when all
hell breaking loose you with the eye in
the of the stor this is your moment the
floor is yours the day is here talk to
us now it's just the wildest thing is
that we finally got to this point and
you know you look at all of the people
at Microsoft you look at Sarah Bon you
look at uh Phil you look at uh greeny
you look at all the people that were
publicly Tweeting or that were in the
face of the public not one time did they
give up but I seen a lot of people that
say that support Xbox or they like Xbox
products they were giving up like the
people that actually there fighting in
the trenches with it you know trying to
get it across the line and I'm using
fighting in the trenches proverbial like
a little overarching little uh com the
thread to it um but they're actually
trying to get these deals done they're
not giving up they're not giving up hope
they're keeping hope alive because they
understand that with every given day
that there's opportunity for it to go
forward and there was so much money on
the table what I was trying to explain
to people that it's so much money on the
table they're going to have to
scrutinize the deal on every angle and
everybody wants to get paid that much
money comes through everybody wants to
get paid so you had to wait for
everybody to get paid for this deal to
go through and everybody did get paid at
the end of the day it was a ton of
overtime being pushed through you had
people uh raising their budgets or
trying to get their budgets raised um
because of this deal it was people
trying to extend their careers because
of this deal so until everybody's beat
got wet this deal wasn't going to go
through I just like a couple of things
that Phil made and was trying to
reassure the public about Bobby will not
have any control Bobby will uh be under
me Bobby will answer to me Bobby will be
leaving in two months right that's just
letting you know that things will not be
operating the same exact way I'm in
control without being disrespectful to
Bobby right um you know as being a
leader and I'm I'm not saying that Bobby
deserved any of that it's just the fact
that is the measure of the man the
measure of the man has he has not thrown
anyone under the bus at any point in
time even though he was able to at
multiple points in time right didn't do
so so I know going forward these these
games are going to start springing
inside game pass they're going to let uh
a group of games in at some point in
time probably in the next month or so uh
probably around the time that Call of
Duty does come out to offset the
marketing deals with other people this
is a great time to be a gamer but also
in that same thread he said it's a great
time to play right and I I like the
think he said f around and find out
that's not what it did not say that I I
like y y y played around and Y found out
and y'all want to play so you want to
play and and Phil now is on your neck is
he a nice guy
now is he a nice guy now but I was
telling you dudes before when he jumped
on that stage and he exed out Reggie and
Sean oh my Lord and I told you the next
dude was next and I told you he wasn't G
to survive this fight this was going to
be a battle he wasn't going to survive
and Phil made quick work of him but in
order to show you how deadly he was he
made sure that that deal was closed on
Friday the
13th there is no way in hell you going
to keep telling me all this stuff is
coincidence with this dude how many
bodies do you have to see in order for
you to know that he's a Serial dude like
dude is actively taking out your great
CEO whoever your CEO is they been
missing right if they haven't
capitulated if they ain't get down and
lay down better think about it Bowser
nothing slick came out of Bowser mouth I
thought he had pocket I thought Bowser
that's what I'm talking about you see so
Bowser ain't coming up missing Bowser
signed at the dotted line so this is a
strong arm tactic by Philly team okay I
get it now Jim signed the dollar line
too under
duress oh Playstation sign to take your
deal he was under the rest okay okay I
got it you got to think about it cuz FTC
said I don't even know why Sony signed
that
why why you why you signed there he said
man have me under
pressure said yo we ain't seen Jim yet
ain't nobody can show me a video of Jim
but we got a signed document that they
down with us now what
so and then and then then under
circumstances y'all have been like nah
something's up with this picture we
don't have a body we just have a note
and then he talk about he going on a
long vacation
oh so you don't believe the retirement
you believe this is Phil's wor pushed
about show me show me Jim produce
Jim oh wait so you said Jim is we have
not physically seen Jim anywhere nobody
has seen Jim we just got a note cuz one
minute he's adamantly against it then
all of a sudden we got a note that he
down going on retir he did say
PlayStation what is it can't exist
without this deal so he did say exactly
where's Jim show me Jim
and then you gonna do it on Friday the
13th I don't know I think we all in on
one big
conspiracy but I I just want to say I'm
so happy it happened to y'all Y you dir
that's messed up because just this month
this shocktober it's a shock this a
shock this is shocktober this is going
to be your worst Halloween ever and I
know they're going to do something on
the 31st to make it worse I know that's
why I got two MTH that's why I got the
Michael Myers and the
and soon they going to put the Freddy
out y' ain't going to be able to sleep
it's tra to y'all so let's let's have
fun with this topic I
waited for so long and I'm glad it
happened to all of you you glad it
happened to you you are ridiculous sir
but I had to let you get your balls up
they told me I had to be quiet this is
all about the king Hold the Line
advancing the line but we got a special
guest there who's been very patient
who's been very patient Lord Tom Warren
of house Verge but much respect love
what you doing my my fellow Destiny
brother I don't know if you been playing
in a while but we used to we used to
play that game everyone's everyone's
taking a pause on that right yeah we
take a little pause we take a little
pause we got to talk about this man
because you have been the Lord has been
kept us a breast of all the latest with
the CMA the UK the Microsoft movements
with this whole thing you even alluded
to the spooky Friday the 13th something
may or may not happen you know so I want
your thoughts you know on just now that
the dust is set a little bit about you
know the The Regulators agreeing you
know what this means and then also a
second part to what you said um in
reference to you had a great article in
reference to the something that I see
nobody talking about which is the
Ubisoft and Activision part of it right
so and and about the cloud gaming right
so first the deal now that the doesn't
settled and then the Ubisoft
portion yeah now the deal's settled I
think the announc of the deal was kind
of strange right like it was obviously
Friday the 13th which makes it spooky
strange anyway yes um but like it wasn't
like the pesda announc was it it was it
was very kind of subdued very kind of
just just the one blog there was no
Round Table um no promises of stuff on
Game Pass straight away so um I do
wonder if that stuff the way that
they've kind of framed it with Phil
saying it's going to be a few months
until they start talking about the Game
Pass stuff I do wonder if they they're
kind of holding Activision a little bit
separate until some of the FTC stuff
maybe pans out
um and also just because Activision put
that a really weird tweet in the week as
well they were like it was very vague
but it was it was essentially saying
Modern Warfare 3 and Diablo 4 wasn't
going to come to game pass this year
which we we we kind of knew um Modern
Warfare wasn't but obviously people were
kind of hoping die blow M um but then
they was like vaguely saying that stuff
was going to drop in 2024 so so now I'm
like and that that to cut you it almost
was also interesting it was kind of
before the deal was officially announced
right didn't they kind of they was like
you we know our fans have been asking
about the Xbox like it was like this
Preble before it actually happened but
I'm sorry continue yeah well at that
point they all knew I mean basically
this deal has been done since July um
the CMA really well yeah essentially
it's just them going through the steps
so um so when we talk about like the
Ubisoft stuff so like back in July um
obviously Microsoft wanted to sort of
restructure the deal to p the CMA but
then you get to this point where you
have a bunch of folks that want these
cloud gaming rights obviously Ubisoft
have succeeded but the actual process
there is that they essentially all have
an interview with the CMA it's like like
trying to get a job so they have you
know they'll have a pitch deck and
everything and then and then the CMA
will say okay we like these guys we like
these guys we don't like these guys then
they might gave two or three um options
to Microsoft and it's up to Microsoft to
decide so Microsoft did make the
decision for Ubisoft but they have to go
for the CMA first um as I understand it
so um that deals the C's kind of like
rubber stamped it back in July right
just by saying these people are okay
this would fit you know
how address our concerns ENT so a future
Tom Warren article about maybe who the
other players were yeah I know who they
were oh oh you do know but out of
respect for The Verge we we not going to
disclose right
but but how hopefully we don't got to
wait too long cuz I am curious because
Ubisoft was chosen obviously you know
French based but so they must have fit
all the criterias that both the CMA and
Microsoft Microsoft interesting so there
were other players that could have held
this for the game continue sorry there
there was definitely some ones that were
like you wouldn't
expect this list
continue Sony wasn't know that Sony was
that financially they don't got the
structure
no they do not have the facilities
yes so no so so pretty much it was
stamped then because that's basically
them agreeing to it at that point yeah I
mean they're basically going through the
process over the last few months which
they have to obviously go through
through their own process and it all
makes sense but essentially the whole
thing where Microsoft and the CMA both
basically said we're not going to go
through this appeals process round about
that time is when you know that it was
pretty much okay they've obviously got a
good deal in place that was going to
address all this and it came out it was
restructuring and all that so it was
rber St stamped back then so when
Activision's putting a tweet out earli
this week they know they know it's
closing on Friday everyone knows they
all knew internally that's why I
reported a week ago yeah that they were
eyeing up Friday because it was just
they knew that that was when the CMA was
going to come out and um say that you
know it's you're clear to close and then
they all ready with the money and then
they close so got you I I wanted to
follow up on two things obviously just
wanted to obviously you're based out
there so I want to do this this theme
like the British were coming you know
what I'm
saying that was the vibe of this IOP so
I wanted to get like what was the
temperature you know in the
UK prior to this when when the deal was
initially blocked by them they wanted
more cuz I think the surprise if we had
to be honest was that they blocked it on
cloud right everybody thought the Call
of Duty thing that would be and they
didn't fall in line with the EU the EU
was was different so I guess what's the
feeling the temperature like was it BL
were people upset the consensus was like
why is this getting blocked or was it
the opposite where it's like you know
cuz the CMA statement felt if you read
the CMA statement it feels like you know
they put the gauntlet down they made
Microsoft change these I mean this this
this document that they I got to read a
little bit of it is really intense about
like the things that they're saying they
say we've cleared the New Deal for
Microsoft to buy Activision without
cloud gaming rights in August Microsoft
made a concession that would see Ubisoft
instead of Microsoft buy the right and
then they said this new deal will stop
Microsoft from locking up competition in
cloud gaming preserving competitive
prices and services for UK Cloud Gamers
so they they were very animate like they
made Microsoft capitulate and change and
you know stand up for the government is
that the Fe feeling in the UK like what
is the feeling I don't think that's the
feeling amongst Expo fans that's for
sure okay they hated the CB's guts for
months um in terms of the UK I mean it's
like a business thing but um for for a
lot of people looking at it but I think
it's also the element of brexit right
like you see the CMA like beating their
chest here and and kind of alluding to
other Regulators not getting such a good
deal or whatever I think that's that's
been a general theme in it um and you've
probably never heard of the CMA before
this um because and to be honest we've
never really dealt with them heavily
before this anyway wow cuz they've not
really had the same sort of powers
because all those powers that they've
got now are just because of
brexit they've suddenly transformed into
this Global regulator because of brexit
um because the European commission no
longer has the powers to to to block
that stuff in the UK obviously because
we're out of the European Union so I
think that that is definitely the
biggest context of this whole thing and
I think this was obviously a huge merger
for the CMA to sort of stamp their mark
on um and to be honest I think even
though they you know it was it was a
long process they they dragged it out
and Xbox fans might not liked I think
they kind of did the right thing the C
like this going to be controversial no
break it down break it down I want to
hear because they they saw what I saw as
well early on um in part my reporting I
I did say that the cloud was going to be
the problem this I said it too I said it
yeah I basically said Call of Duty was
like a load of noise which it turned out
to be but the cloud stuff was always
going to be the issue um because
Microsoft can leverage so much stuff
there and they're only when you look at
the cloud in the future it's only a
handful of companies that are really
going to be a to succeed right Amazon
Google Microsoft right that's that's the
trio at the moment really um and
obviously Google hasn't succeeded so far
correct corre with stadia but I'm sure
they'll be back at some point they like
to revive old stuff
to um but I think ultimately what they
got was probably a better deal for
consumers in the long term it doesn't
might not look like it right now but
they kind of Microsoft's agreements that
they have like some of these cloud
gaming agreements um although they don't
specifically state it in these words or
anything but they essentially force
people down the windows route to to host
those games on windows so they wouldn't
be able to host them on on Linux because
they need to Port them
and some of the weird licensing with
these games just wouldn't um allow that
um so the CMA is kind of pushing it so
that it will be across multiple
platforms so so now that we've got like
such good emulation well not even
emulation but mapping the apis
essentially with proton and stuff like
that it it just it's just going to make
Services more competitive in the future
and cheaper um if if people can run on
Linux rather than having to have a
Windows license all these sort of tiny
little things um so it seems like they
massive pain in the ass
right I think ultimately they probably
have done the right thing and I like I
kind of understand where they were
coming from and I think they've probably
done a better job than the EU if I'm
honest because the EU process was like
okay here's all these companies the way
they work out is they they they find the
competitors that have got issues with
this deal right and then that basically
they give that list to Microsoft
essentially or they let Microsoft know
and then Microsoft can go to all those
companies like it did and then they do
all these deals like they did with Nidia
cuz Nidia was against this deal um
originally and they go to all these
companies they sweeten them up with a
good deal um and then obviously the
European commission goes okay companies
are you happy now and they go yes yes
we're happy now yes we're happy now and
then that's that like there's no fair
enough it's it's a it's a weirder way of
doing things um in in my opinion but um
yeah but at least they' both got good
deals forood for their relevant
consumers in those markets I think umir
we'll see we'll see how it goes
hopefully like you wouldn't me to talk
about the Ubisoft stuff and and how that
works like yeah because because the
thing is again the fact that they're
going to have you know the cloud rights
and I I'm very curious because you had
an article about that if you could
explain the the intricacies of that a
little bit yeah it's even if you
probably read the article you probably
still confused yeah I was confused it's
it's this it's really hard to explain
um but essentially what Ubisoft have
acquired is the rights to cloud gaming
um for for all of Activision Blizzard
games that exist right now and that will
exist for the next 15 years and they
keep those rights perpetually so into
the future in 15 years time they'll
still have those rights for whatever
games have been released now and over
the next 15 years um those rights only
apply outside of the EU or outside of
the economic I can't remember the EA I
can't remember the exact term name for
it but it's essentially the EU and like
Norway and a couple of other countries
um and yeah so so that those rights
apply outside so they do apply in the US
the UK any other other market and it
basically means that they will license
for like a commercial fee um to any
stream streaming service Activision
Blizzard games it does mean that
technically or legally they could say
okay we're going to give the next I
don't know um Call of Duty exclud to
son's Cloud they could technically do
that possibly we don't really know what
the the Sony deal is but um they could
do that but are they going to do that
probably not because everyone will know
that ubisoft's done that and it's them
that allowed that so you know that's
going to put put them in everyone's SES
everyone sight L interesting interesting
whereas we've obviously seen deals where
Sony has paid to to not have games on
game pass and that wasn't obvious to
Consumers right right those during the
during the trial yeah that came out more
mhm yeah but if it was obvious I think
people would be you know pissed at only
right so yeah um so I can't see that
Ubisoft would do it just because yeah
they're going to be right in the fire in
line so they'll be right but they do
have to license back to Microsoft to put
it on Xbox cloud gaming but not Game
Pass right so it's only the cloud stuff
cloud cloud RS which which are separate
so it's not going to affect Game Pass um
m is free to P that stuff in Game Pass
yeah
as long as they got the licenses and
what's not um but yeah they don't have
to worry about the the um the licenses
um for the cloud gaming stuff to put
that in Game Pass got it now final
question I just the the ramifications of
the deal in general obviously you know
Activision is huge it is we know it for
Call of Duty blizzard you know we we
know about wow and and the PC and what
is it uh Battle.net and then obviously
King the mobile right which is which is
huge you know what do you think now that
this deal is finally fiz like what do
you think this means for Xbox how big is
this for Xbox what do you anticipate the
next steps you know happening as far as
you know the integration just overall
prediction just your general thoughts
yeah I think they I don't think they're
going to do too much integration right
now like look at Bethesda it's still
pretty much run very separately yes um
inside Microsoft as we saw with some of
the games that have been released um are
you are you
you're playing with red fall situation
we going to move on I think I know what
you was doing right there
but um so yeah I I don't think that's
going to change too much um but for them
they're just a huge publisher now right
so that's that's it's the control aspect
of of these games really for them um
having them on Game Pass and I
think a lot of this deal that hasn't
really been talked about because it's
been overshadow shadowed by the CMA
stuff and by Call of Duty and the cloud
stuff is mobile right yes King King
obviously Call of Duty mobile like all
that sort of stuff it's just is huge um
I think obviously people who play on
console and PC don't probably care about
it as much but the money it's yeah it's
making money um making more money right
like yes than console so on the Call of
Duty side so it's that that's going to
be the key I think and I think it all
ties in like with um Microsoft making an
Xbox Mobile store that potentially
launch next year um depending on some of
the regulations which are kind of a open
up like the iPhone to more stores and
stuff if all that sort of stuff comes
together then having like a good amount
of games that you're publishing um for
the mobile future is going to be super
interesting and we see like apple
although they always constantly try and
say that they going into gaming yeah um
with the iPhone 15 Pro they're showing
games running on their like res evil and
stuff so it's we're at the cusp of like
where mobile might become a lot more
interesting and to have native games
there not just Cloud I think it's G to
be GNA be pretty important for them so
but in terms of stuff coming to Game
Pass yeah like especially in the EU like
what do you do you think this makes
impact in the EU with Xbox series
consoles with Game Pass
subscriptions yeah I think it will in
time like because obviously Sony's had
the marketing deal
um for Call of Duty Call of Duty
obviously was at home the home of uh at
home at Xbox um years ago and that's
always been a kind of bit of a sore
point for Xbox fans I guess that that
went to PlayStation so that that that
not having those exclusives elsewhere
will obviously will matter because now
you know Xbox is the home of Call of
Duty so um I think that's going to going
to help but it's going to be it's going
to be a long time down the road right I
think it's going to be a few years down
the road maybe maybe even the next next
gen before it start starts to impact
really um it's it's more The Game Pass
stuff that's that's going to help in the
near term in the near future okay yeah
because that the Xbox series s is is
really the Game Pass console and it's
that's what's really shifting their
sales numbers this generation right now
so um but is jez joining us but um he
should he was supposed to but I know
yeah he may have some things going on so
made that yeah right cuz he reported
that there was going to be a bunch of
games on day one into
right so I'm curious what's happened
there like that all just seems a little
strange because I figured that they
would have maybe it's Tuesday because
that's the next Game Pass drop right um
but I figured they'd have some old Call
of Duty titles that's surely yeah that's
what I'm think Microsoft was lighting
those servers up it wasn't Activision it
was Microsoft that that fixed those Xbox
360 servers for
sure okay okay got yeah cuz I saw that
influx and people like they were playing
it and you start to see the engagement
with some of the older stuff so I was
wondering how Okay so they were they
were preparing then um but I think the
difference is I don't know whether it's
something to do with the FTC whether
they're trying to keep stuff separate
just in case the FTC does go you know
nuclear and somehow manages to undo this
deal um the most unlikely things but you
never know um so I just wonder if that
just I think just from the way that they
announced this on Friday yeah wasn't
quite what I was expecting I wasn't
expecting to say
we talk about Game Pass stuff in the
coming months I thought it would be I
thought it'd be like soon coming weeks
you know not fair enough fair enough
that makes me suspicious that they got
things cooking no fair enough fair
enough let's open it up a little bit and
uh Lord addict man this man feels like
damn near two years that subject of ABK
Microsoft every title of IOP we have had
that in it at some or some level um from
the day that we announced it probably
one of our biggest we got to the point
where we refused to talk about it yeah
we we had to put it it was getting to
the point which is too redundant we were
talking about it all the time so like
now that we're here the dust is settled
you know what are your thoughts on on
the ramification of this deal how
important it is and that it's finally
finalized we are here I care as much as
I cared the first day they announced it
uh it's cool if you like their games uh
good for you I just not a big fan of
their games um I have played really a
Call of Duty since like Advanced Warfare
you know it it's nothing I'm more
interested in like the crash bandicoots
the spirals I'm more interested in stuff
like that I think I would enjoy those
type of games more but as far as like
the the deal with self closing Thank God
now we don't have to hear about it no
more but that that's pretty much all man
you know I I people expected this long
drawn out response from me I said
exactly what I was saying the the
previous time we talked about it is it
was one of those things it's like I want
the the the end result that makes this
quicker whatever get whatever do to
resolve it yeah because it's like I said
like two or three days after it was
announced it's like Not Gon to lie I
wish it was Sega like we'll talk about
next stuff we'll talk about Activision
just does nothing for me you know um I
do think Call of Duty in Game Pass is
going to really Drive their cells and
what's funny is people sit there and say
they only have Call of Duty you mean
that the game that El sells everything
every year in two months you mean that
game like it's just like look like you
could you could talk down on Activision
but you got to respect the the brands
that they own yeah you know the oblo by
itself huge brand OverWatch huge brand
like there's a reason Microsoft had to
spend $68 billion do on this company
because the the the IPS
alone is what drove that price up as
much much as it did and it's just like
but at the end of the day when it comes
down to it like me personally it does
for but I think as the deal itself is
going to help Microsoft tremendously
going forward especially you know Tom
was talking about the marketing thing
you know I've said multiple times on
this show the marketing rights to Call
of Duty is probably more effective than
Call of Duty itself uh because every
Studio makes different Call of Duties
but guess who doesn't know that the
average consumer that plays Call of Duty
facts for the most part they just see
Call of Duty and then whatever's after
that they don't you know some might oh
this is an Infinity war game some might
they might have a good concept on it but
for the most part that marketing rights
doesn't
discriminate it promotes all the Call of
Duty Brands regardless which studio made
it that year I feel you I feel you that
well said I got a question for you guys
then yes please if I may um like what
IPS do you think they should revive oh
you asking me now I'll jump in oh for me
listen I I am everybody knows me I'm
such a G1 Transformers guy and those
High Moon Studio games well Fall of
Cybertron War of Cybertron those to me
were the best games I've ever SE done
for the franchise that respected the law
the stories were great they had a
Cooperative element to it I believe the
gentleman's name is David teager who was
the director of the time he was a huge
Transformers fan they were made with so
much care and love for that for that
franchise that I need those first I need
those in back compack that's number one
number two you know if we could get him
out of the Call of Duty sweat
shot and and get them to make because
Hasbro clearly wants it I remember I saw
the conversation between um Hasbro and
some other outlet and Hasbro was under
the impression I'm sure they all about
that ex money Hasbro was under the
impression that Activision give me money
of me doing nothing just getting money
yeah they was under the impression that
Activision lost the source code and then
Lulu misseri said no no no we have it so
to me let's revive that either remaster
them or put them FPS boost 60 frames
Jason Ronald and the team um looking at
you you you got a lot of work done to do
but you know um get that done first and
if there is interest because Hasbro
clearly wants to do it they can really
make a new one and it doesn't have to be
like a cash grab or a movie tie in but
that's one for me but s what you what do
you got what's one of the ones you want
any old friend oh I know one for you you
I know what yeah I mean for me it's it's
tenu the right the rights pass like 2004
belonged to to from right but um but
earlier stuff so they can go back and
remake some of that stuff and I don't
know what that gives them in terms of
the the right to go and remake certain
things I think they should talk to from
and be like yo you know if you make an x
amount of tenu games will'll give you
the IP or something well that's the
thing I I feel like you got to make it
very very I get that but that's why it's
like you know scratch my back I'll
scratch
yours so so that um there's a couple
like you know obviously like prototype M
was was it you know I knew you was going
to steal oh Ste with that prototype I
was trying I was trying to be quiet the
whole time like just just go
ahead do you honestly think it would go
through to you and no one say
prototyp but my guilty pleasure my
pleasure and King probably because he
played these too I know Soldier of
Fortune
oh I don't like him when you get soier
of for that first Soldier of Fortune you
play it right like okay this like you
know little tactical it isn't even a
tactical shooter it's just kind but the
moment you dismember somebody for the
first time you're like oh is this type
of game this type of game oh it's go
it's like it's like the video game of
the boys or gen V Yes gastic sold your
fortune yeah so I need sold your fortune
back in some way shap before no doubt
add what you
I actually have a weird thing I want
them to do you know um tonyk the the the
you know the Donkey Kong 64 game where
it switched between all the the the Kong
family yes I want them to do that but I
want them to incorporate uh toys of talk
I want them to put uh banj Kazooie Spyro
Crash Bandicoot and just like mix all
those IPS together and do something like
that cuz I actually feel like those
brands individ ually won't hit hard but
I do feel if they did a correct building
that universe together as a unit it
would it would do better as a whole than
it would individually because you can't
tell me if ratchet and Clint can't have
an audience there's no way those games
can't have an audience they don't have
an audience app apparently
oh you're messy King what you like sir
what activis joints what about the most
SP beings too oh okay that this is this
is my evil wish let's oh here we we go
we come the 20th next week they drop all
the old
Spiderman oh just to come back just and
just say happy Spider-Man
day you Spiderman you
get I think it would be more effective
if they did it the day
before people people are getting into
the game and they like if you drop the
day of I I think it gets drowned out I I
think it gets drowned out no nobody we
ain't playing it oh my God I'm just
saying drop it on they day like Y is
your birthday is my birthday
too I
wonder that's probably that's probably
one of the reasons that they're taking a
little bit longer is because there's so
many
like legal issues they can and cannot
listen I'm tell you it'll be crazy if
they've been working on this Spider-Man
thing and that does happen that say
I'mma tell you if it does if it does
that you have seen the most evil evil
villain rise the the villain Arc the
villain Arc fill fulfill he turned hell
he would turn hell so terrible that day
if if he please on God
please you're ridiculous you are
ridiculous I've never wish for nothing
this hard of my life that is petty sir
but oh God okay if y'all could do this
please so you want all the Spider-Man
games to come out on the same
time King King I make it worse they drop
all the Spider-Man in Game Pass that
Activision published but they only
promote Amazing Spider-Man
2o you're ridiculous yo okay so talk
about just say they just say happy
Spider-Man
day yo okay I want CRA to to my real yes
yes your real stuff yes we got crash oh
god um that was
dope crash team racing I want crash team
racing I want all of them I want all the
cards crash card games to come back
inside uh you know Game Pass I want them
launching game pass 60 frames per second
really you think they need to do a giant
like mixture with the Xbox people too or
should just I think I think that'd be
dope like um they could take imagine
crash team racing and then a giant like
DLC where it adds like like
the they can do like monthly they can do
they can add psychon not dudes like on a
Game Pass type of thing I mean um um uh
a battle pass type of thing you can get
a psychonaut kid you can get uh uh
Master Chief you can get uh Marcus
Phoenix you know you can get different
uh type of characters I think it can go
over well this can be a game of a
service that you can put the cart racer
there with a battle pass inside and have
different tracks be launched it it's
something that they can go back to I
want them to do that okay I want them to
go back to spiral oh oh yeah I love the
Platformers the old Platformers that we
did have the first 3D Platformers Spyro
was one of those guys that was in there
that actually did a 3D platform pretty
well so just just to go back and nudge
Sony so bring back the crash games bring
back crash team racing just toy not
because people wanted to no no no this
this for me
yes yes I want your mascots to be our
masc yo we we we own your Mas we own
your most famous mascot now like the
dude out for the only dude that was
other other than him that was famous I
got him hostage I'm wait I'm waiting for
him his gay to come out but I want crash
and I want CR I want I want Sega I mean
um Microsoft to send him over uh to
Sony's headquarters a bullhorn yo and I
want them to call out uh God of War God
of War get out there you're ridiculous
get outside God
War that's what I want that's what I'm
looking for you want marketing with
crash vanou fa yo listen listen Aaron
team with me make me uh your your
co-host whatever in marketing and we
will we will destroy this generation us
together we will destroy this generation
we would take back mind share and we
would do the things brought the edge
back to stuff we could do you know you
know the only thing that happens in that
Arrangement is King C say why can't we
do that Eric yeah exactly all his ideas
getting shot
down need one oh and don't forget we
need them um The Raven Games Marvel
Ultimate Alliance games I need those oh
yeah that's me um but I didn't get a
chance to talk to you you know now we
here man this is a long time a lot of
people said it wouldn't happen you know
um just in general now that the dust is
settled it is approved ABK part of Xbox
game studios you know what are your
thoughts man what this whole thing yeah
I think the same as everybody kind of
relief that it's done like you know it's
it's you know when it came out you think
naively you think oh it's G to get done
quick you know whatever and you forget
about the processes and you forget about
the fact that Microsoft isn't you know
super well-liked in that regard when it
comes to like you know the idea of of
you know take absorbing other companies
I'm sure some of these other like
regulatory things they just love when
Microsoft pops up over there so what can
we do to mess with Microsoft this week
right exactly well how do we mess with
the with the big dogs right so the fact
that it's done with you know all the
court proceedings and stuff are done we
still have the Len KH trying to decide
if she wants this fight or not if she
wants to smoke more uh so we we'll
figure that out and then you know I'm
sure for them it'll be a win if they do
decide to continue to pursue this and
then Force Microsoft post acquisition to
have to make certain changes from within
right that's something that I'm sure
they hope that they can do um but we'll
see we'll see if they want that fight
we'll see if she doesn't get you know a
supreme amount of push back from the
government to just let it be um but I
think the most interesting thing is that
now that it's settled right and we
talked about what's next right who's
next and the
president okay well I I was gonna come
back to you but you want to do it now
you want to do it now yeah because I
don't to say about I don't have let's do
it let's do it now let's do it now cuz I
got to set you up though I got to set
you up cuz cuz you you did your thing on
this man like in general like you were
the one you know just be honest like we
laughed throughout the room we were like
who should Microsoft get next after the
zenimax thing and and you were the old
only person bro that was just like look
you know ABK you were like you know
Bobby the whole situation over there
good PR you know and we like man I don't
know what he talking about so now that
we are here we have to bend the KN of my
bro so correctly the s d correctly
predicted it you know what do you think
you know I know this is not a popular
subject so just for us to even talk
about what's next after this cuz a lot
of people like yo consolidation this is
crazy but we all we say is on record
Microsoft has confirmed they are not
done with Acquisitions even after this
so we have to talk about what's in the
here and now so after this in your
correct prediction what do he think's
next man what do he think's next
microsof this is the thing with the
president they set with this with this
acquisition MoneyWise right everything
else that they would acquire that makes
sense or whatever Falls beneath that
money threshold meaning meaning that
when you look at the way that the FTC
and these other governing bodies look at
uh what they look at when it when it
comes to monopolies and unfair you know
business practices and stuff like that
and and sort of eliminating
competition the thing that they kind of
switch from from back in the day back in
the day it was looking at hey how much
stuff are you trying to gather into your
fold that is going to Corner this
specific market right and it switched at
some point
after the r era right it switches at
some point to just money hey are the
consumers going is this good for
consumers and how much money does it
cost to to get this done if those two
things fulfill this quota that that that
falls under this line that says okay
this is viable this does not change sort
of this the spectrum of of of power in
this specific uh corner of the industry
then it's fine so now that they've got
this high threshold of near $70
billion everything else falls under it
so everything else theoretically should
be easier to
pass whole B now is what you say now
that's the thing that's the thing
anything else should be easier to pass
yes you know with with Lina Con on the
prow she's going to be specifically
Vigilant about whatever Microsoft does
sh 100% you know nobody likes to get
beaten up and then and not have an
opportunity to come back so
um but but when when you look at how
things have been done the past 20 30
years it really has shifted away from
ideological ideologically trying to
corner a market it just it's just about
dollars and cents so if it's just about
dollars and cents Microsoft is smart
enough that they're always going to
frame it in a way that's positive for
the consumer right they're always going
to do that and and and the money
considerations are never going to be as
high as the 770 billion they probably
aren't when you think about what's left
out there right um so it's kind of like
the doors open for anything it's kind of
it's kind for anything really um just to
interrupt for a quick second because to
to add on to your point and again I I
see some of the the the Monopoly Bros
bad that we even have any discussion but
we got to deal in reality on what is
about to happen so you could be mad that
I can't believe these guys are talking
about what's next after the biggest this
is what's going to happen so brace brace
yourself no Real Talk cuz I'm tired of
the fear bonging we got to deal with
reality we here now right so this is
going to happen this has happened and
this is what's going to happen so let's
get this you know you the stages of
grief and acceptance we have to get
there now so the reason why I bring this
up I wanted to add on to your point is
cuz just like you right it what after
ABK I'm like man AK really can't do
anything else at 70 billion that's a lot
of money that's a lot of ey scrutiny
government you know Regulatory and I had
you know the great hog law on and I said
look you know obviously you know I'm a
SGA kid right at heart so I just said
you know let's be honest after buying a
publisher right it's going to be hard
for them to maneuver they got to chill
and he was like no go and I was like
well what's the distinction and it's
just what you said so he said it all
comes down to the money the evaluation
right so if you know of course there was
another $70 billion evaluation publisher
then yeah of course it's going to be
regular eyes it's going to be crazy but
the reality is he was like Sega would
not even be in that that that range they
wouldn't bat an ey at it for the you
know relatively right or any other
Studio or publisher that's of lesser
evaluation so that's the thing that
opened my eyes so really the regulatory
thing comes down to the evaluation how
big it is and then they'd get the eyes
on them so to your point yeah like you
know it's like chump change after you
get this which is all the way up here
everything else is really down here so
it wouldn't necessarily raise the flags
but continue I do think though that they
would sort of raise the same amount of
scrutiny outside of the US because now
when you look at the CMA right and to
Tom's point you know and we talked about
this I like I don't understand why this
Call of Duty point is being is being
beaten up on so much when that is not
the that is that's what's most important
to PlayStation that is not what's most
important to this entire purchase it is
absolutely the mobile stuff and it is
absolutely the cloud stuff like nobody
is seeing that when Microsoft is
promising that they're going to give
Call of Duty and cloud and Cloud access
to all of these other small Cloud uh uh
companies it's like okay does nobody
realize that the fact that they're able
to promise this and follow through on
this promise indicates the level of
strength and power that they have in
this corner of the market it's telling
you that they can dominate so maybe look
at that thing and and and maybe try to
whittle that down a little bit because
they're telling you with that how
powerful they already are
and it's only going to grow if you allow
them to do that so it was it was always
strange to me that no one else saw that
so uh so I do think whatever they do
outside of the US there's going to be
that same scrutiny right it's going to
be like hey how does this happen and
obviously with the Ubisoft thing and
them having those sort of licenses and
perpetuity and then being able to put
those on any sort of platform I think
tomm you're right giving it to Ubisoft
makes the most sense because Ubisoft are
you know Ubisoft are are for the
streets can I can I say one thing yeah
can I can I say one thing and and I want
time to to to think about this
part you said Microsoft agreed to who
they can sell it to right the the rights
to right yeah could you say now now that
now that I know that Darth Phil exists
are they hold they're holding company k
no no no no no no no not even that more
nefarious than this oh Lord oh isn't it
plausible that Microsoft can inter in
the next couple of years just turn
around and buy
Ubisoft and and all of those rights
fundamentally come back to said company
because we sold it to you now we own you
this is
ours so definely CMA would definitely
have the CMA would have some thank you
yes thank you Tom for bring toity
imagine imagine having the conversation
Microsoft like two years ago
we made an arrangement that they would
offse your Cloud we want to buy them
exactly we got to do something else with
their Cloud I heard you be saw us having
money money
truffles look
Contin hello
everyone they made the bet there that in
15 years is probably when the clouds
really get a matter and then they'll
have all the rights In fairness In
fairness to you Tom you know I I got a
lot of flack for some of the you know
Xbox community and say that there's a
part of me that does understand you know
the cma's position in reference to Cloud
I always said even though Cloud was a
nent market that this is something that
Microsoft is more equipped to dominate
than the others there's few that can
match them in that space if Cloud
becomes a dominant real I don't know
what's going to happen 10 years down the
road right who knows you know we could
be flying cars we can have you know
latency that is you know imperceptible
you know down the road 10 years from now
and if they are the leaders of that
market and control some of the biggest
franchise there's a part of me that yes
that understood that yo you may have to
control them because it it no one else
will be able to compete so to see to see
them capitulate to that to Sol Point
willingly right like yo okay here's
here's a loose list of suitors here the
people that you know we think here's the
people that you think I can understand
that and to me the reason Reon why I'm
bringing all this up is because again I
I'm from the era of when an acquisition
or something happens I'm looking looking
at it from the games what do we get what
happens what and the thing that I'm
seeing it's a little bit of annoying
some is that everyone is a financial
analyst how's Microsoft's going to make
the money how are they goingon to how
they going to survive then everyone is a
regulator this is a monopoly and I'm
like the there are people in positions
that are paid Millions more than me that
that is their job right and at the end
of the day Microsoft has to get through
like King said all the scrutiny all the
regulations cuz they know this is not
going to be easy enough to pass but it's
just funny to me how gamers are telling
me how it's bad for the IND as if
everyone can predict the future or how
things are going to go no one knows I
don't know you know what I'm saying but
to sit there and say something is
definitively bad I just want to go for a
minute CU I got to give my little soap
Bo to say something definitively bad for
the industry when you don't know
yourself how things are going to go
that's like me arguing yo Blockbusters
should stay you know what I'm saying
like what are we doing like bro you
don't know where the industry is going
to go so for me I have to look at myself
as a consumer first is this good for
consumers yes more people are going to
play Call of Duty Activision Blizzard
gamees and is it going into Game Pass
and Game Pass is one of the best more
consumer friendly Services out here so
that's the first thing second of all
Nintendo is going to get get it you know
what I'm saying cloud services are going
to get it more people getting a chance
to pay these games okay so if you take
yourself out of your individual box if
all you do is play on playstation and
you look at the rest of the gamers that
never had a chance to play these games
this is good for gaming and here's the
other thing is the thing that kills me
is regulator's job is to determine
what's monopoly if they are saying the
Xbox is third place or whatever it is in
the scheme of Gaming revenue right and
even with this deal they still remain in
third place what are we talking about so
again I'm from the era right and this is
the thing and King you going to
appreciate this one I'm from the era
like I don't have a problem with
exclusiv I've never had a problem with
exclusives I've never had a problem
whatever to me make that shows the other
side okay you have to step up your game
you're going to have to make compelling
reasons for us to go to your platform
people for years said Microsoft I don't
understand I just want them to compete I
just want them to be better they're
utilizing their greatest superpower like
remember when Batman was like yo what's
your power flashlight what's your power
I'm rich I'm rich that's his power so
all these years people complain in the
Xbox one generation and all these
generations with it's faltering one is
Microsoft to compete and now they're
doing this right don't get mad now I
don't don't I don't want to hear about
the crying now yeah like like like I
really don't want to hear and to me
here's the other argument that I I just
don't agree with with this organic stuff
and the right way to do things that's
for you can't tell someone how to to
they got to win your way you can't tell
someone that that's they they've
literally transformed their whole model
into a subscription service it's on them
to prove that that model is going to
work it's on them to prove that hey that
this is going to be financially stable
me my job as a consumer what's the best
deal for me and right now this is the
best deal for me and more people get a
chance to play the games and the last
point I'll say is in reference to the
actual Studios themselves this is not a
hostile takeover y'all like Activision
didn't go Phil and Si didn't go down
with the guns on Bobby and say sign the
paper that's not how this worked this is
not a
take listen this is not a takeover bro
from those emails I don't know listen
this is not a takeover when someone has
to want to be acquired someone has to
want to say look we cannot survive or
we're looking to sell you know what I'm
saying now it is funny that Mar always
comes to people when they're going
through a little Financial show I will
say that yeah I I will say that I will
admit that M so seems to have a knack
for when you're going through a tough
time rub your back yeah they got their
arm around you you know what I'm saying
no doubt I I understand that but it's
like that's how business work and if in
and any other industry if you look at
the entertainment all these industries
ad me you've had this conversation you
see Disney buying up all this stuff you
see tensent we we talked about buying up
all this stuff every other industry
there is consolidation there are people
but I'm not justifying I'm just telling
people the reality right so the thing
that we have to stop being hypocritical
is when it's the company that you don't
like all of a sudden you got an issue
but when all this other consolidation is
going around you're pretty quiet so I
don't necessarily believe these people
you know what I'm saying cuz there's a
if there's a strong contingent of people
who are extremely happy for this day if
you saw Jason shri's part you saw like
they were talking to a lot of Activision
Blizzard employees extremely happy for
the deal to go through there are some
people that yeah there's going to be
layoffs with bur we know that but
there's there's a lot of people that
says look I rather this alternative than
what was happening before so my thing is
none of us can predict the future let's
see how it plays out but at the end of
the day as a consumer I am happy I think
this is pro consumer I honestly do gu I
think to your point uh if we also look
at the state of the industry today right
even the big boys are not immune to
having to to to make Cuts Like We saw
epic make a bunch of cuts like so the
state of the industry is such that like
it's so volatile right now that that
honestly again we go back to the point
what would you rather happen that this
this this Studio this this franchise
whatever be allowed to live under this
bigger umbrella of a company that can
support it or allow it to die right and
you think about Darwin the law of
Darwinism like survival of the fit if
it's time your time to go it's your time
to go right but again yo that was cool
that was cold if he dies if he dies he
dies right but at the end of the day and
and some stuff some stuff maybe it's
just meant to you know for the dodo bird
and some stuff not so much um we look at
right now this situation now with with
the new Telltale right um basically you
know The Wolf Among Us to is on ice
again they've had to let go a bunch the
the the word coming out of uh people
that got let go from there is different
than what the company saying and the
people that that got let go saying
basically let all of us go yeah and and
you know development is Frozen on this
and the company saying no it's just yeah
we're holding off a little bit but we're
still we're still moving forward which
and they may they may turn around on
that point you know at some point in
time and just come clean and say hey no
we're done we're dissolving this once
again
so you know again it's one of those
things where it's like hey I would have
loved to see The Wolf Among Us Too come
out I love The Wolf Among Us that may
not happen now right what would you
rather and it's just the fact of the
matter is that the state and there are
some people out there who blame the
state of the industry on Microsoft
trying to purchase ever since ever since
the vendi uh the the Whatchamacallit the
ZX purchase went down in this it's
Microsoft's fault that the consolidation
is going on forget about tenson forget
about anybody else who's purchasing
forget about that but desda was really
uh nose diving in remember they were the
home of the just saved single player
game and then they started to shift and
pivot when things weren't going when
they were not doing well exactly they
weren't doing well so it's just hey uh
it does keep keep your fandom out of it
and look at it objectively for the
industry especially the state of the
industry that we're in today you will
see that overall this is good especially
when thinking about the alternative
right you're talking from the standpoint
of the
Victor is true you cannot tell you
cannot tell a Vanquish this is good why
they not vanish though you acting like s
still selling well listen listen they
have been thrown into the abyss they
just don't know that they Fallen oh they
don't know they falling yet okay that's
what they don't know they're dead yet
they don't know that yeah listen I'm
sorry to bring the news to you
oh you going to let us know I'mma let
you know right now it is over why is it
over why is it over why why is it over
why is it over you know why it's over is
because we can sit here and say
scenarios and none of the scenarios bold
wealthy there's not one scenario that
anybody has said on this panel so far
that bolds well for you my scenario with
all those Spider-Man terrible day for
you everybody talk about bringing back
prototyping all these games terrible day
for you anytime we talk about bringing
back games to this platform you know
it's going in Game Pass terrible day for
you so we look over to you and say what
are you going to do to combat this I
have no idea but I do know this it any
scenario that you produce is a terrible
day so like you said if he dies he dies
I think he's de I will say this is what
I will give you me and you will agree on
this is that look the sheer volume of
what they've acquired right and we even
we even talk about the king aspect and
the moment and all that but the thing
that we've take ABK out of it for a
second yes we've already said that when
Xbox game studios gets cooking right we
saw a glimpse of it in 2021 what was it
Forza Horizon um Halo infinite Age of
Vampires Microsoft Flight Simon psych
Psychonauts 2 right and we like wow yeah
like psychon yeah right and we like wow
when they're cooking look what could
happen right we all know what happened
in 2022 we don't need to revisit that
none of those games the Microsoft an
abkda exactly adct right Bethesda kind
of went off this year right so now we
looked at this year and we go okay you
got the highi rush you got the AG um the
other joint agent the mcraft Legends
obviously we know about redall but we
got the Starfield agent Empires right
Starfield and then we got the um Forza
Motorsport right say what you want most
of the majority of them minus the red
debacco quality games with a frequency
and a Cadence right that you go wow this
makes Game Pass very attractive to make
people stay in it or newly subscribed
now we talk about next year right you're
talking about what we saw the Bethesda
leaks and then we saw obviously most
likely either AOW hellblade we know we
know about more things to come you throw
ABK into this just the back catalog we
just talk about the back catalog alone
is insane right which you can filter you
don't necessarily have to do a big
massive drop right and you can start
filtering out things strategically like
we already talk about Bobby already talk
about Guitar Hero potential resurfaces
you know resurges there things of that
nature but the thing that we have to be
honest is the elephant in the room and
regardless of how we feel Call of Duty
is that thing right Call of Duty just
like adct said the marketing alone the
Shar you just associate this like Tom
said is the home of Xbox or you as Tom
said we all know the series s is The
Game Pass console it's an all digital
console you're literally footprint
entrance into Game Pass and we saw some
of the splits as far as the series s and
the X as far as that's concerned so if
that becomes a deao Call of Duty box
that's a problem because now you've got
the Casual mind Shi on the biggest game
going to them then we not even talking
about you know all the other future
releases we're not even talk about
blizzard stuff it becomes a Cadence in
with Xbox x game Studio where I call it
the Avalanche effect like not all of
them have to be 90 plus metas they could
just be 85 and up or 80 and up and you
just every quarter you just volume after
that's a because even if and shout out
to K we had this conversation you know
even if um you know they come out let's
say two two games or two what we call
the bangers the hashtag just was from
Sony PlayStation a year right which are
phenomenal games but they're like one or
two like in this case it was what it was
um Spider-Man it was uh for spoken and
what
was f f which is times exclusive right
but so we'll say two plus the times
exclusive right what did say
Spiderman again it it becomes a Cadence
to try to keep up with that if Xbox is
again provided their own all cers
they're doing what they have to do it it
does become a tough battle and that's
the thing I will give you that uh King
in the sense that it is a very strong
lineup and a strong consistency of
titles that you know they're going to
have to deal with and and I just wanted
to say one last thing to adct and he'll
appreciate it was that if you've been on
this platform this is people I to
understand with the whole Studios and
Acquisitions and stuff like that if
you've been on this platform adct I
remember Xbox one and it was like five
Studio what was the studio back there it
was what was it it was it it was um the
coalition Coalition Coalition 343 turn3
turn
10 um they still had was rare and L head
was still yeah and lioning head was
still a thing I think bro it was five
Studio that was Xbox's lineup going to
war with everywhere and that's why Sony
was able to smile and laugh all the time
yeah now you're not laughing no more are
you so so you messing but if you really
think about it it's just like and reason
people like why is people celebrating
this again if you're a fan of this
platform you've seen let's be honest how
anemic it was during the Xbox One era
and you seen a lot of the things they J
didn't own even the just ones they had
the rise to the RS the um Quantum breaks
and you're like damn why are they losing
out and then let's be honest it talk
there was a time when people like is
Xbox even committed to gaming is this
something like is this just something
they do on the side but committed now
huh
how that for commitment
baby you so to King's Point this is why
people if you love The Brand and you
were sitting there during those Dark
Ages wanting to know is this even thing
going to be around do they even care
about it is this a right off what is
this right and and to see the level and
that's why Phil is revered because to
see when I remember was it 2018 and we
saw the initial push the um what is it
you know the compulsions the ninja
theories the obsidians and you like okay
playground moang okay okay they sure now
we know those games are going to take
time but we're seeing the commitment
what I consider the draft picks that's
what this is so now it's like oh no they
have reinvented themselves and Game Pass
is the Trojan Horse and this is what
they're betting on I don't know what's
going to work I can't predict the future
but this and if you're on this platform
that is extremely refreshing to see that
is extremely to see the Comm commment
that they are going to be around and I
always give them credit for the for the
Japanese support so that's pretty much
what I wanted to say for for people who
don't understand right because a lot of
people I I hear the consolidation talk
on death of the industry and the fear
and mongering all that if you've been on
this platform again it's like the halves
and the Have Nots PlayStation been
eating for a long time you know what I'm
saying and they've had exclusives St
being GRE and they've had exclusives and
I haven't complained I hey when they get
exclusive I just go over there and play
it that's it but I don't want to hear
about they complaining cuz to me now
you've got 10 live service games you
have to do and you going to you know do
what you got to do you got Bungie over
they sign Bungie they the last five
Studios have not been organic at all
they've all been straight purchases you
know without that that history tied to
them you you see that dude that I guess
he's from Ben Studio or something or
used to be yeah he was saying they're
buy they're gonna buy uh Namco
something I will consider that organic
cuz been there from the beginning light
on that I can light on that Tom you you
could probably say if I'm right or wrong
if I'm when I say this
yeah they're going to do a partnership
with him because of
Evo look it makes sense look we got to
be me here's the thing when we bought
PlayStation one king remember that Ridge
Racer that Tekken Tekken that Tekken
right those are showcase that that's
that's organic that's an organic
relationship band on N so I'm not even
mad so at the end of the day yeah I
think it it don't matter
Microsoft or Sony or even Nintendo
degree they buy any Studio it's organic
they've been working with these
companies since day one there a't one
Studio
especially well I mean I'm talking about
companies that's been here for years I
thought you I thought you said
everything they did my bad my bad I mean
I'm talking about Microsoft too how long
work Activision you can't say that's not
some form of organic growth they've been
working with since the beginning like
you know to a degree especially the
Publishers if any of these Studios these
companies bought any of these Publishers
there is some form of organic growth to
the core of that relationship because
they've been working with them for
probably two decades like but my thing
too is
like I was like what does it matter like
I'm not coming at you addict I'm just
talking about when people say that it's
just like to me what matters is the end
result like what are you producing all
the games okay they it matters because
they want to be looked at as perceived
clean as the clean we've done the right
way we we've we' spend money in areas to
grow the the industry you know what I I
I love to hear that Microsoft is going
to kill the industry no Microsoft is
going to kill Sony and oh my God and and
and y'all can sit here and try to talk
about what's bad and what's good I don't
care the games will pop up someplace
else later you know anyc passed away
they're gone but did bons die no bons
was living on bons was being uh he was
put on Super Nintendo he was put on Sega
he was put all over the place so I I
cannot wait for that to happen that's
what I'm looking for to happen I I don't
want to sit here and act like oh we're
supposed to preserve one company no I'm
not GNA sit here and and if it was
Microsoft on the other end yeah I was on
the other end of this knife remember
before that I was looking at the brink I
was at the edge of the Rope I was so I
was holding on and I was like no they're
about to kick us off just like they did
Sega it's about to happen again and
Along come Phil Dominus Maximus a really
expensive and he came in organically
with good intentions but y'all kept
hitting him and y'all kept pushing him y
kept doing things to him and now he is
Si Lord Phi and you got Friday the 13th
happen to you y'all did this to yourself
so I don't care if y'all go away I don't
but your games will live on oh my God I
have a different what I think organ grow
you know a company like you know somniac
that you know when they bought that's
organic growth they all they did was
funnel money to them make this game make
that game like to me true organic growth
getting to them when they're small
nurturing them from the small helping
them with Talent sure did PlayStation do
this during the time they're working
upside you yeah but at the end of the
day it was always a somniac decision if
they took it or not and and to me it's
like you know you take a like like
compulsion Studios and you're nurturing
that from you know a small flower to a
bigger flower it's like that to me is
more organic growth than yeah I gave
money for like 15 years I decided to
sell the deal and buy like it's just
like to me that's a cop out it's like
most of these Studios they built
themselves that's the reason you bought
them is because they built their own
infrastructure and you felt value in
that so that's when you officially
bought them yeah that's fine that's fine
all was interesting you mentioned
earlier about the Xbox One launch and
let's go let's talk about it let's talk
about it CU I think where we are with
Xbox is pretty much down to Satin Nella
right like he came in in
2014 there and then almost immediately
Phil Spencer was head of Xbox after like
a couple of months after he was in um
and then Mojang yeah his first big
acquisition and then obviously all all
the other stuff like um obsidian and and
the rest that that they acquired the few
years later and I think like he I think
without satin Adela Xbox could have been
sold to I know Amazon or whatever you
know there was potential for that to
happen it was it was always like um
investors trying to push that way right
remember we used to hear that all the
time yeah so I think CTI n is definitely
kind of the key to this no I agree I I
think that um again to we've had that
discussion where it's like you know
whether or not Xbox is going to be taken
seriously in and I believe the
conversation with Phil and stuff like
all we committed to games and stuff like
that the conversation those two had and
to see his involvement with it is Sati
has been tremendous because yeah they
they clearly showing they're still
committed what I want to ask you um Tom
in reference to uh Sol's point which was
um the what's next thing you know what
I'm saying which is obviously we know
they're not stopping you know we know
that there is more what do you think
logically makes sense as a Target you
know for for Microsoft mov forward
it's going to be Nintendo
right you gonna like the poll question
you GNA like the poll
question wow you know feel wants to
retire oh
man bro I they are so mad with me for
him even discussing that like they were
like you I'm he get Nintendo he get
Nintendo I will come in with a full
Mario suit with a
Yoshi oh my God that that
is I mean he he did say it would be a
career moment what do you think that's
realistic or that that's your choice I'm
curious what's your choices I I think if
anything would happen with Nintendo it
just be a I think the Call of Duty stuff
is the beginning of yeah even more
closer partnership and they have been
pretty close anyway so I think if we see
Game Pass eventually come to the switch
to you
know coming in heart some some games you
never know Swit switch to coming in
heart with Game Pass I got I I gotta ask
a contrarian question we have we have
Tom here and I just as somebody who you
know who writes about the
industry if Game Pass theoretically
doesn't hit some internal level of
success or whatever the case may be is
there any scenario in the future you
would ever see that game pass goes away
and they go back to selling all a cart
exclusively and not Game Pass or is
there a scenario where maybe they took
first party out of game pass eventually
in a future yeah I think it's going to
be interesting to see what they do with
Activision to be honest with whether
Call of Duty is going to be there day
and date on everything
like we'll see what happens with that um
that could be like a little bit of a
telling sign to to where it might go but
I don't think they'd ever shut it down
um it's just the fear is that the prices
will keep going up right to to cover
that sort of stuff um it's already
profitable um and they've obviously got
I think where where they need to know is
is the mobile stuff in the future but
obviously the PC side as well like that
Xbox app on Windows is still really
janky yeah and I know everyone's
obsessed with steam and you want all
your games in in that Library um but
maybe they have to have some sort of
deal with valve
there game Personal Steam would be would
be kill yeah that be sick cuz
Yeahs part of me feels like they like
that steam money too much put Game Pass
I don't know why I feel like they they
feel you know maybe when that this is
done they'll they'll they'll merge kind
of way battl net and they'll keep game
pass over there you know but part of me
is like you know you have the option to
go over here but we know how these steam
people are they're going to buy it even
if there's an option for free over here
Ser yeah it would have to be a pretty
big bag that I think Phil has to give
Gabe to to get that to happen cuz mic's
not going to want to pay 30% right so
yeah the bag is called by
steam that be adct real quick it's
probably never going to happen right but
it would be that would be killer pass
was on Steam that would be that would be
insane yeah I could even visualize I was
going to say adct real quick I to get
your thoughts on uh the next obviously
we know that Microsoft's not finished
you know um this is discussion a lot of
people don't even want us to have but uh
I got to ask you what do you think is
potentially the next
I think I don't think they're going to
really overextend for a while I think we
might not see them buy something for
maybe a year two year and a half L lay
low yeah I think they're going to lay
low as far as like if they do buy
something I think they'll still closer
to like smaller Studios maybe work deals
out and buy uh you know Crystal Dynamics
off of embracer maybe a couple of other
things off of embracer I I don't think
they're gonna mess with Publishers
anymore part of me just feels like
they're done with that got I think I
think they could they got the money even
if like something like Sega was one I
think they might overextend for
something that would make sense to their
Library maybe like a Sega or something
because they don't really have a lot of
games that are hom grown from that kind
of uh scenario but as far as like the
Ubisoft the the activ Activision the EA
I feel like that's too much of a risk to
redo again outside look like da
Disney I feel you on that but I do think
if they try to buy EA um I I'm confident
they would shut them down I don't think
there's a chance that they buy them it's
just like a hard one yeah the FTC is
like look we told you with that Division
and now look what they bu another big
here they
go buy um a so oo I like that that that
works thatal one the Bigg things that
they're going to focus on is stuff that
makes sense that Enlighten their
companies but the problem is too is like
the infrastructure the one of the
reasons they love to uh you know romance
Publishers and take them out and then
buy them later because it's because they
look at that as like a running engine
that they don't have to really intervene
too much they if they buy Crystal
Dynamics and stuff like that I
personally feel like if they buy these
Studios from Brier the companies that
are working with their existing
companies are going to merge together in
one company like for instance is going
to merge with the initiative I can't
remember what company's working with um
uh
playgrounds what company's that I think
it's people that that make the um why am
I blanking I know I know what you're
talking about tell me I know out of the
almost 1,600 people in the chat I know
one of you know somebody's working with
playground recently no there uh yeah
elos
idid ID yeah so I think what would end
up happening is Crystal would merge with
the ini
they'd have a main team working on play
they would go to like a two team type of
thing one working on uh Fable and the
other on the background working on Tomb
Raider if they got Tom Raider aios I
think that would I I don't think they
would drop the game they were currently
working on before I just think that
studio would rotate between two IPS okay
so just you mentioned you mentioned
Fable did you guys see that um what
Peter Molin is saying that he's working
on a game in the in albon oh no I didn't
I didn't about this
I wasn't aware was he don't he don't
like all the attention the game the game
apparently is I guess code name Mo or
whatever but it's it's in albon so he's
working with Microsoft in some capacitor
prob it's probably Milo
too n too whatever he's working on just
let him whatever he's working on don't
let him be part of the pr that's all I
got to say wait ad before I pass the
kick so just to be clear you you want
them you prefer them to go after another
Studio than buy another publisher or is
it you're saying no I prefer them go
after Sega that's what I want okay so
publish it was to say yeah yeah like
what I want and what I believe is
realistic at this exact moment I don't
feel is like on the table right now
because I do think that as much as we
might think you know there's two
scenarios we don't know like on the
logistic things how close and I maybe
you know Tom can go a little more how
close this was like maybe the from the
start this is exactly how they expected
it the CMA they knew they were going to
give them issues and everything would
exactly how Microsoft envisioned this
process to go but the biggest thing that
I feel like makes me don't think it was
like that it was a little bit more on
the we don't know if it's going to get
approved or not is them signing over
Ubisoft with the cloud computing because
I feel like they initially didn't want
to do that they did that because they
had to do that and that's why I feel
like big Publishers they're gonna stay
away with because they're not doing that
again okay interesting yeah it was I
think they were realistically aiming for
like sort of April gotcha so they like
six months six months late so yeah six
months behind which isn't terrible I
guess given how big this was but yeah
but they definitely held them up on on
future things um quickly because I want
to respect Tom so I know he's got to get
out of here but I want to um King king
um I didn't get your choice as far as
what's
next um well I feel it's a partnership
with Sega everybody keeps talking about
purchasing I don't think they purchase
Sega I think uh when you go over to the
Land of the Rising Sun business has done
a little bit differently over there um
there's a lot of respect going Japan
even let them buy them another thing
this is that's the whole thing my thing
is you go over there you make a
partnership you get uh like a 40% stake
in their company so you have a
controlling stake in set company whereas
you don't actually you come to you come
to the door but don't walk in no well
this is this is what you do in order to
uh get access and allow everything to
work as status quo you know K and I was
talking about it the other day about uh
how the Japanese uh business structure
is over there respect you know um honor
different type of things and instead of
over here we're like in in in the
Western World corporate backstabbing
Espionage and all that stuff goes on not
saying that it doesn't go on over there
but a lot of deals can be done with a
handshake and respect right over there
and you know I'm going to work with your
company and we've had organic growth
whatever the hell um but I believe that
they do a partnership with Sega uh
because I don't think a buyout would
bold well for Sega or Microsoft because
if the consumer turn that back on the
company because they feel like the
company turned it back on them disloyal
or whatever none of those products sell
there so you're doing counterproductive
work right um from from what I heard
actually talking to Cog the other day a
lot of that stuff is on the shelves
without The Branding of their name up
there so there you don't want to go over
there and try to upset the apple cart
you go in there you become a partner
with this company and say we're going to
work with them we're not trying to
change their identity okay and you still
get their their products and their
products are still day and dat on your
ecosystem
and yeah and I think we're starting to
see that with like square right like
they realized that yeah they they need
just to have a partnership there and
we'll see ends up we we saw Square was
the only one that had a folder the only
one that was actually you know talked
about vetted and was uh probably going
to get purchased before this ABK thing
went up and they saw ABK as a more
attractive thing and probably jted them
and I think that probably fractured
relationship so Microsoft needs to
repair that relationship with square and
I don't think they can go and purchase
Square I think they can go over there
square and do a partnership with square
and get a lot of the games to come out
on the um on the
ecosystem I honestly and analyzing all
of this stuff and looking at Ubisoft
having the the rights to the cloud
stuff I think Ubisoft is next on The
Chopping Block I think Ubisoft is the
next one
won't let this UB s thing go I see no um
watching it all right if if if we're in
a room and you give me a list of people
that I can mess with or I can give my
work to right right and I pick a
person that's because I'm comfortable
with said person or I got plans for said
person I believe Microsoft has plans I
believe that they're comfortable and the
financial instability that's over at
Ubisoft doesn't bold well for their uh
viability later on in the marketplace so
Microsoft could funnel cash their way
and purchase them at a different period
of time did Tom already told us that
that the C is not going to
like not going to like that because they
pick so that they could be an
independent you know what I'm saying
Orbiter of the situation with the cloud
they won't they won't like it
but but but that that don't mean that
they won't try I'm just saying I'm just
saying I I see something happening in
that area I don't think that these dudes
aren't as calculated as we think but
okay I just want to say one thing
because I saw on my timeline a lot of
people was champion in the fact that
Ubisoft has the streaming rights
yes listen here you
idiots you're no longer buying directly
from the plug now you're buying from an
intermediary uh so what happens is the
plug sells to the intermediary right
that intermediary has to say I have to
raise the price to make my profit back
you understand so he brought the brick
over here for 22 and then he's going to
sell it to you for 27 cuz he got to make
three off a brick uh that's what we do
it so y'all was sitting there Champion
getting the brick because y'all didn't
want to pay Microsoft but yall paying
more for the brick now that the
middleman is dead you dummies y'all
don't know how business this works when
there's no middleman you D deal directly
with source so the fact that they put
somebody in the middle that's charging
you
more you would have got the brick at a
lower cost y'all guys have been hustling
backwards for a minute y'all had y
Microsoft came to you and say yo we're
gonna give you all the ABK stuff y'all
went snitched and got a 10-year deal of
Call of Duty yo I'm telling you I don't
know who's in charge over there but
y'all put somebody else in the middle so
y'all could pay that guy in the middle
more money than y'all would have paid
Microsoft hustling backwards is going to
do y'all in and y'all been hustling
backwards for a while there no there's
no reason why for y'all to say yeah I
agree with Ubisoft to be it
why why you think Ubisoft GNA cut you a
break when they paying Microsoft no they
got to pay to stream now you got to pay
the stream
too power book three by King David thank
you thank you for breaking this down I
got to get the legend he's giving us
more time than I thought to Warren out
of here brother again appreciate you
coming on we got to have you back on in
the future fun man absolutely let the
five people know where they can find you
and what else you got going on yeah I'm
over at the verge.com obviously and on
Twitter or X whatever hell we call it
now I'm Tom Warren so yeah dude TR
tremendous reporting um youve been on
fire with this whole thing and just
correctly I'm just glad it's over yeah I
know we have made it we have made it but
you've been on fire with that I went on
holiday in like July and I couldn't have
a holiday oh you FTC stuff right it's
been nonstop man you've been on the ball
thank you so much man again a pleasure
the legendary Tom
waren no doubt appreciate you brother
thank you so much all right I'll see you
next see you on the next one you already
know no doubt no doubt see got the ubw
stuff you are ridiculous yeah I mean
I'll just answer it quick um I don't
know I don't know what's next to be
honest um obviously you know what the
heart once you know the heart once say
of course but you know I see King's
Point and you know what is that I always
put you the expression of when you
already have the cow with the milk I
always right why a bird in the hand is
worth more than two in the bush why why
buy the cow when you already get the mil
the milk for free right and you can tell
the relationship is good now obviously
going over there you know um they they
initially people like oh it's just
gabing but it's more um the cloud stuff
but I mean and to adct got a good point
too I mean maybe you stay under the
radar there are some natural things that
make sense that like a Soo is one of
them obviously the uh uh Microsoft
Flight Sim the um what is it the um
plague tail isn't that them too Soo plag
tail Soo yeah right you got that um
certain Affinity also makes sense
they've been uh working with them a
while I'm going be honest you know you
though s is my number one and that's
what I
want what makes sense would actually um
help me as well with my hashtag just one
initiative is Crystal Dynamics yeah
Crystal D they are the hash just one
studio if you really think about it like
that's what they do high graphical for
the LA Triple A you know over theh
shoulder that kind of thing but look I'm
going to always hold out hope for Sega
because look they were on the list
before you know we talked about the um
you know they they still want to make
Headway in Japan and that kind of stuff
and and maybe it goes to what king is
saying where it's like you don't
necessarily have to rock the boat but
you you keep things you kind of you kind
of do a bungee in a sense like you keep
things multiplat but you get your name
and your branding over there in the
region and make Headway there so we will
see what happens but as far as um what
what it is look this is a tremendous
move for them they've got Activision
Blizzard King to deal with you know the
the the transition the I'm very curious
when the the round table is going to be
if Bobby's going to be a part of it that
would be interesting you know what I'm
saying how they handled the drops you
know kind of thing and um somebody says
to Xbox next bad which you currently
have look they have to manage what they
curring out that's true but we have to
deal with the reality is that they're
not done and everybody else has to catch
up to speed in that reality and I know a
lot of you are emotional that they
acquired Activision Bard King and
emotional that there's more things that
going to be purchased but that's what's
going to happen so we got to talk about
it I deal with reality I don't deal with
emotions about they need to do this and
they need to with they look bro this is
happening you better get on board now or
you going to get left behind I don't
talk in dinosaur talk and the
consolidation talk yeah I mean it's it's
just people mimicking what what yeah
what other people say yeah people are
saying nobody no just fan of their own
according be like I can't I can't deal
with this consol just because you don't
like something doesn't mean that you
can't you you not you're not going to
have to deal with it and face it you got
to deal with it and face it this is what
it is that person is outside your house
so you can sit there close your eyes and
say yo why is he why he doing he outside
your house you got to step outside at
some point and face it that's where we
at I deal in reality I don't deal with
emotion so to me when they say they're
not done I have to at least talk about I
have to at least discuss and see what's
going on so yeah that's that's pretty
much where it's at with me what you
laughing at King you started some Joy
online Lord be
outside
it is what it is I tried to do something
in the background right I tried to
really do something in the background so
but it didn't
happen I apologize guys but Advance the
line t-shirts is right now hold the line
is in stores for limited time only you
know hold the line is about to be gone
but Advance the line is going to be
there it's going to be replacing it but
I tried to do something right now it
just didn't happen
good glad that didn't work out for you
anyway stupid that's all I got but yeah
historic day y'all and um yeah I just
want to see how the integration uh works
I want to see how um you know the games
the backup all that stuff get get
leveled out and then obviously the when
when is Dia ablo hit right when is I fig
maybe next year there's going to be some
things I think will hit and they may
strategically hold it like for example
Theo's new season right whenever they
come out and say okay that's what we put
it out next year but I do firly believe
they they going to um hit the service as
well as one of my predictions is Call of
Duty next year in the service you know
what I'm saying maybe not this year
because it's so close that they have to
you know the integration on the back end
but I believe next year that they will
have that in game plan that's going to
be a tremendous Boom for them so let's
see what happens and I'm looking forward
to the round table I want to see how
they present it to everybody the way
they did with zenack I want to see how
that goes but that's all I got anybody
else on this historic day that we
correctly
predicted just want to say the Lords
correctly predicted it you know what I'm
saying
despite feelings Des despite feelings we
held the
lie anyway what else we got H we got
some super chats uh oh King by the way
so um Sonic Superstars doesn't come out
till Tuesday but it on Metacritic it's
sitting at a 76 same at open critic so
it's it's good it's good it's not oh oh
okay that's what's up yeah Mario
probably gonna eat his lunch but the
problem with that is I have only enough
funds to go get one and
sorry
[Laughter]
bucko
no we we have so almost 20 hold the line
and Advance oh Advance the line is
moving that Advance the line is
moving I mean they better get that hold
the line going yeah it better get hold
line ain't going to be much long it's
not going to be like that last time King
was supposed to do something didn't do
something all
right still in there remember when
people were remember when people were
clowning us and getting it on the back
end
the I was mad as hell because it wasn't
supposed to
be definitely hold the line is it just
remember the moment in time because it's
going to be gone so no doubt now Advance
the
line then we have uh we got Ryan with
the five pound Super Chat Lord King been
the protag in the next Gears of War
screaming Hold the Line will we take out
every grub inside Xbox is Phil spener
make it happen yeah that's what's up
King and King GE War six let's have it
let's do
it then we got uh bad boy Zone Mike
Lowry
mikeith AKA Mike
low5 Super Chat miss the opportunity if
we don't get 50 Cent bulletproof and
Scar pH The World is Yours nextg remakes
the went to ABK when mend merged in ' 09
nice nice bulletproof get a get a little
ni little 50 we got country big 9
Super Chat happy Sunday Lis thank you
thank you uh thank you thank you to all
you guys for covering this ABK deal for
the past 17 years Tom thank you for all
the coms really do feeling like I I've
been doing this since 2014 and I dead
ass feel like I've done this the entire
time so tired of writing that topic in
the description almost two years bro
it's almost two years M yeah years then
we got almost the whole pandemic facts
pretty much yeah then we got asash with
the uh 2B Super Chat King held the line
when no one did
respect factual
blessings then we got called weed $5
Super Chat Jokes Aside thank you for
what you guys have done for the
community last generation we didn't have
really we really didn't have many voices
in the Xbox Community oh salute salute
salute yes yes salute he those dudes ran
away now and now they want to act like
oh no I've been there I was out here
squabbling in she it wasn't out there
squabbling the street was no nobody
remember your fake exploits B oh
man we got hardge chy $2 Super Chat Cog
pumping meat pause yeah listen man it's
a real in you know in line with a beefy
acquisition we had to debut the beefy
Emoji you know what I'm saying we had to
get that beef theying real beef a lot of
people don't appreciate the beef for the
the ABK
today
too young dreads with the original with
the original of concept for the
beef go go to go to Twitter it's it's
it's trending it's trending Lord beef
Lord beefy is outside Lord beefy is
trending listen man it's a beefy day
beefy acquisition why not perfect
perfect day to bring Lord beefy
outside wow
oh and right on time right on let's play
with each other's joysticks $5 Super
Chat Lord beefy looks like he can handle
the meat yo almost almost as good as me
yo yo yo hey hey
hey back to you s you don't get to beefy
Emoji with that talk we not we not
supporting not even done yet not even
done we are not going to press the but
beef emoji on that you out of pocket
Follow by followed by he boo boo can't
wait to show you my meat pumping
skin yo they Wilding
[Music]
wow back to youself thank you for your
Patron thank you for your your Super
Chat hey yo then we got n nay Super Chat
Lord beefy he's in the running for Mr
USDA
man 100% great a beef out here salute n
day we outside with it beefy boys let's
go then we got s Jitsu Sage $5 Super
Chat Phil said when everybody on
Playstation plays called Xbox Gamers win
thank you for your service suckers oh my
Lord Sage come on behave yourself get in
there get in there behave yourself sir
yeah get that Modern Warfare
3 get
in Dean Rivera $2 Super Chat ABK trailer
is at 25.6 million views on Twitter oh
yeah that a nice trailer was Ace
watching it then we have Huffy bear
ch5 Super Chat shout out to the Lord Tom
waren for joining one of the funniest
podcast salute to Legend Tom man hell
yeah long overdue it's finally get good
to have him in the real he didn't know
what he was getting to he did not know I
was like oh boy but he had fun he had
fun that's what's up that's what's up
let me see there we got uh Lord Metroid
member for 24 months Lord silver
watching my Jags versus Colts Ola Lords
and this great Community a salute Sal
blessing Super Mario Wonder with out
Starfield and Spider-Man 2 Nintendo
Power oh we outside with it all right
talking that Nintendo okay but it ain't
going to win game of the year so go sit
down yo them Advanced thei is moving I
just seen a sweater two
shirts they advancing people are happy
about today man
we we are moving forward we will crush
another one in BL nice nice nice nice oh
some they getting hold the line now they
getting the remaining holding lines now
a couple of them just okay those y who
frauded the first time yeah frauded the
first time now you can act like you've
been there from there y act like y'all
was
down oh somebody got the unity jump off
yo that's what's
up we have thrash metal metallics thrash
metallics $2 ja revive Starcraft ghost
yes # just one
Starcraft I would love that hell yeah
let's go you remember when we was
anticipating that joint droing oh yeah
bro I used to watch video of that I'm
like oh she's smirking oh she got powers
and wasn't it coming to the PlayStation
I think it was Xbox I think it was was
it PlayStation I don't remember I think
it was multiplied
anyway I don't know we have THX 1138 $2
Super Chat second row was published by
Activision it's a St yeah second row a
second row in there so we still got a
few cuz I was going yeah we got a few
got a few we got jiger J $5 Super Chat
dark Phil Super Kicks Jim Ryan in the
face and throws him through a plate
glass window solidifying his heel turn
HBK style yeah this is some real
Heartbreak Kid Marty janetti in the face
kick in the mouth thing yeah it kind of
reminds me of like Phil is that dude off
300 hitting the dude in the
well this is Xbox
there says Xbox then we got dub member
for 20 months Lord bronze it needs to be
Sega cut Sonic the damn check imagine
the potential strength of a fully funded
Sega Pan Dragon let's go Fantasy Star
let's go Etc do it Phil yes yes uh that
that ghost was uh coming out for
GameCube Xbox and PlayStation that that
whole generation pretty much
multier then we got Nicholas Hill $2
Super Chat embracer group be the next
one Xbox will
purchase they will stop that they will
they will shut that down even though the
embracer probably needs it but it we're
talking about what was the I forgot what
the well they needed
over3 something uh like licenses they
got yeah they have a lot they have a lot
boy they would stop that I'm sure they
want to get rid of a most of that yeah
then we got uh Wolverine uh Wolverine
3xx or whatever I'm sorry if I said it
correct incorrectly Wolverine 3x uh $2
Super Chat I want everything yes that's
probably some people out there who
want then we have Lieutenant Hulk $5
Super Chat can't wait for the Sony
Fanboys to see the Xbox logo on Call of
Duty startup screen hit that like button
yeah I was saying that too I cannot wait
until next month when they boot it up it
says Xbox Studio
game
studios and we got hary chani $5 Super
Chat square is the likely next Target
given their financial situation fill
some of the remaining gaps would love
Sega but Square makes more sense now
Square would be scorched Earth as well
they pick up Square oh my God you might
as well set fir to the internet yep for
real then we got hold up Dam we got roll
back crazy okay give me a second cuz you
guys in here okay we got Necromancer Z
member for 23 months Lord gold I believe
parts of of embrace group I embracer
group iip and individual Studios is next
Sega Square Enix Etc is too big for a
bit other options nether realm or IO
interactive another real I'm fighting
games
M let me see then we got JD gamer $5
Super Chat my question is not who they
will get but when will the next
acquisition announcement be made hey are
we waiting uh one month 3 months a year
I say I agree with that I think like a
year or so maybe got let this settle for
but again if if some if something
happens to fall into their lap you never
know you never know and then we do know
that this is because this is dragged out
so long this has held them up from other
things they want to do so we got to see
I mean it could be that that the
intention was was was uh you know
Crystal D all along a Soo all along and
they just haven't been able to yeah
could be yeah and we have elemental po
$5 Super Chat digital frry is impressed
with the 60fps consistent performance of
redfall is the Sky
Fall good on redfall good on redall at
least they they made the promise they
delivered on that then we got JD gamer
$10 Super Chat Microsoft is taking
PlayStation's identity by becoming the
owners of all the IP the classic
PlayStation was known for imagine a
world where crash spiral Tomb Raider
Persona and Final Fantasy are all Xbox
IP Xbox is the new
PlayStation yo this guy's outside with
it I see facts it's kind of happening
it's kind of happening then we have
Stitch member for 46 months Lord gold
question does Sony still have to do an
8020 deal until next year or is Sony's
dropping the marketing and do they have
to they have to show the Xbox logo on
all of the trailers now that's a that's
a good question right I I don't know
let's get that Xbox up there all right
let's go
guys come on son think everything will
go like normal until the uh contract
with PlayStation's up yep you're gonna
have to pay like you
owe you goonna pay you gonna pay
us you
wait 800 pound gorilla you gonna pay
like a 800 pound you're ridiculous we
have Spartan
6615 Super Chat Xbox will have to hit
hard and go for the stealth strike
before Sony loses their number one
position get Square Enix and Sega Sony
last vision is Xbox on
top the last thing before they die is
Xbox number one they get thrown
overboard you see
them Yo you
stupid oh
no get thr like like Leonardo DiCaprio
sinking in night yo you Wilding y'all
Wilding right
there
oh not the Titanic y'all doing the most
y'all out of
control you're going to the bottom of
the ocean Buck
over yo I waited for this day yall said
it wasn't gonna
happen and I told y'all no PlayStation 6
this is going to happen to
you m you know why you're really afraid
because I told y'all a lot of stuff
before and y'all dismiss
me and now you know that I'm 98% right
you said damn it
man God so that's why they don't want to
hear you they be afraid and this go this
going to happen they said shut that man
up yo some of the chat said I love you
Rose yo I'm done not the Titanic love
you Rose I can't yo remember when I said
it was a week before I said um they need
to get their stuff because we talking
about the Cyber Punk title uh topic and
I was like yo
um what's what's the uh the the ones
that did redf what was them um um Arcane
arcan remember remember I said Arcane we
looking at you yeah then a week later
Arcane drops to 60 frames per second
mhm I have been on a prophetic rooll you
you been on fire Jim Ryan yes no
PlayStation 6 I I ain't with you there
but you rocking you rocking strong yo
when when wait till my next trick pop up
and for my next trick I just like how
bad they are at you that we had a topic
that says what's
next like that the fact that they are
that mad at you because I think it is
funny like how dare they talk about
after what you did
I have to admit I am getting a lot of
enjoyment off of the emotions of people
with that so thank you King for that you
have definitely red them up continue
you're
welcome we got Joe Repco AKA
FL uh $5 super chat with a little bit of
scripture here as Jim looked upon the
Army approaching his crumbling Kingdom
and turned to his Twitter generals and
said all right I'mma head out said the
book of X Messi messy flame get back to
writing you out here writing novels but
Jim Ryan and book of X
continue and we got JD gamer $5 Super
Chat Jim gambled his career on being
able to block ABK we know how that
turned out I know it's not g g his
career on it yeah okay wouldn't it be
crazy if kic ends up running
PlayStation he will throw it into the
ground bobb's available yeah Bobby will
be available shortly shortly yeah he
taking that bag oh he taking a bag but
it's no guarantee taking a bag and going
to chill I mean that's a nice parachute
man yeah I mean these guys what what do
they do they end up on a board
somewhere the dayto day stresses of
running a company can really get to you
so yeah I wouldn't blame him I think
he's gonna buy some islands somewhere
and cash out Chill on his own little
island cuz his situation is a little
different than the average person all
that's why I don't know if he going to
be on any round tables yeah could be
could be he ain't going to be there I
agree they don't they don't want Bobby
there anyway they may wait they may wait
till January and be like hey we needed
time to yeah get away from the pr aspect
of having to deal with him I'm not
having to deal with the fact that he's
not there January s I'm with you on it I
think that's how it's going down yep and
then be a smooth transition of power
he's already gone and then they still
got to announce what they going to do
with that we talking about who's going
to be the head who's going to be in
charge yeah who's going to be the head I
would give it ID give it to iara but
iara I mean Sarah's out there too
Sarah's there Sarah's there but iar I
don't know maybe want to stay maybe
leaves maybe never
iara seems like he wants to stay at be
at
blizzard he doesn't want to be over all
of it he just wants to be over blizzard
like yeah it is kind of different now
these guys you know we talk about rod
they coming in different different
positions or whatever if there's anybody
I think that walks really is Rod just
because Rod Rod's thing is going into
different places and you know closing
out and fixing and closing out things I
mean if there's something internally if
rod says hey send me the 343 and let me
see what I can do there whatever did you
see the Tweet though from Ron yes like
uh he said something about my ID right
put up his old Microsoft ID it was like
yo I wonder if it still work y going to
let me use my own J right like so to me
I just look at as as as a playful thing
that I mean if you not happy and you
don't want to let's be honest like guys
yeah you're about to merge yeah and if
you're not happy about that part of me
is like you ain't really necessarily
going to be joking about that you know
what I'm saying so that's why part of me
is like it leads to my whole thought
process that these dudes be undercover
agents
bro what I said like y'all keep laughing
here we go every time somebody goes to a
company they leave Microsoft when they
go to a company they wind up acquiring
said company always and this this is
always happened and they went over there
and two of the most high-profile dudes
happens to be over there and we're
talking about two coming back and then
one post his old id was like I wonder if
this he got to post another tweet that
just says it took y'all long enough or
what I personally with the particular
circumstance that one on with with
Activision I don't think anyone in like
the company's going to take over I think
it's going to be an outty it's gonna be
Sarah s if she's not there full time
she'll be put there like as like a
temporary lead just and I don't think
she's going to be intervening in
anything with with with Activision I
think she's just going to be there to
make sure the company rolls the way
should and she'll be reporting directly
to Phil like and then I think when
Phil's ready to retire they'll replace
her with someone and then he'll take
she'll take his I I don't think so I I
never thought that she' take Phil spot
and nope not not one time uh I believe
that she's she'll be over ABK and the
same way they'll put somebody in um you
see how Mikey bar is running his
particular situation at blizzard I
believe he stays there right it maybe at
least for two years maybe that depends
on him um but I believe Sarah is like
Matt mat booty as how Matt overlooks the
zenx stuff but you know Todd Howard no
Matt is is a game Studio Xbox
Studios you know he's still his eyeballs
are still peeping you know don't don't
don't don't get it twisted he's watching
those dudes um I believe that they put
her in a position just like that to
watch those guys and everybody stay in
position except for Bobby Bobby got go
Bobby got to go you know
Bob cannot he cannot stick around too
much political ramification but when
Phil goes I think Matt takes his spot so
you think booty will take spot right
because I believe Matt has the
temperament going forward oh he said
he'll Buy Sony out of business that's
the type of it yeah
um we know where this is going we know
where this is going now I know why okay
I got you it it's other things about
Matt's teint that shows me he has the
gumption for the fight OG Midway days
tremendous respect like is is is is this
in the sense that you have a friend and
Phil brought his friend that he knew
that he needed that that was there and
you know him and Matt is is pretty cool
Matt has a certain Killer Instinct that
is necessary in this position you love
that quote and yeah I love the fact that
that came out people was telling me in
the background he that dude and I was
like really it's like no no no he's that
dude if it wasn't for him games would uh
um wouldn't be day and date on in Game
Pass he made them stick to that I'm like
I don't believe that then when the
paperwork came out I was like I'm I had
to you know say I'm sorry but the fact
of the matter is I believe he has the
temperament that is necessary are saying
the booty yo I can't with k k put
respect on that man's Day Mad Mad
peaches booty
Emoji come on y y'all got to stop y'all
got to stop somebody said booty is a
goon pause done I believe so I believe
he's the strong armed Guy The Enforcer
that this the shooter that you need I
mean he he reminds me of Beanie
seagull the truth yeah he he reminds me
of Beanie seagull and if y'all don't
know it's get down and lay down kick
your boy let kick the ball over the Fist
and let him know yard is this yo got he
got that j i a go for Jay lost that one
that was be was on him he's not playing
with that boy got a hold of him and
shook him up boy boy sweeter than a
Hershey
Kiss that was hard that was hard
continue God is this yes hold on a
second then we got let me see we got
Aaron with the booty single I'm
done yo
booty
booty yo y'all stupid continue
pees I'm done with y'all with the
peaches Aaron with the five five pound
Super Chat Love by Iron Lord crew Big
Love from London great to see uh Tom in
here too my fellow gonner peace and
blessings to you all Xbox for life baby
Sal Aon salute salute we got JD gamer $5
chat panel what would be the surprise
move SL acquisition that would uh be
most disruptive to PlayStation and an
industry transforming event Namco Capcom
Square cdpr it's it's
Square it's so it's so associated with
PlayStation that it would just be out it
feels out of the field I'm gonna I'm
willing to say you take out play you
take you buy Square Enix PlayStation
can't compete at any way shape or form
anymore sure they might be able to
Output quality games but I feel like
Square Enix was very vital in them
filling in gaps and if you take away
that ability I don't see PlayStation
being able to release more than two
games a year if that they got peaches
and me I'm done they are out of
control they are out of control
continue then we have JD gamer2 Super
Chat Darth field showed up showed out
and ABK deal
closes
then we have elitist edits $5 Super Chat
yes merge Crystal Dynamics with the
initiative and call them Dynamic
initiatives how about Crystal
initiatives Crystal
Edition then we got JD gamer again $
Super Chat who told PlayStation to go
and poke a Sleeping Bear and then laugh
about it while still in its cave doing
doing it over and over again well the
Bears awake and PlayStation's dead
already messy there we got splint diffus
$2 Super Chat you need to get down or
lay down son Phil
outside is outside definitely
outside then we have boy member for 26
months Lord bronze them Runway
them you can't be stuck and strong
Jamaican to like that n
Son Xbox Dem
you can't be using console war straight
Jamaican talk Man Bon talk you can't be
doing that
man sh that was
wild I don't want hear nothing about
them Pony I don't
py can't be war in
Jama we can't be having that rude boy
talk like that nah son you doing too
much
that's too strong Call to
Arms then we got JD gab $5 Super Chat
darville is out here in his full Michael
Buyers gear slashing up PlayStation fans
hopes and dreams he's delivering
nightmares to Fanboys and gold nuggets
on
Xbox y they messy today bro then we have
Gamers play HUD zero a member for 34
months Lord Bron Advance the line the
Xbox world order has begun ABK is the
Boon that will fortify Game Pass and
make smaller devs confident to jump in
with Team
Green yep be could
be then we have King goris $5 Super Chat
where Microsoft by Sega which one of
y'all is going to try to knock me off
the outrun leaderboards as good probably
that's probably all that's all three
that's all three of us cuz we outrun
heads we a lot of arcade outrun got fun
sound shower let's go yeah that was my
only oh
God I remember the first time I won I
almost
cried oh my God love that song oh hell
yeah classic JD gave her $5 Super Chat
can't wait to see crash Bandu outside of
PlayStation headquarters screaming
through a megaphone saying come out here
I got the games all of
them come out Kratos they got
us Kratos come out they got us you know
would be funny if if Kratos just came
out just started just start they just
started fighting yeah
messy in the suit there we got let me
see there we see Spartan 661 $5 Super
Chat I want an update for every single
Activision game to have an Xbox logo on
the load screen on all Sony console
maybe changes it to a Game Pass act yeah
messy
yeah sonic pull up in a
warthog y messy today boy I knew this
let's go let's go Sonic then we have
then we have Mr to opinionated $2 Super
Chat Bobby should go turn PlayStation
into a destiny sweat shop yo that that
would probably be his his method he go
like okay what can we commodify what can
we turn into into something that here
let's make Destiny great
again disrespectful continue There we
got n nay Super Chat we all about
filling
booty filling the booty wow whoa whoa
time
[Music]
on Wow time that was that was actually
continue Mr two opinionated once again
$2 Super Chat that court case revealed
Who Booty was # booty goon
y I want you and I'm going to have you
we going to do this the easy way on the
we are not doing booty goon we are not
doing that time on booty goon that works
that works booty goon
nah don't work that's crazy that's crazy
good then we got then we have some Jitsu
Sage $5 Super Chat uh Xbox needs to do a
how to fun game pass video has payback
for how to share games and show someone
purchasing Call of Duty on a PlayStation
console yo y'all right
now this is like you know what this
remind me of with this ABK thing finally
going down this is literally remember
the Matrix
Des this is Zion like we are in Zion for
the Xbox
Community it's raining indoors for no
reason mad people wet for Reon even
though they underground like this is
what's going on we are in like the the
level okay all right add can you is
tight tight he spinning there I'm hungry
let's go ad hungry yeah can you dig
it good then we have splend differ $2
Super Chat this mean Lord booty gotta be
next in the
real we got to get get them in the real
exactly then we have ch chair Walker $
five Super Chat congrats to Minecraft
with over 300 million unique units sold
and passed to the Jedi DLC salute salute
salute then we got split difference
again $2 Super Chat y'all got fat while
we starved it's our turn beefy
wow looking real beefy very beefy New
York King of New York that's it beefy
that's it we good all right let me read
the next uh five numbers for the code
for the free game that was uh donated by
Champagne
Supernova x c d c p yeah that's x c d
CP yeah got it y got two more left 10
more letters now we did skip the um
patreon uh question Cu uh Tom respect so
we got to get it off shout out to snail
killer hello R of the Lords we all
understand that today the show will be
messy I want to bring something to the
round table we should appreciate the
real benefits that this merger will
bring to Consumers and the workers of
ABK we Community will now have access to
more games for a low lower entry point
and I don't know about all of you but me
growing up having access to two new
games a year was a lot also the workers
of ABK will now have an option to create
a good work environment for themselves
we should celebrate the positives before
plunging into console war zone X this
should have been R early also games may
take a while to hit game pass because
they may must want to launch on console
on PC at the same time PC store
integration cannot be easy to achieve
now back to being petty Square Enix is
next online hey yo he said all that
positive stuff to at the end so yeah to
stale Killer's Point y'all what do you
think about let's get at it because he's
spinning he losing control um what do
you think about as far as being a
positive thing to Consumers and the
workers of ABK go at it definitely a
positive thing for the workers um you
know it's a positive thing to Consumers
I ain't playing none of these games GES
but uh you know I could definitely see
the average Call of Duty fan getting a
series s just to play Call of Duty every
year and the funny thing
is you could probably keep those Call of
Duty fan Just Call of Duty will probably
keep people in Game Pass for three to
four months Just Call of Duty good so
you know that's that's a long time
that's almost half the year yeah and
then it's really on just micro not to
mention if Microsoft continuously drops
games like they want to every other
quarter or every quarter and then you
know drop little games in between those
like they go right back to Call of Duty
after they play them yeah so it's just
like you can literally keep people in
that service the whole time you know and
and it's it's cost affordable you know a
lot of people can't afford to go out
spend 60 $70 a couple times a year uh so
you'll get more of those people to jump
on here because they might not have they
weren't going to buy that game anyway
that's that's why like people kill me
and they're like well you know Game Pass
hurts first g game sells no game pass
only hurts the people that were going to
buy that game if if you weren't going to
buy that game it was you you weren't
going to buy it anyway so they wouldn't
have got your
money yeah and what about his being
petty Square Innings his next
online I would absolutely love that oh
they be interesting no it's not it's not
about being interested I just don't
think it's I don't think it's in reality
I just don't like I think that the
Japanese government would shut both of
those down Sega and square units I don't
see them letting it happen and I don't
see
Microsoft letting here's the thing they
can't want to get into that part of the
world and Japan and sell better in Japan
and stuff like that and then something
like a Square Enix being shut down from
the Japan government or what the
Regulatory Agencies down there and then
just be okay with that it's just like I
feel like that's why they're GNA stay
away from these big Publishers because
it's just especially you know Square
Enix Sega you know they got to go
through the Japan regular uhor process
and I don't know if they will be okay
with an American company owning a big
Japanese brand like that so it's just
like look is it possible yeah but I
would just say Microsoft doesn't want
none of that smoke right now right now
they want to just keep the stuff they
have in line show some games and then
maybe sometime in the next year and a
half to two revisit buying maybe a
publisher but I think they will buy
individual companies or buy companies
off of companies but as far as like
buying an entire arm I don't see them do
that again so publishes are R that's you
already here yeah for for the
foreseeable future king your thoughts on
um the consumers and the workers of ABK
post deal I think they're in a better
position now MH um because the unions
will be able to thve
I think Microsoft has lit a fire under a
lot of these companies where they're
going to see now that unionization is
going to happen across um all companies
and it's going to give a greater voice
to the the workers who were under
conditions that were less than you know
ideal to to say the least you know not
to even downplay what went on there
there's reasons why this deal had to go
through other than just video games and
the workers are a large part that you
know to be played in this uh this
scenario but um no this is this is a
good thing for them and I'm I'm really
more than happy for them everybody has
to forget that you know it's it's about
games at some point but yeah the people
that make these games was under
conditions that were really bad and
there's a reason why everybody wants
Bobby gone and don't want Bobby
associated with this uh you know
environment and there's a reason why
that um the the letter came out with
Phil saying that you know he'll be in
charge and Bobby answered to him there's
to reassurances going forward because
there was promises that were made that
Bobby won't you know be involved so
again Bobby will be gone the environment
will get better and the unionization
will happen with these workers so they
can have a better work environment I
think that's a great thing no doubt
solve your thoughts on what the deal
means for consumers and the workers of
ABK I mean the consumer part is obvious
man it's like it's like now Game Pass if
you ever thought that game pass was
lacking in any way shap before uh this
is definitely going to reinforce that
uh give you a big boost of things to
play um and that's the key right Game
Pass is the platform not the hardware
Game Pass is the platform Game Pass is
what they have to reinforce and their
goal moving forward which is why we know
they're not going to stop buying things
is that yeah they need to keep
reinforcing Game Pass they're going to
keep buying stuff to put into the game
pass for you will the price go up
eventually yes it's going to go up more
it's going you know it's not going to be
egregious but it's going to go up um but
you're G to have a lot to play so for
consumers what you're paying for the
amount of choice that you have there is
is unprecedented in the gaming space and
nobody can say that you can say whatever
you want about consolidation not liking
whatever the fact of the matter is that
as a consumer deal there isn't a better
deal in game and and the truth and it's
remained true throughout even maybe at
its onset when they still hadn't had the
first party stuff or the good first
party stuff hadn't come in maybe you
could say he it's not worth it for me
having it but now you know if if you're
in this ecosystem you should have Game
Pass straight up now for the workers
same thing you you mentioned this
earlier where you know the consensus
from people that have been interviewed
uh kind of behind the scenes saying that
hey this is an opportunity for True
change at the company right yeah
obviously they probably internally did a
lot of things to address the negativity
that was going on there um specific
situations that involve Bobby and stuff
like that whatever they did internally
to kind of quiet that storm a little bit
is is whatever but at the end of the day
those are Band-Aids those were not real
sweeping changes to the culture there
which is what M that's what Microsoft's
goal is right so the first thing is
Bobby gotta go Bobby so Bobby got two
months for for a lot of people in there
I imagine for I imagine for a lot of
people that is the key first and
foremost Bobby gotta go Bobby gotta go
Bobby's influence has to go Bobby's way
of thinking has to go and it has to be
again I Phil said well somebody else
going to be making the decisions I.E me
yeah report to me was the line report to
me right um so yeah I I completely
believe that that people in there are
like hey now we're coming in here
especially these people look I know I'm
I'm sure plenty of people are just happy
having jobs right you know being
considering the state of the industry
but I can't believe that these people
that were once part of like Toys for Bob
and Raven and these and these other uh
devs are not hopefully looking at the
situation looking at it in a hopeful way
and saying hey maybe this does give us
the opportunity to to work our way off
of the gravy train that is Call of Duty
and be able to make something us as fans
that's the first thing we gravitate to
oh man they be hopefully be able to do
all this other stuff the reality is of
business maybe mean that's not
necessarily the case but I think I think
the possibility with mic Micosoft exists
there because yes Call of Duty is super
important right and I've talked in the
past about ways that you continue the
Call of Duty gravy train one of which is
okay hey maybe you don't release an
actual game every year and let each game
live for two years and make sure you
have a big content drop around the same
time or you do the other crazy thing
which is the opposite and you add a team
to the dev cycle therefore giving each
team four years to make the game or four
or five right and then they can create a
game that differentiates itself a little
bit more from the previous one right and
maybe take more risk with Call of Duty
but you continue the gravy train and you
just add you just gave each team more
time to make their game so maybe that's
that's a solution but end of the
day you know if you're a small if you're
a Toys for Bob and you're like man we
were doing good with crash we had the
opportunity to bring crash back hey let
us continue that let us hey you have
banjo let's let's let us make let us
take a shot at banjo um so that's the
hope and I think
that they know the situation better than
than any of us and I think in their
heart of hearts they believe that's a
possibility within Microsoft at least
they're G to be heard anyway um as
opposed to stamp down like no go go make
this Call of Duty um so yeah I think I
think both things are true both things
are true it is it is a new day at
Activision Blizzard King uh and things
look bright I think ad you was goingon
to say something fu yeah I think that's
they might take down the story of Call
of Duty to every other year thing
because like people would say Call of
Duty makes them all this money no Modern
Warfare 2 makes them all I mean war zone
2 makes them all this money that's money
uh so you know I'm curious how much the
single player aspect of Call of Duty
brings in money and I'm
will I I'm willing to to bet that it
does bring him money but it's only a
fraction of the money that comes into
call Dy but this is the thing there was
which one was the one that they did only
multiplayer that's I was about to ask
you a question did one year they try to
not do single player they did it and
it's like even if whatever the small
percentage of people that play it played
it right and you would think that
logistically hey it doesn't matter we
could release a multiplayer suite and
forget about the single player for
whatever reason people consider it a
package yeah and the package doesn't
feel as robust without that single
player even if they don't play it they
had the metrics that show that people
wasn't playing yeah right and but the
thing is the metrics also showed that
when they gave him just the multiplayer
they was upset they were they were upset
too I think I think the reason that the
multiplayer was so first off they're
they're charging full price for these
things yeah remember that to that's a
good point so it's just like and and not
to mention that's the standard you know
if they came out and said look you know
we're going to work on a good fleshed
out single player every couple years and
then uh you know but
the caveat to that is we are they could
do that too it's like you know but the
caveat to this is but what we will do is
will put more effort into war uh into
war zone 2 you have more events you have
more stuff going on you only get the
single player every two years and if you
buy the single player you'll get like
you know special stuff in in war zone 2
but you know that it's out it's no
coincidence that they have been redoing
everything to go into war zone 2 and
that's because War Zone 2 is generating
the income that people that they really
vitalize and and to me it's just like at
the end of the day their biggest thing
oh here
comes here comari jaar's in the
building if if it wasn't 4:30 I would
say you could come in here and say about
your little thing with Call of Duty
because I know he's a huge Call of Duty
fan he said he want we break protocol
shout out to J Bar $20 Super Chat
whatever fellas when is King and Cog
joining my Call of Duty
lobis can't you going we going to get to
smoke with him and then crossplay you
muted you muted is
zoom you still muted as hey yeah my my
bad my bad when it when when it's when
it launches day and day and Game Pass
I'll be right over
there just just just so you and I could
play the same game but you could play it
for more
money so you go you that's you play jar
with with it's it's free and gay pass
and then he okay let's see I'll join you
when you pay and I come in for
free that's when I show you're
ridiculous he's laughing J laughing yeah
that that's my personal opinion on the
matter I think that you know I do think
they're going to to loosen up the grip
on Call of Duty in some degree but it's
it's not going to be drastic you know I
I think that they're very serious about
you know I do think toys for Todd
whatever that company's called to for
Bob to for Bob I I I do think that they
will probably be freed from the Call of
Duty machine because uh Microsoft don't
have a whole lot of the games they make
so what what I laugh the dudes is like
nah what we going to do is we GNA mess
up the
b y we going to buy them to mess up the
B y'all sit down and y'all play y'all do
what y'all was doing no they going to be
a factory shop forever y y sit there and
think y'all was free thing that we don't
know though is like how many of those
what are those Studios working on like
how much of those Studios working on
those games like clearly you know Toys
for Bob was doing something because they
were still making crash Crash Bandicoot
games so it's just like logistically how
much of that studio was actually helping
with Cod was it animations was there
only a stu a part of the studio helping
it like there's a lot of information we
just don't have when it comes to that
and I think they're G to still be do
they going to be a s out all that all
that hopes and dreams for B toys B why I
gota be hopes and dreams for toys B they
GNA go in to work on
Tuesday they gonna be like yo so I
really want to make you know I was
thinking
about get their freestyle off like word
you was thinking about that well how I
was thinking is go right back to what
you was doing cuz we like how the money
was coming in the thing is though is
like it's like I said even I do think
that you know messing with that single
player and doing it every two years I
don't think would affect their bottom
line much because the majority of people
are just playing war zone 2 the majority
of people are buying Nicki Minaj for $20
on war zone outside Nicki's outside for
sure for sure that's that's nice that's
nice um what about what about
Microsoft's Pockets King that the fact
that they could they could get another
team a support Studio to help out let
Toys for Bob
free them free we we didn't buy you for
what we wanted y'all to do some other
stuff we brought you for what you do
this what you do right we didn't buy you
for how good you did
the brought you Elric Boogie do electric
boogie Your Leader said Electric Boogie
he said that there are some franchises
they want to bring back so if they going
to bring back old franchises you got to
let the people who made those old franch
go go to do something but he did not say
nowhere in there that we going to stop
the people from making he said yo it's
stuff that we would look at we would
like to bring back and we will see if
it's feasible but we did purchase y'all
to do what y'all
do so in
hindsight what we what we want y'all to
do is get back to work you was you was
dope at that right I love the way you
made that knife in Call of Duty go back
to making
knives you are ridiculous and and Trey
get ready cuz you up
next you know how we do every Tuesday
rotate rotate so we not messing up the
bag we ain't messing up the bag we got
money to get rotate
rotate I guess to me if they didn't if
they didn't do anything and and continue
letting all those Studios work on Call
of Duty that'd be disappointing to me I
I understand it from a financial aspect
but it's like from what I actually would
like to see from the studio if they did
that then there's literally nothing to
Studio like buying Activision like
benefited me from so well you you wasn't
messing with them anyway remember you
said they ain't got nothing over there
said I don't mess with Call of Duty
right and and let's that was the biggest
portion of this right let that bag work
like let that bag work and then what
they're going to do is they're gonna
work on the king stuff and then once
they get that down pth let them get it
down pth first before they start
switching up right let them make it work
and then they say okay we do have a
window open hey
Bob hey Bob you like you like banjo yeah
all right let's take a couple of Y let's
get some Concepts together and we can
see if y'all if y'all got something
worked out other than that get back to
making
n you're messy I can't with you anyway
yeah they just did y'all see this that
they put Lilith in Call of Duty yeah I
heard about that's going to be crazy
the right now I will say the the
promotional stuff they can do with Cod
is crazy and Microsoft IPS and stuff but
um n to the to the patreon real quick I
pretty much agree I think that's the
part nobody's talking about like I said
the consumer I'm a consumer first and I
dict more people getting that chance to
access it and that's obviously at most
people if they in the game pass service
at a lower price point for the guy that
just buys the one game a year because we
know that guy right we know that guy who
is just either Call of Duty 2K you know
Madden and that's it for the year and
this is one of his you know major games
that he buys so yeah for the consumer
hands down and for the um the work
workers yeah no one's talking about that
that was the reason why they got
themselves in trouble in the first place
because of all the conditions that was
going down over there and that's why to
King's Point while Bobby's reputation
was really hit and then someone lost
their life remember someone lost their
life someone committed to us yeah this
was serious business un alive their self
yeah yeah straight up so it's like at
the end of the day you know the
conditions were not good so like like s
you always say like I always look at
well what's the alternative no one buys
them or someone that no one else likes
May me 10 C whoever buys them or they
don't get bought Y and they start
spiraling downward because of what's
going on so I always look at that that
is a better alternative as far as them
being acquired by Microsoft than what
the status quo was so that's how I look
at it as far as the other thing that you
know people back there not get enough
credit for is the promotion of the
unionization Microsoft is staying out
the way they're not blocking that and
then um King had us with an article with
the what is it the CWA and there strides
there and they seem very Pro Microsoft
acquiring them so look you know they got
to keep their word and make sure that
these work environments are are good and
sustainable and that's on them but at
least I like the idea of that versus
what was going on before that's where
I'm at with it so anyway let's move on
we got to get this uh last two topics
popping we got couple superat superat
get Super Chat we we got we got two
topics right yeah they quick okay cool M
we got CWU $2 to chat beware # Master
cheeks beefy booty goons outs man not
getting the beefy off of that n e Guns N
heing there we got splend difference $5
Super Chat Phil to Jim you can't acquire
big companies you not like me you ain't
no game like me you ain't no games after
this year you not like me snitching to
the CMA son you not like me oh not the
J cops not like
me I
didn't wait a minute n
l not like like
me yo not the 50 y'all
Wilding we already got J Bari we got G
$2 Super Chat here's some new info get
back to work
that par Savage Savage that's it we
caught up all right no doubt this is AD
oh oh the code the code yes please yeah
the code all right so the next code up
for the free game giveaway that was from
Champagne poppy Champagne Supernova is c
d
m9g That's c d
M9 G we got one last Cod left part of
that Cod and whoever gets it I want
y'all to you know tag me and let me know
what you got no doubt no doubt moving on
this is if you have you said what game
that is yeah he they don't even know
what they getting no no see because I
want to know who really got
it fair this is this is putting y'all to
the test for real now a lot of times
people give away games and y'all just
you know hey man got a
game you know what you giv away money
for this what the only copy of
Spider-Man 2 on XX
yo it's it's wild you never know what it
is and who says it's it's not that it's
not that mess well I mean you would have
already gave all the codes away if it
was a PlayStation game I know shut
up anyway moving on now that we got that
out yeah adct you're up U it's your
topic man Lords of the falling a lot
going on you want me to read the Press
statement or you good you got yeah go
ahead so yeah this is for the Lords of
the Fallen um Twitter account and uh
yeah this week is said Lord for we like
to take this opportunity to thank all of
the content creators who have worked
with us to enable the rapid deployment
of patches updates and performance
improvements ahead of tomorrow's
exciting launch of Lord of the for
fallen as such PC and PlayStation 5
players will be able to enjoy the game
as intended the Xbox version is
currently being updated bringing it to
parody with the other platforms and the
patch will release over the coming days
so uh this set off of a bit of a Twitter
Firestorm and um sounds like again that
that the day one patch will be um
available for PlayStation 5 PC but the
Xbox one will get an inferior version
without the patches so adct you were
very passionate about this subject
obviously me and you covered uh Lord of
the Fallen at Pax West I believe and um
got a chance to play this game so like
what are your thoughts about all this
stuff going
on you know the biggest thing that I
feel like the shows is just
this industry needs to be way more
transparent on what's going on behind
closed doors on these these these builds
and stuff I understand it could affect
your bottom line when it comes to
selling the game but at the end of the
day like none of that's my concern the
fact that this company released an Xbox
version of something that didn't have
the day one patch I don't care if it was
certification matters or anything um if
your over online did not have that game
coming out before you could do
everything you should have delayed it
even a week would have been fine um
that's besides the fact uh the game's
buggy it's glitchy the performance is
horrible and what's funny is when the
game functions correctly it's probably
one of the best Souls game that's
out but all of that's irrelevant when
the game doesn't function correctly you
know the I don't know if you guys saw
the Twitter post it literally looked
like a like a slly on PowerPoint oh damn
it was so bad on performance wow wow and
it's just like like and I'm sorry we
continue to
see this happening over and over again
game being broken here game being broken
there I can understand a little bit more
when it comes to networking issues a
game just been overloaded like payday
three I I'm more sympathetic with that
but when you release your game and it's
not playable because you decided to go
ahead and jump the gun because you
wanted holiday sales over the condition
of your game I feel like Playstation
Xbox Nintendo and all steam they all
need to pull your game off their their
store because we're getting to the point
where they are very comfortable
releasing broken games to us and not
caring because there's no consequences
you've been on your square with this I
got to give you that you've been on your
Square since the Cyber Punk stuff you've
been on your square with that I just I
want to ask you like is there more stuff
going on like there's a lot of
controversy I was as me and you spoke
during the week and were telling me how
like there was also some some issue with
the way codes were being distributed or
something or is that completely
unrelated okay
so the way that that irritated me is
because it was it was a tool that was
used to hide the performance of the Xbox
one uh just on the front lines like you
know someone sent me a um a screenshot
on a website that was Distributing Lords
of the Fallen codes and before before
the game came out they weren't offering
you Lords of the falling codes for Xbox
oh so it wasn't even available it was
only on PlayStation and steam got it
okay why is that you know we've seen
throughout the time that they have no
problem like when we played Starfield
they had a day one patch after we we
were playing it for like a week and a
half to two why not give us that and be
transparent with yo here's Xbox code it
might be a little late in terms of a day
one pack patch that's because the game
probably was literally unplayable before
that day one patch and and to me I I'm
sorry I'm starting to get on this on
this hill with people there needs to be
some government over uh reach on this we
got to bring them in because at this
point what what's gonna fix it we we say
we're not buying the game they still do
it we say we're buying the game they
still do it we we lash at them on
Twitter they still do
it it's like they they value all that
money they can make over value being
transparent and telling the truth with
their customers how many companies need
to get sued over false advertising a
game he's on his Square y'all now we got
to talk about it we got to talk about
and then people s to say don't pre-order
I don't believe in that I don't like you
should I get it logically you should
wait for the pre-order but if if if a
company is taking advantage of your
passion you the hypeness you have for
their game and they're choosing instead
of making you
excited when you play it they're using
that to sell you a false reality there
is more issue with that than there is
the other way around so we should never
go after consumers for supporting a
hobby they play and just completely
avoid the companies delivering games
that don't work I feel you on the broken
part and I feel you
on kind of taking the power back but I
guess my confusion is you're saying do
pre-order cuz isn't the pre-
them oh okay I just want to be clear
what saying I was saying I understand
where people are coming from but I don't
like the standpoint people blame the
people pre-ordering the the the problem
is the developers Publishers that's
releasing it in that condition I don't
care if if 10 million people pre-order a
game we should never blame the consumer
for just purchasing a game it's always
on the people delivering the game
interesting interesting I want to get
solv next on this this is a is a is a
good it's a good discussion I'm dying to
get his his thoughts on it you know
obviously the laws of the fall in the
codes you know um obviously we they put
out the statement that the PC version
and the PlayStation version is going to
have the day one patch real quick let
let me address someone said in the
comment section they said uh stop buying
the games this is the way our economy
runs I get that but that's the reason
they implement the Shady marketing
tactics and Shady PR taxes where you
can't play a game for this they they
restrict you from saying that there's so
so many incidences were uh what was the
um the the Kojima game the one that last
no the last one uh the Metal Gear Solid
5 I don't know which one it was the you
guys remember the the the testing
solution they came out with that pretty
much lock you in a room and there is so
many Shady tactics that these companies
are using to sell you a dream I don't
blame the people for thinking the game
works so it's like you can't really go
off of that telling people not to buy or
telling people you know not not not to
commit on on a problem because they're
literally using some of the shadiest
tactics that's in the industry but part
of it I got to push back a little I mean
part of it part of it is if we're still
enabling the pre-order because of our
hype they they're praying on our hype
which I agree with you but if we are
still buying it the pre-order then we're
part of the problem like part of us
shouldn't be like y we not going to buy
nothing from you until we see that your
product work kind of thing don't you
think like some people should just hold
off cuz we're emotional like as Gamers
like we see something we want the statue
we want the the extra M you know I feel
you on that but then there's companies
that say you can't talk about this game
till the day it comes out or the day
after it comes out or you can't talk
about this particular part until this
particular part of the Embargo there for
every scenario where you know we have
power to take it away from that they can
easily just rewrite that and just take
it right back from us it's at the end
end of the day I've said it the majority
of the biggest W's that this iner has
ever won on companies was before that
stuff even
launched U um Star Wars Battlefront 2
game wasn't even out we had them
reversing those policies Xbox Live gold
price increase didn't even happen we had
them reversing those policies your
wallet there's too many people that
don't pay attention what's going on beh
they don't keep their ear to the ground
not on YouTube and Twitter all day long
they're going to buy the game there's
there's probably 15 of them to one of
us there's not enough information
cycling around the Casual Market to stop
people from buying a game like that
that's why You' seen the majority of the
time they have reversed these policies
has been because it's a social media
outcry before money even came into the
picture so you're because every time
it's solely just on wallet we lose every
time I'm let's solve again because I got
I got thought I want to make it like I'm
going back and forth so I want to solve
you jumping because it's your turn what
are your thoughts on this whole Lords of
the Fallen thing and then obviously what
can we do to fix this long term with
these Gams being
broken it it it has to be it has to be a
generalized effort by everyone in the
industry and I'm talking about and I'm
talking
about press and us to say no we're
pushing back no we're pushing back the
problem is that's never going to happen
because the NeverEnding desire and cycle
to be first to say hey I have the review
on this good or bad right the idea is to
be first and the race to be first is
what dominates and governs the new cycle
now that's all it is it's it's about be
it doesn't really it doesn't matter what
you're saying about the game so the fact
that these companies understand that and
pray upon that that's just business like
when adct talked about the you know the
the review the the review cycle for uh
metal gear solid uh the phantom pain
yeah they brought everybody to Konami
and and everybody was there for a week
and they played the game they gave them
room and board or whatever and you
played the game there for a week they
control that narrative at the end of the
day if you're if you say the the game
sucks at the end of the day that's what
control they have over that um I don't
know that that you know that implicates
people it's like oh well they they did
all this for me they brought me there
they wind and DED me I have to get game
a good score right that's just something
that's it's understood that not going to
happen problem you have a lot of these
media uh you know small and medium it
they they're too scared to like look
what happened with PlayStation in a few
games you know people sitting there
talking about Starfield and I can name
you three websites that's been banned
from PlayStation so it's just like you
know it's just there's too much
cherry-picking going around and there's
not enough people actually being honest
with opinions it feels like every time
something is a negative output in gaming
these days someone has to follow it
right up with something that's positive
to diminish the negative Port yeah I
mean I guess that that's just the nature
of the sorry I'm distracted they just
told me the 49 is lost I'm I'm so
distracted I'm like if I've not been
engaging I've been looking at the
Highlight everybody's like we're sorry
CNE the rookie kicker missed the field
goal they messed it up sorry yeah I'm
I'm destroy I'm looking at the
highlights destroyed all right the
Browns beat us this is terrible sorry
I'm back to gaming now okay I'm back I'm
focused continue continue so I mean I
don't know man like I I really don't
know the answer to this it's just it's a
it's a messy business it really is and
us just having kind of dipped our toe in
it and just seeing it from the other
side you see how messy it is cuz it's
like you know we get a certain we get a
certain code and we're like oh we're in
that's it we're there we've made it and
then the next week we don't get a code
that that that the expectation is that
we should get because of the size of the
game or the size of the public and it
just doesn't happen right so it's just
it's it is a situation that you can't
really figure out it's very hard to
figure out if you've been in the space
for a very long time chances are that
you're you're probably on a list
somewhere that that it's going to get
you these codes up front early on or
whatever um at the end of the day though
these PR companies their job is to try
to get the game promoted in as positive
a light as possible at the end of Once
the game is in people's hands right it's
first getting the game in people's hands
right they need to talk about it and
review it and then it's presenting the
game in as positive a light as possible
once they give those people that that
code like you're going to get the
response to the game that you're going
to get and then you deal with the
Fallout of that afterwards how you try
to manipulate that before
hand it's just business it isn't fair it
is shyy though it isn't fair it isn't
right it is shyy but it is until they
give you that code that is that is their
prerogative to do that right and to try
to control that narrative as much as
possible it isn't their job to be
objective it's our job to try to be as
objective as possible I I feel you on
that but we've been doing this since
2014 I have and we've been doing the
podcast since
2017 nothing's changed we keep getting
more and more broken games every year I
feel like cyberp Punk was a huge example
that seemed to self-correct some of the
industry to a degree but now right for a
little while yeah but now it feels like
okay you know we we got to get up by
January oh but this game's broken can we
fix it by March yeah we can fix about
March we're releasing in January then
and then and then the next the next part
of that is just
the the reality of the economics of of
the industry is that we always talked
about that the the the effects of the
business side of of gaming on the
creative side of gaming and the fact
that the business side tends to
supersede the needs of the creative side
if the creative side is telling you I
need six more months to put this game in
the place where it needs to be there you
go and and if the numbers are saying
otherwise or we have to get out by this
quarter this F year whatever the case
may be
that supersedes the need for the game to
be to the the game to come out in a
proper State because again as you say
the world we live in is is a world where
that can be fixed post launch and that's
just the reality unless that world
changes and it's like no games have to
come out in X State and I to adct point
about having government intervention on
this like right um I don't know about
that F yeah yeah but I don't know if I
want the government in games we we going
to keep buying broken games stop
pre-ordering let me I got to go I'm
tired so so let me real quick so that's
why and I think Microsoft has learned a
lesson from this right the red fall
lesson right and they they've learned
from other things when you look at a an
Activision Blizzard and a Microsoft you
know uh
purchase they they've seen the they've
seen the problem with doing this right
they have the means to say okay how much
time do you need you look at Starfield
and when you think about when Starfield
was supposed to launch and what that
game probably would have looked like if
I had launched at that time and how it
launched this year that is a perfect
example of
why and it the business part should
never supersede the the need of the for
the art to be good because at the end of
the day the art is going to have to
suffer at launch and it's going to have
to
suffer see the gamers the people that
are passionate about this are going to
run them through the dirt if they do
this to them but at the end of the day
another issue that it falls on us we are
very forgiving we always want to see the
comeback story and we're willing to be
there for that and that's
fair and sometimes we'll run the devs
through the mud and they devs no Dev
wants their game to come out in that bad
State it's a business decision so I I
can't even say I have an answer for it
uh just completely stop buying them when
they come out and that's not going to
happen I have an answer good let's go no
it's just the fact of the matter is that
okay so adct and I was going to review
this game okay and we put in the code
for the Xbox yo send us the Xbox joint
we're GNA review the game so they Hemm
and they hard and they heed and they
hold and then they hit him with the um
yo you want the PlayStation um code and
he was like no we put in for Xbox codes
yo what's up with the X after that well
you know um we get back to you then they
didn't say anything
so now addict realizing the game is
getting ready to come out and I'm like
yo do we have to hit up the iron bank he
is like no King it's more nefarious than
that I said I said what happened he said
the game is broken on Xbox they just
didn't want us to know and they was
giving us the PlayStation c p code I
said are you serious he's like yeah oh
no Alex got a hold of the situation too
I was like what so I go and I check old
no Alex video I'm like oh man these
dudes is dirty right so this is where it
is if you know that one version of the
game and we have the boldest gate people
too and it's the reason why we stole one
of you dudes and you over here on Xbox
now you talking about playround
ridiculous took you didn't we we took
you see heard you got game of the year
candidate we took you didn't
we messy so the fact is that it was
broken on one console MH delay it until
all consoles can release in a good State
don't say oh we're going to drop it on
these right now cuz they ready to go
y'all can get whatever y'all gonna get
and we'll fix it
later why is it not done on
Playstation I have well every time I
turn around every
time it seems like the Xbox version
is oh afterthought uh you know we're
going to go with the market leader and
the install base the money it has a
bigger install base we we'll go for it
you know a lot of pre-orders went down
we got to fund these pre-orders board
decisions in a world is governed by
Gamers I don't like this I don't like it
and and I I especially don't like it
that it's happening to my console that I
love the most right if it was happening
to PlayStation I'd be like
ah You' be laughing I get my live phone
which I'm G do later um I'm like uh but
at the same time
I don't think that it's right on either
console right if it's wrong it's wrong
if if the game is broken on one wait
till it's fixed on both and release it
don't release it on one and talk about
oh we'll fix the other one down the line
that's not good business practices that
right I I don't I don't like that and
the fact that you're trying to keep up
with the board listen this month was a
crazy month for games anyway your game
didn't have to come out this month there
was no reason that your game had to meet
some invisible deadline that you wanted
to put out so it can go against Mario
mushrooms or Sonic All Star or Spiderman
or anything else for that matter in this
month so your game could have slipped to
November oh oh you didn't want to put it
up against the Call of Duty well then
put it in December get the game right
that is released on all platforms
because what I did hear that all
platforms has some form of problems with
said game this game was in in such high
demand that it needed to come out like I
I know that y'all have your your your
baby in high regard but look at the read
the room look at the landscape and put
your game in the best position for it to
win y'all went with the same name of the
fail project from before right and
hoping that you can get a different
outcome but it seems that you're making
the same mistakes put the game in a
Prestige way put it out in a ideal
situation in the December when people
are looking for games you don't need to
meet Black Friday you can just wait and
put it out a little bit they got enough
money though to wait what if they not
built for like a big Studio to be like
yo we can afford they like yo we spent
all this money the game got to come out
and that's a problem that's a problem
that you're saying that okay we need to
return on investment now so we can put
out a broken product and hope to recoup
on the back end you're going to you're
going to diminish your Returns on your
next project because you're putting out
broken projects take the time out put
out a good product so that way that you
built up this Goodwill that your
consumer would say man I love the way
they products come out on all platforms
on Steam on PlayStation on Xbox and say
yo I'm I'm going to support them with
their next product because this product
was so good now you're going to have the
Xbox consumer say ah this project is dog
crap or the PlayStation product consumer
saying oh this this product is
inconsistent in in some of the level
designs or some that's going wrong with
it because I heard there problems over
there or the PC gu saying oh I can't get
it to run it keeps crashing on this end
put out a good product so you can get
build faith in your product so the next
time you release something you don't
have the hesitance inside the community
because right now to be honest with you
adct said he didn't care to review the
game at all he said I don't want the
PlayStation version forget about it I'm
going to talk about this and I love the
stance that he took because he could
have took it and said no we're going to
review the PlayStation version he said
the hell with that I'm going to give
them the smoke that they deserve and
that was right look sorry I want to
point out this is an industry issue this
isn't the people who make Lords of the
Fall it seems like everyone at one point
in time in this industry has done this
to some degree yep shout out to Javid
jaffy I'm a break protocol $5 Super Chat
the problem is once a studio turns it
around most G Gamers forgive the past
mistakes and the cycle continues
absolutely look this is tough this is
not this is not an easy fix I'm more on
as side with solving this because it's
like look we as Gamers have to stop our
fomo for wanting to be first right is
part of this problem I'm not absolving
the the developers and the Publishers
I'm I'm actually I'm not absolving the
the Publishers but because I don't feel
I'm going solve no developer wants their
game to come out and be bad no developer
wants they want the best representation
of the problem they work extremely hard
for these Vision we we interview these
devs the passion is there they are
controlled by a boardroom that either
find a publisher that financed the
project and they got a certain amount of
money and time of when it got to come
out now it could be the Publishers mad
yo we feel this should have been out
when you said you didn't meet your
deadline right or hey the the the
publisher the developers go back to the
poish like look man we just need a
little bit more time in its current
state it's you know it's not good enough
now the addict point where I do agree
with him is I don't like the idea of yo
we got multiple versions platforms of
this game we are going to release one
platform inferior on launch day that's
wild I'm with addict 100% on that like
that is wow that is not a good precent
that is not hey we're going to send this
out to two platforms you got the best
representation of us this is how we feel
it should go but you
you over here you get the other one and
you got to make a statement that's not a
good look you know the other thing I got
to call out and you're goingon to be
surprised about this I got to call Xbox
out from what I'm hearing their
certification process from multiple devs
is a problem and it takes a very long to
get certified for whatever reason I
don't know what that is I'm just telling
you the people I speak to who do not
work for Xbox who are third party
develop
they tell me the certification Pro it it
takes a long time so if that's the case
that got to be corrected because you
can't blame the dev they like yo we gave
it to them and they still ain't certify
our joint what I don't know Lords are
fall in situation I'm not saying that
that's what happened in this case but
let's just say theoretically they gave
it to Xbox and was like yo PlayStation
certified PC certified what's up with
y'all now they G to say to them yo we
not going to launch our game because
y'all holding it back I can't get mad at
the de if if that's the case I don't
know you know what I'm saying but I have
heard that is the joint the other thing
we got to talk about is the straight
business and I know nobody I got to be
corporate Cog again and yall know y'all
don't like it but at the end of the day
we got to be real with the install base
numbers if the certification thing is an
issue or not we know what the
PlayStation install base is it is to a
third Pary company best interest to
launch on the platform that you think
you going to get the most sales on
especially if you ain't getting the Game
Pass back yeah so we got to be real
these dudes are trying to keep their
lights on the reason the certification
hard is because of the series ass we got
to be real we don't know right we don't
know what it is we don't know if little
man we don't know
if theoretically but but theoretically
you you got to pass two certifications
for I will say this and this I'm not
going to snitch out the person because
we ain't going to snitch him out but I
have heard that this game me and I
played this game at packs behind the
scenes this game is a beautiful game on
PC this thing is doing amazing things
with like a lantern it's basically
rendering the game two two times like
when you got this Lantern it it's like
showing another version of reality in
the game this was on a highend PC we
played this thing was beautiful I was
told that even some regular PCS you
better show your build because this
joint is running not good on PC other
PCS right so we must have been playing
on the I this game doesn't run good
exactly so all I'm saying is the the
scope of this game how intense it is
seems to contribute as well but look I'm
with y'all on broken games I'm with
youall on the practice at the industry
we got to stop you know supporting it
and it's a cycle I agree with jaffy that
that keeps on continuing but we also
have to take accountability as Gamers we
also care oh y'all they giving us you
know what I'm saying and the statue yo1
150 up front we got to stop if if we
feel that we also got got to do our part
so that's pretty much all I got of this
this whole situ only thing we that's
something we have to agree to disagree
wee I I just I won't blame the consumer
base that's just me where I definitely
going agree to disagree with you I I
feel you on that and where I agree real
with you I don't want no government on
my gaming I fought too hard I came from
the Mortal Kombat days where dudes is
like oh we don't want no blood and
dismemberment in our game this is bad
for the kids are causing violence
because of video nah get them government
out of my games please art is Art let us
create let the developers have the
vision that they want to have and if you
want to put a mature rating fine if you
want to say I'm not supporting it
because of the graphic nature fine but
when they got involved in gaming bro it
was horrible that's right so that's
where I'm at with that but I feel you at
it CU I do understand your point with um
yo you like yo the process got to stop
and I feel you it does have to stop and
you know it is what it is but I just
want to make sure everybody get their
balls up last topic F all right cool um
Super Chat let's get quick super chats
we have Michael Patton $5 Super Chat
industry unionization raises the cost of
production for Sony 2 while Microsoft
leads in worker right Sony can't keep up
they will
retrench
just then we got Ryan with the one pound
Super Chat thank you so much appreciate
it and we got John Wolf $2 Super Chat
guess the macroeconomics were on the
side of
[Laughter]
xbo woo then we got Ryan went again two
proud Super Chat should Xbox get codor
back now PlayStation version is dead
let's try to get that back man that it's
on Ice that was egregious oh yo K stop
it they like to put things on ice over
here it's all nice baby hold on let me
let me get at somebody real smiling ways
I just feel like it's always Cognito
when to defend these company man it's
look when I read the corporate card cuz
I know it bothers y'all but the reality
is not all I want people to do is see
the other side of something that's all
I'm not agreeing with the practice I'm
just want you to see the other side
before you get emotion see how you
contribute to the problem problem say
you can't say you don't contribute to
the problem that's all I'm saying we all
have to be e accountable both the
corporations for doing the foul stuff
and us as Gamers for being neb with our
foral and our foolishness that's where
corporate car I do it to bother you cuz
I know you get on your
nerve if if if if tomorrow the reviews
for Spider-Man come out that's 7.5 are
you not going to play Spider-Man that's
a good point n IGN already said they
going to be a nine
yeah at least a Nast he said if this
game Ain a
n we got oh we got jaffy already shout
out to jaffy oh shout tsws gaming $5
Super Chat is there a chance us as
content creators can you unify to make a
guild where we speak as one voice one
band One sound drum line drum linish uh
yeah that ain't going to happen because
no we do that now it's called Lords of
gaming.net to become a writer join us in
our fight against all the crap cuz you
won't hear us say something like yeah
that game will be scored at
nine before it even comes out a month
before that's crazy you have you have
little pockets just like just like King
said but across the board that ain't
happening bro it's too many people have
too many other
agendas join
us I said we're caught up cut up no
doubt No Doubt last joint in let me get
the last code let me get the last Cod oh
yes please please all right this is the
last code and I want y'all to tag me to
so I know that you got the game remember
this is brought to you by champagne
poppy Champagne Supernova he got this
game to you with his hard-earned money
and I hope you enjoy this game this is
the last code I'm glad that just stuck
around we have
1,171 people we have 841 likes let's get
those likes up for this last piece of
the code
v23
gz that's
gz good luck doubt and by the time this
topic is done if nobody post I will all
of them in succession to make sure that
y got it no doubt let me get a god
Emperor s king um solv M for six Co I
feel it what you're saying I just don't
believe Dev should not be excused when
they know how long certification
especially when you're a marketing Xbox
look I feel you all I'm trying to
explain is a lot of people don't
understand that the certification
process does take long I don't know I
wasn't in the room I wasn't making this
game I don't know when they submitted it
but I'm just saying theoretically let's
just say they submitted it at the same
time they submitted PlayStation and PC
and if the Xbox One is taking long then
yeah you know what I'm saying so it's
like we have to look at it again from
all sides I'm not saying they're not at
fault and I'm not saying they are at
fault I'm just saying that these are
things that I'm hearing from other
developers and then you know from other
people as far as the um oh shout out to
Smiley because Smiley still talking I'll
talk to you brother um here's the thing
it's not I am Pro consumer first number
one I always care about me that game
pass stuff I think is the best deal in
gaming but at the end of the day brother
if you are that upset all I'm trying to
say is you have to look at all the
factors as to why something is the way
it is that's all I'm say I'm not seeing
you do that you're just projecting and
that's cool you know what I'm saying but
I just want you to see all the factors
that's all I'm coming at
continue uh I think that's it WEAU cool
last one we are up and uh yeah this is
uh King's topic
uh straight from K&N news affiliate uh
Dexter toe
um roblocks how we pronounce it Roblox
roblo
Roo hold up this is we're not talking
about the new consoles that's what I
thought this is King's topic I thought
we talk about the PS5 slim and the P
thought we could we could roll this up
into it because this is a PS5 uh topic
you know we can talk we could talk about
them Slims Slim came out I thought that
was for sure going to be on that's what
I thought so he said Roblox fans are
furious with the state of Playstation
release
it is uh so bad quote so this is um
coming from on a post on the uh official
PlayStation subreddit and again this is
about Roblox that came to um now
PlayStation 5 uh one user posted his
opinions as a first- time playing saying
the entire experience is horrible they
put zero effort into localizing this to
PlayStation the UI is basically an
identical copy and paste from PC
complete with Xbox button indicators the
Avatar The Avatar customized purchase
screens don't load items don't appear to
uh quickly equip things purchase and
just is not fun to navigate so yeah
another user uh from I guess the same
Reddit as far as the criticism Roblox
refus refuses to open Roblox I keep
bustering the name refuses to open and
crashes every time why I've waited so
many years this seemingly lack of
compatibility is yet to be addressed by
the developer so um yeah it seems to be
a frustration uh regarding their their
version on a PlayStation King this is
your topic you wanted to talk about this
so your thoughts sir on this well in
light of what's going on in the industry
lately I've noticed that now that the
shoe is on the other foot and it
happened with one of the biggest titles
roblox actually sells tremendously and
it is a wonderful game and it gets
everybody involved but you can't get it
involved
when the devs doesn't give you a fair
Shake now we have ROBLOX here and it is
an a disarray and I just wanted to ask
yo how did y'all feel about getting this
Roblox did y'all get a chance to play
Roblox because I was anticipating it me
and my son was anticipating it and when
we downloaded it on the PlayStation 5 oh
man it just wasn't in great shape so I
just wanted to know how y'all felt about
it before we talk about the new
consoles I can't adct your thoughts on
this situation with Roblox on
Playstation I don't
care okay but you care with his Lords
that are Fallen yeah see yeah I got we
got a callard on that we can't have you
can't be with you don't care you can't
it's broken it's broken this is your
joint you was you was Lord broken was
Lord I got to get I got get said one
sentence and you interrupted me before I
interrupted oh I interrupted
okay
silence on the set he muted he's
muted no just yeah he mad at me I guess
listen my thing is bro like you
interrupt all the time and then the one
time I interrupt you going thrash me
like like damn thrash anymore like you
thrashing me and I just be I was saying
how is someone going to attack me over
something I haven't even been able to
say yet you literally just said that you
not talking about I said I don't care
and then I was about to follow up with
something and then I just got all right
my bad go ahead all right sorry look at
the end of the day Roblox is a very
popular title and the developers should
have made sure that game ran on
Playstation so it does show that to some
degree these companies don't care what
the main install base is they still
going to give you a half ass product so
it it's just it is what it is at that
point you know uh I guess it's the
certification
issu I guess PlayStation didn't didn't
make sure that game I actually think the
the certification should be a little bit
uh more structured I I've been told it
just pretty much make sure the the Xbox
and Playstation doesn't like break from
it like they don't really test to make
sure anything like the game functions or
anything it's just like it's what I said
like I personally believe these these
companies start ripping these games off
their
stores the moment Roblox came out and it
was in the in the performance and the
degree it was it should have been pulled
off the store and Playstation said get
your stuff together and then we'll put
up back on soor your thoughts on Roblox
robloxs he stepped stepped away for a
minute all right you want yeah go ahead
go talk to me about these robots uh
again um it's funny to me how you find
these
stories I have not found anyone this is
it's my first time hearing about this
look it's unacceptable if it's that's
the case right if if the you the Reddit
sub poost saying that you know it's all
you know bust I just don't like the fact
it's a copy and paste UI I think that's
that's lazy like if it's a copy and
paste UI and you see a you see the red B
button on the Xbox or the if I got a
play if I see a red B button on the Xbox
in the UI then that's that's lazy but um
this is a big game though I mean even
though I clearly don't care about it cuz
I don't play it I keep this game isn't
as big as Minecraft but it's close yeah
this game is huge you're absolutely
right and it's the biggest game on
PlayStation most likely besides
Minecraft cuz what I you know what adct
is right where I my number one metric
for um I like of Engagement especially
on Xbox is Xbox most played and a lot of
it is uh daily active users and stuff
like that I'm still getting official
confirmation on um all the the the
algorithm behind the metric but it's
extremely important to see what's
trending what PE what gamers are playing
yo Roblox always be up there rob it it
be in the top five I'll be like yo what
is this game like I remember seeing it
during the destiny days I'm like why is
this game ahead of Destiny like
create your own
world create your own games this joint
is crazy so yeah I got to I got to bend
the knee man I got to bend the knee this
is a Hu and they and let's be real
didn't Xbox have this exclusive for a
long time a long time it's been on Xbox
for a long time yeah this is a a long
time so this is a huge deal and people
in that Community you know really waited
for the PlayStation version and for them
to get it I know yo I can't pronounce it
I don't know what's wrong roll like roll
your Bo roll your boat blocks okay roll
blocks there we go so I'm like the seat
that upset about it shows you like yo it
must have been a lazy port or whatever
but sa is back I took his turn I jumped
out yeah I mean
um yeah I again I don't I don't play
this game but I get it I get it because
this game I mean this game went into
like like it had an IPO like not too
long ago if we had all put some money
and we'd be rich right
now that's when this game went public um
so it's it's a huge game and for it we
just go back to the topic that we were
talking about it's like they they can
get away with just copy pasted the youi
because people just gonna jump on it
they're gonna complain they're gonna
they're gonna [__] they gonna
moan
but the numbers are gonna be there trust
me the numbers are gonna be there so
yeah people are gonna play that game in
like masses like people don't understand
how popular that game is hugely popular
it is hugely and is and it just is like
a Creation Suite that's really all it is
like it's just you going on there
playing other people's Creations um so
yeah I again it it'll be fixed it'll get
fixed it'll be fine eventually over
there but uh yeah this is uh because you
know PlayStation had uh what the heck is
it called um the heck is that game that
that Xbox passed on that was huge it's
like birth of the wild um what they
passed on that they passed on Phoenix no
no no it's a it's a freeo playay
game genin impact oh Xbox pass yeah yeah
yeah so they've had that for for a while
and now we're flip flopping where
they're getting this game that you know
the Xbox has had for a bit um yeah so
they're going to fix this but again it
just goes back to the idea of listen you
know PE people and this is not the same
type of foro obviously because you can
play Roblox in other places right it's
not like but you if this is your
platform of choice
you want you're waiting right you're
probably going to wait and yeah for for
it to come over in this state is
disappointing um but again don't play it
just the answer is don't play it don't
play and don't play it until they fix it
and you know bad behavior this is the
this is the whole thing right at the end
of the day the roox thing that is that
is a business decision why that game
came over in that state that's just what
it is it wasn't the D be like yeah I
don't care let's just do this no the
devs don't do that so you know it's hard
to it's hard to say I'm going to
penalize the the the publisher or the
the money people behind the game and not
be penalizing the devs at the same time
it's a hard line to draw so at the end
of the day the best thing to do is to
wait until the product morphs into the
product you want it to be and if it
never happens it never happens but uh I
doubt very much that it's not going to
happen on the Roblox side that it's just
too much money there and if if the this
will be fixed by this time next month
probably man if it isn't fixed by this
time next week I would be surprised um
so yeah that's it I mean again it's
Roblox and it's it's everywhere as it
should be shout out to King for finding
these very yeah that's news news we work
hard at K&N news to bring you the best
in PlayStation slander so before we
check out let's talk about these
consoles yeah yeah let's talk about the
the real time we thought we should have
been talking about yeah let's talk about
these conses fs5 Slims yeah we got we
got the announcements who is who was was
it Tom Warren who initially talked about
Henderson Henderson Tom Henderson
Henderson yeah so Tom Henderson
originally said that the these were real
and um yeah it turns out that they are
shout out to Tom Henderson um yeah so we
got two new SKS once again of
PlayStation we have a PS5 um are they
calling them Slims is that what they're
calling them or because it'll be the new
PlayStation 5 they're not calling them
Slims they're calling them new
PlayStations the new PlayStations so new
PlayStation take over the skew or
something like right the old skew is
going to go right
discontinued
yeah love how King just loves using the
most negative language
possible
de put on Ice put on
Ice put on permanent ice put on ice so
yeah the so the new consoles are
supposed to be 30% uh
smaller um which in comparisons that
I've seen so far kind of holds true um
we were we are
getting essentially there is one
model and that one model comes it can
come with a disc drive that that comes
off right for the old $500 that you were
used to pay now you got to say it like
that if you if you want the Digital
model up front
though it will be an increase in price
for what
$50 from the current Digital model
because because said Digital model is
going to be modular in that that if you
decide someday you want to add the disc
drive to it that will be an additional
what $50 or something to that
end that's $80 that's $80
$79.95 for the for the extra drive right
yes right in addition to that in
addition to that they are only giving
you they are only giving you a
horizontal stand with these PlayStations
now they are smaller than than they were
before right little horizontal stand so
they giving you a horizontal stand that
looks like a paperclip um oh you talk
about the little leg the
little the little kick stand if you want
to place it vertically as I have
done that's an extra 30 bucks for you so
um no it's
not
it's 40 bucks like a hecky going wait
wait where's it 40 bucks it's $ 39.99 oh
damn okay $40 so yeah um PlayStation in
this theyve managed to do what I don't
think any company has ever done when it
comes to a midgen refresh of their
console is
that you what you usually do is you come
in if there's like a slim version or
whatever well it's a cheaper price right
or if you come in just with a remodeling
well you immediately drop the original
model in price and $30 I'm seeing on the
site right it's right it's it's 30
that's what I oh sorry I was giving you
EUR price yeah you always throw exra mny
we
know I was giving you the Bangladesh
prices banges
prices price is highest now I'm going to
hear 20 people say IOP gives nothing but
misinformation information oh yeah you
inform I got the right information you
ain't getting it in the
box
so um so again they committed what I
kind of think is a cardinal sin in this
is that you kind of the new model comes
in at if you want to maintain Price
Right the new model comes in at the old
skew price it takes it over and then you
discount whatever stock you have of the
older model and that you know that that
usually drives your Christmas sales and
whatever because everybody's trying to
liquidate that stuff and you get it at a
better price and the other stuff the
newer stuff that has whatever you know
better power usage uh in this case more
storage slightly more storage like aund
and something more gigs of storage or
whatever the case may
be um that's it but theyve said no we're
literally we're literally giving you
less
conso for a higher price
um and and we're we're we're dipping our
toe into this digital future that we
know is inevitable but if you want to go
to that digital future 100% with
PlayStation you going to pay you're
going to pay um I it's just not there's
nothing about this that feels good the
redesign they just shrunk it they they
paid no attention to the fact that most
people despise this this console design
um yeah it it was very meh all the way
around so what do you gentlemen think of
the new
PlayStations addict stuffers it they pay
lot
of I just got to the point with
PlayStation are you
surprised like like he's sitting there
like oh I can't believe they're doing
this
really like it's like I think the odds
of of PlayStation straighten up their uh
the way they're thinking right now
there's a no better odds of not
releasing broken games these days like
it's like PlayStation they just they're
like oh they love
us
you know the PlayStation's not okay with
having you know a wife and a mistress
they want a wife a mistress a mistress
two a mistress three and mistress four
and they gonna make and they're they're
not catering to you they're not whining
and dining you you're GNA whine and dine
them they got a herum yo what's crazy
what's crazy is you go from one month
that they released uh they increase the
prices of all PlayStation Plus by
30% then the next month Jim Ryan leaves
then the month after that now the price
of the console's going
up the second time they did that with
that console though well the first time
was a little different CU it wasn't in
the states it was everywhere else but
this one's everywhere so if you want to
play a digital version it's like one
would think they would try to close that
gap between the Xbox series s but it
seems like they've truly lost their mind
and they're like you know what if if we
go we gonna make them pay if they will
and that's why I'm saying man you know I
didn't see too many I didn't see no
article saying this was horrible I
didn't see too many people making videos
about this I literally saw a gaming
industry that accepted it so it's just
like I I I I get what we gonna do
like yes it's been it's been the uh the
talk this week you didn't see much on it
like what adct was saying you didn't see
too many people talk about it but um I
mean I think I shouldn't say too many
but people are upset about it I agree
with him on that um King you already got
your bars off or should I no I didn't
okay your
bars yes oh my God so y'all talk about
the the roof isn't falling in on you yes
it is oh hey hey King King doc said it's
all Game Pass his
fault and I believe so they gonna get
y'all anyway they gonna get y'all they
said we gonna lose yo Jim said here's my
Parton gift to you
dud how the hell see the PlayStation
digital launched that was it was it$
3.99 it was
$3.99 right so he said remember that $50
deal that he gave he said I'mma get my
$50 back I'm get my $50 back we GNA
shrink this jint and we're gonna charge
him $50 more why all right so
technically let's let if you want to
keep the numbers same and King King is
wor remember they they they split the
little sides that you already bought so
those don't work anymore so you already
bought the stuff you already bought the
covers yeah you already bought the
covers you locked yeah you went in and
you purchased all your little covers and
your stuff and you was dope you was like
yeah I got my joint so if they come out
with the next joint no your joint do not
work for this and that's that's cool
that's cool you locked in they're going
to discontinue the joint that you love
they got to get it off the market
because that comes with the stand we
can't have free stuff out there that
gota go how they gonna take the thing
they gave y'all cuz they forced y'all to
either stand it up or lay it down
Microsoft joint can lay down on the side
it can stand up you don't need nothing
extra in the box there you go go get it
yeah I saw the little kickstand little
plastic uh glass slipper the little
Cinderella
glass yo then they going to penalize you
this little $12 disc drive that they
getting out out out in the Philippines
that they putting that they putting in
the box they're charging you
$80 this is not the the best
top-of-the-line HD Drive Blu-ray Drive
that they're putting on the side how is
your cheaper version actually going to
cost more than your base version that
comes with everything this is the most
egregious stuff they raising everything
across the boards they raising the
services they putting Cloud through a
pay wall if you don't have premium you
don't get Cloud y'all talking about
cloud like now all of a sudden yall love
Cloud
streaming now Cloud streaming is oh this
is the wave the cloud the cloud is got
to be the
thing everything has been raised they
have blocked the prices as far as you're
not going to have a lower cost of Entry
no actually they raised the cost on
everything for you dudes and y'all don't
see this as a bad practice nobody talked
about this nobody talked about you're G
to get a slim and you're G to pay more
this is the first time in gaming history
that consoles in a later cycle has gone
up in
price we have this this is the part
where they supposed to save money they
told you a while ago that they were
making money off of every PlayStation
sold they told you that now that they're
selling the PlayStations at a profit but
instead of saying okay we we reduce the
footprint we reduce materials we reduce
productivity cost and Manufacturing
cost they instead of giving you the
discount and dropping them by $50 they
kept the status quo at $4.99 and raise
the digital at 50 gave you a bunch of
peripherals that go with it that
normally that you get in the Box for
free they charging you for it and they
raised a service and they told you get
ready for the cloud but in order for you
to get in the cloud you got to get in
that $40 premium service that we put
over here
extra when are you going to see that
they're giving you nothing and taking
everything from you at a higher cost you
got got to stop being a fool at some
point in time but y'all ain't say
nothing about this slim so I can't wait
for it to come out but I'mma keep my fat
PlayStation in the back because she
comes with a
stand and I like her like that I like a
[Music]
little she come with
everything oh man yeah this is look not
surprised at all you know this is part
for the course as far as the economics
and I'm knowing base I mean me
personally yeah they they've gotten away
with a lot this generation you know
obviously they they they've rise raised
the price of the console you know
obviously 70 $70 games was something
they introduced initially you know what
I mean was one of the ones they were
pioneering you know how I feel about the
nickel and Diamond you know with the
past generation upgrades and you know
instead of there being a smart delivery
it's like oh pay this to to get the
features I don't like the idea of the uh
REM Masters all the time that's just me
personally it's just way too many but
all of it doesn't matter what I
think because as comy [__] I know how
they move and you know what they say
you're going to buy it anyway and you
do so all this talking dudes will run
out there and get the new slim with all
the trimmings and all the and they will
buy a new set of covers because they
know their base their base is loyal
their base continues to go out and by
despite any shyy practices they will do
it and and I can I get mad at them for
that not really I mean it is what it is
I just feel that I will say the thing
that it Justified for me is that cuz I I
forgot who I was arguing with someone
was like yo everybody was mad at Xbox
because when the snitching came out when
they were like about the consoles and we
found out that they're not doing a mid
generation refresh so everybody was like
yo oh you know how they going to do that
and then yo PS5 Pro H how remember they
said the the cloud what was the name of
it the code name I forgot the code name
but remember the hybrid console right it
was a code name for it and then they
were like yo how they going to have no
no excuse me the um the slim the slim
version of the Xbox one I mean series
Xbox series X was it Brook was that
Brooklyn Brooklyn right or whatever it
was right so they say how the Brooklyn
going to be 500 when we know a PS5 Pro
is coming cuz Tom Henderson right we
know his his reporting is on fire he
called this slim thing a long time ago
so I was like you sure it's going to be
$500 because Microsoft must know as well
so if they're five and now we know that
this is going to stay you know five or
whatever that means the PS5 Pro is not
$500 to me in my opinion six or whatever
right so that shows that the other thing
is like you know with the decision again
with the u m regeneration refresh so so
we'll see how that works out but they
know that their their base does buy I
will say something though King ain't
going to
like to me when they Dro this is my
opinion I could be wrong when the series
X and the S was announced we saw two
skes it was like all right boom we
understood what Microsoft was doing $500
console then you know we get the $300
joint you get the Lesser person in on on
the back end
remember when PlayStation had their
announced stairs they did two SKS but
with the digital if we remember was kind
of hard to find yeah it was kind of like
low so I've always felt that the digital
was always a last minute thing okay this
is what we doing we GNA compete with you
in that space we can't let you have a
you know what I'm saying completely not
even though they don't got the lowest
skew we got a lower skew right so that
if people did flock to the S we protect
it a little bit that's how I felt the
mentality of of of the PlayStation 5
launch now this tells me based on their
success how much Hardware they're
selling we don't care what you do you
know what's worse c yeah I I think it's
even a little bit beyond that I think
they're going to try to artificially
raise the price of a physical version
because what they're going to do is
they're going to print more digitals and
if you well obviously they're going to
get more digital and when you want that
that hard drive you you have to buy the
individual piece in now like so they
they're going to be like okay here's the
digital for 400 or 5 450
now we want 80 on top of that 450 if you
want a physical version because it used
to be five you would get the physical
but now you got to pay 550 to get a
physical look at at the end of the day I
think they look at themselves in a
category all their own they are the the
Elite Performance Brand and we don't we
don't compete with you to me that it's a
cck you're not even worried about what
the sence to now to King's Point this
could be a critical mistake because of
what's going on with ABK in the future
you know whatever but the mentality of
what they're telling me right now by
this action is you are not on our level
we do what we want to do and our base is
going to be our base and we just got to
see how it plays out but in their
defense everything to this point their
base has bought and is not fought back
that's not true they they have not
brought the PlayStation V all right true
true true they did not and we don't know
what the portable the portal going to
look like uh as far as that go right um
I I think that their base is finally
understanding that they're being gouged
I I think this is it I think they're
making a turn the Worm but will they
take a stand though like I don't see it
when the new Spiderman come out and
dude's going to forget they they to me
Sony's one trailer away from everybody
forgetting all of this when they see
Wolverine and they see Spidey they see
whatever yo we forgot that we paid off
they're going to take a stance um when
they see what happen happens The Game
Pass it's it's really what they do they
like to pocket watch that their team
likes to look over and see what you're
doing what you're eating what's going on
what you brought to lunch and stuff like
that so their team is not really Forward
Thinking yeah they they play Spider-Man
for five hours and that'll go away and
then they they'll be on to the next
looking into your pocket again trying to
figure out what's going on over there so
once they see a consistent flow of games
inside Game Pass they're going to leave
that um that area over there in droves
it's just seeing what's going on on the
other side defense that's all and to be
honest with you I don't think it's
anything that Sony's going to do as far
as keep them there they're not going to
be stuck there and it's not going to be
those one player single player games it
has to be games that's going to keep
them consistently playing and I don't
see any of those games on the horizon
actually I don't see anything on the
horizon I mean we got to see they still
got the brand recognition they still got
the name power you know we'll see we'll
see that's all I got to say but yeah
definitely I'm glad we did it talk about
it cuz it was something that broke this
week but that's all I got unless I got
anything else oh I want to give a shout
out to Jay is uh jonty
2992 he got the game uh it was uh EA
Sports
fc24 oh okay and uh it was a complete
version that so have a great time
playing that and I'm so happy that you
got a chance to get it and I'm so happy
that you watched the whole show in order
to get the code and I would like to give
codes away in that manner so that way we
know that you watch the show you was
there for every topic and you stuck
around and only the truly the one got it
as opposed to dudes copying and pasting
and see who's the fastest to get it down
the fastest copy and paser I'm I'm happy
that you got the game no doubt no doubt
you want me to get the poll or you want
to get Super Chat so these are the last
few super chats real quick uh NC ghost
of low road $5 Super Chat good evening
Lords I'm in late watching on replay
right now y'all are the best and your
Vibe is contagious Advance the line
blessings Tracy Brothers is that vric
brothers from uh cyber punks of the
joint the termbase shout out the out if
that's y'all in the in the chat like
those
developers then we got hary chan $10
Super Chat the $50 increases to handle
the kickstand at PlayStation great the
PlayStation graciously includes with the
console so you can put it on its side
PlayStation should appreciate the
quality of the Microsoft clippy stand
yes it is the Microsoft clippy stand
included with every PlayStation um then
we got John Wolf $2 Super Chat don't
worry PlayStation Nation clippy holding
it up for you oh man messy very messy
that's it oh it is hold on it is th
Brothers hey it's it's us two days until
cyber nights flash point launches can't
no doubt salute to the Tes brother adct
those are our turn breaks brothers we um
we covered that game yeah the robbing
game or it was the Heist game you it was
yeah it was uh cyber Heist nice flash
point turn base hot Heist joint we got a
chance to get some codes early we give
it our thoughts I have their little
pamphlet here for like a longest time oh
you still got it from back then let me
see let me see we go we go shout out the
homies this turn this turn based
gang all see there we go we play these
games y'all we go to these shows we play
these games shout out to Cy Cy night's
flasho go check that out should be two
days before release you know your game
caught my attention if I kept anything
from yeah adct kept it I'm going tell
you right now if adct kept it it means
something I moved twice since then he
moved twice since then so yeah yo he
said he said holy ish y'all still got
it yes we are turn based for real we do
this salute to that man Simon Simon I on
flash white going to be out there inore
he's giving you a St in Ovation by the
way adct I just want to shout you out
hit me up on Twitter man hit me up on
Twitter yeah let's go Adam let add we
add our devs as a a little moderator but
then I'll get the um uh poll if we good
um sof
all good okay cool no doubt all right
new IP poll with Microsoft finally
closing the deal in acquiring ABK into
Xbox game studios and the rumors that
they are not done acquiring Studios who
do you think Xbox should acquire next I
wish Tom was here for this one hey no
one Xbox has enough Studios
consolidation is bad for the
industry B sea
bring them over here C addict Square
edict or D third charm third time is the
charm baby Nintendo we want you and we
going to have you you just don't know it
yet those are the choices booty
style check out the when it goes up when
I remember hopefully I'm not
hospitalized to to put it up and uh
again shout out to everybody who hit me
up just check and see I was doing
everything but it was a it was a
scheduled procedure so I'm doing good
but uh let's get our shout outs Lord
addict where can find people find what
you got going on Sir follow me on
Twitter Lord addict ILP find me on
YouTube at gaming addict so you know
it's funny I had like a really like a
really spicy video messy video I was
going to post but every day last week
there was some Xbox news I had to cover
in set of it uh so hopefully that will
come out Monday yeah I noticed man I
noticed Cog King yes
and know there's a reason that
PlayStation fans talk about Xbox more
because they ain't never any PlayStation
news about that man it's like if you're
a strictly PlayStation content creator
it's rough in these streets for you man
it's rough no I give you that cuz they
don't have no leaks either yeah I would
see why you you would have to talk about
Xbox what else you gonna talk
about so y uh shout out to we had 16,700
people in the chat today uh we have 9 12
people of a thousand come on let's get
that over a thousand for the the show
there there's 80 90 people well actually
88 people ain't like this podcast yet I
know they ain't up but regardless if we
get over a thousand I appreciate for
coming through here I do want to address
something I saw in the chat earlier but
I wanted to leave so I wasn't really
trying to like s that up no me and car
gonna have beef relax we what's funny is
we every time there's any type of like
disag dis disagreement to anyone
especially me C for some reason always
people feel like like oh they beefing no
we've had way seriouser conversations
that that's my brother we we went at
each other over Destiny multiple times
MTI multiple times we've yelled at each
other way worse that's just how that's
my brother we are very passionate when
we on and you know how we know this how
you know when we good when we just say
we just gonna agree to disagree and we
just Mo it's not that I'm saying that
because it's like there's beef and I'm
mad I'm saying that because it's like
okay clearly this conversation's not
going it's not productive but I guess
people sit there like ad you weren't
talking yet cuz I didn't know what to
say so I was like you know what let's
just move on facts that's how real
brothers do
continue yeah but appreciate for coming
through man uh we had a pretty engaging
conversation which we knew we did
definitely caught that that'll hold the
line and Advance the line t-shirts man
you know we might do something in the
future with that I don't know yeah but I
appreciate we're coming through by the
way if we was beefing we'd have to use
this Emoji that's real
beef what's the I can't look at screen
look that's what we beefing when you see
that I'm going to be real I like the I I
like the original design you like the
original with the J with the I liked
when you had like the tomahawk and you
look like you just biting that off the
bon no no we just trying to make it work
shout out to the young Dre shout out to
grabing off for the update no doubt yeah
but appreciate for coming through uh I'm
going to send you guys over to let's see
who be sending you
to uh just keep going until I figure it
out salute Lord son W can to find people
find you what you got going on Sir uh
yeah could find me uh playing Mirage
this week up until uh I can't I was I
was mysteriously going to uh get sick on
Friday but we already have too many
people out I already know the list of
people that going to be out so I can't
so I have to hold my head so I will be
playing uh uh probably playing Mario on
Friday at work um uh yeah it sounds so
bad I'm gonna be playing Mario at
work G be playing with Mario at work
yeah exactly playing with Mario at work
and uh that's it yeah but shout out to
everybody for coming through shout out
to Tom Warren salute salute yeah and Je
for those ask jez couldn't make it
something did come up last minute he
feels bad we see if we can try to get
him on next week but he has something
that came up so shout out to JZ cin
window Central no doubt he we got two
actually two super chats let me just
read them quickly okay before they K we
we got Jason with the
$30.99 Australian dollar superent Super
Chat uh let's go champ Big Love from
Australia just tuned in shout out to you
sir salute Aussie in the building void
lock member for 21 months Lord bronze by
team ninja WB and Sega bung's Xbox
trojan horse for son putting games on
Ice
yo we caught up yes sir and salute to
the Advance the line movement on Friday
the
13th you know the we didn't get the
general but we got a whole bunch of
characters salute to uh King David's uh
assortment of villains Friday 13
villains Jason and now Michael my w to
five people find you sir you can find me
behind every Sony dude
pause I'll be hunting you for the
evening for the rest of this month
you're on the menu Bessie I'm got to eat
you up with some Faber
beans and a little bit of Ky
ridiculous yo you can catch me on
Twitter acting the fool you do I'mma do
what I do to
you I can't be stopped just like these
these these these wild characters that I
brought out Michael Myers can't be
stopped Jason can't be St I don't know
man I I I don't know King Michael Myers
got got got some work uh what was that
dude that dude showed up there whooped
him took his mask and left that cave but
it'll definitely be another
movie so I I like to say uh
thank you for the ABK deal thank you for
holding the line thank youall for
advancing the line make sure youall pick
up those shirt there is going to be a
moment in time
again until next time try to stay in the
daylight no doubt Lord Co here for this
momentous occasion y know y was waiting
for the messiness I knew it was coming
salute to King Falls ESP again salute to
Tom Warren for coming through dropping
us the information obviously been like
it's hot droing it like it's hot all the
all the greatest information this man
was ahead of it we here man finally you
know who this day you know a lot of
people didn't think it would happen it
did ended up happening and now we see
what happened another Monumental day in
gaming and look you know there are there
are a group that is excited about what's
to see what the future is going forward
and um I thought it was cool I thought
it was cool that um like I said he came
through and then again shout out to jez
we try to get him next week shout out to
everybody that pulled up a lot of yall
th000 plus the love is felt is
tremendous really respected and U thanks
for listening to all sides of opinions
even when we disagree so I still respect
y'all but that's all I got solv anything
else before we get up out of here
anybody else uh let me see we got
Spartan uh 6615 Super Chat uh the new
PS5 is required to have a fire
extinguisher nearby don't leave it on uh
using the PS portable Port is not the
portable the portal unless you're close
by AKA local
wow best you all the way through that's
all I got everybody else adct we good
yeah I think I'm going to send you guys
over to legendary drop so they're like
the only people I can send you to F but
he don't go live for 25 minutes so like
I can't send you guys somewhere that
ain't live but I appreciate every com
through definitely go in there put ILP
raid I'mma go in there I'mma watch you
guys I want ILP raid all in that chat
and then hit that like button no doubt
everybody enjoy we about
it you're ridiculous
[Music]
w